so, hallo leute, auf gehts, warum gehen meine corona emotes nicht, ich glaub die haben die
corona emotes entfernt, kann das sein, ich hab gestern, ich hab gestern drei, die gehen echt, gehen die bei
euch, weil bei mir im browser gehen die nicht, stimmt, ich sehe sie in meiner vorschau, in meiner vorschau gehen die,
aber leute chat, ich sehe euch jetzt mal kurz nicht, ich refresche mal, twitch chat unbeobachtet lassen
ist gefährlich, ich weiß, ach jetzt, ah, exzellent, jetzt funktioniert's, weiß auch nicht was da war, was da gewesen ist
ich hab mir so gedacht, aus aktuellem anlass, müssen wir mal da ein paar, so aktuelle geschehen, die wir uns einfügen
wie siehts eigentlich mit corona in hessen aus, hab ich jetzt gar nicht mehr geguckt, corona hessen, gibts da was neues, news
oh, frankfurt, oje, leute, muss morgen wieder nach frankfurt, oje, rip, rip, f, aiaio, aber, stripes 107, acht monate, huge sub
frage an den chat, funktioniert origins bei euch, kann ich jetzt nicht ausprobieren, oje, corona hessen, frankfurt, oje, frankfurt, zeigst mal her, was ist in frankfurt los
frankfurt, leute, hab ich euch schon gesagt, ich hab's ja, ich hab's ja auf twitter und im discord geschrieben, ich hatte vorgestern, oder gestern, die nacht, die nacht auf gestern
hatte ich die ganze nacht einen extrem trockenen hals, das ist ja meistens so die vorstufe von, easy killer 5 monate, dankeschön
hi iq chat wieder, also zeig mal her, um 23.45 kam das gestern, es handelt sich um drei männer aus frankfurt, aha, okay die waren irgendwie zusammen mit einem in italien, na wunderbar, das beruhigt mich jetzt natürlich wahnsinnig
aber leute, ist ja kein problem mehr, weil ich hab ja eine, wend, ich hab's ja gestern auf twitter gepostet, ich hab ja meine, ich hab ja mein metro cosplay wieder rausgekramt, der spiegelung von mir sieht, kann sie überhalten
irgendwo ist da bestimmt eine spiegelung, huge mask, ja komm, wenn du schon sowas hast, wenn du schon sowas hast, dann kannst du jetzt immer wieder rauskramen, also ihr seht, ich hab das ding noch nicht verwendet, es ist noch original verpackt
und die filter sind gültig bis zum, bis was, märz 2024, also die hält noch ein bisschen, aber ohne aus, was interessiert mich denn, ob ich leute anstecke, hauptsache ich steck mich nicht selber an
willst du damit schon ein, nein, quatsch, aber ich hab sie, ich hab mir die gar nicht für die corona geschichte gekauft, ich hab die schon, also nicht so lang, aber ich hab die schon ein bisschen, ich weiß gar nicht, wann ich die gekauft hab, da müsst ihr schon mal bei amazon gucken, ich sag mal
also irgendwie, keine ahnung, zwei monate oder drei monate, also noch bevor das ganze corona zeug angerückt ist und mein hauptgedanke dazu war, warum ich mir sowas gekauft hab, wenn man mal beispielsweise eine schimmel wegmachen muss oder irgendwelches andere heimwerker zeug hat, sei es von irgendwie staub, feinstaub, chemikalien, schimmel, sonst was, dann ist es manchmal nicht verkehrt, wenn man das mal irgendwie eine stunde machen muss, wenn man den kram nicht gerade einatmet
so, aber jetzt, das sind nämlich auch filter, die gegen viren helfen, zum beispiel sieht man nämlich hier dran, das sind p3r filter und p3r, da gibt es irgendwie so ein ranking, was wie vor welchen filtern schützt und p3r filter
man kriegt schon virus mit, ist auch gegen viren geeignet, ja, hab ich noch mal glück, ich könnte die jetzt natürlich verkaufen und wenn ich die jetzt verkaufe, krieg ich wahrscheinlich das zehnfache von dem, was ich dafür ausgegeben hab
also die war nicht billig, die hat damals schon um die 200 euro oder 150, irgendwas zwischen 150 und 200 euro gekostet, also das ist jetzt kein absolutes billig ding, deswegen hoffe ich, die ist dis made in uk, das ist auch keine china maske oder so, also die ist glaube ich qualitativ ganz ok
glückliche fügung, da ich so einen teil schon hab, weil wahrscheinlich kriegste sowas gar nicht, oh das scam train ist am start, huge
heimwerker, ich dachte, du bist fertig mit deiner buddhi, man ist nie fertig, man ist nie fertig, vor allem nicht, wenn es um automatisierung geht und irgendwelche sachen in der richtung, dann ist man nie fertig
pilzschema, das passt ja grad, wo ich gesagt hab, ich hab mir ne maske gegen schimmel gekauft, kommt der pilz, pilzschema stufe eins, dankeschön, für den nicht prime sub, für den richtig echten big brain real sub
kannst du jetzt auch mal pirate bay runterladen, den virens scanner, ja das findest du stimmt, max wird bald zu artium, ist artium nicht tot, ich weiß, der ist in jedem metro spiel dabei, aber ich glaub, der ist am ende vom ersten teil noch gestorben, ich weiß gar nicht wie das, egal, ich hab nur den ersten teil gespielt
machete, machete brauch ich nicht, ich hab immer noch mein speer an der treppe liegen, falls jemand einbricht, hab ich euch das ding eigentlich schonmal gezeigt, nee, ich glaub, doch, ich hab mal ein bild von gezeigt im stream, allerdings nicht von dem speer, sondern von dem teil, was neben an der treppe liegt
es ist ja kein wirklicher speer, den ich neben an der treppe liegen hab, ich hab neben an der treppe, nur für den fall der fälle, dass man wirklich sich irgendjemand zutritt hier in die wohnung verschafft und irgendwas isst man, sag mal so, besser vorgesorgt als hinterher doof aus der wäsche geguckt, ich hab von nem zauen, von nem alten zauen, gar nicht wie sowas heißt
ja, ungefähr sowas, plus nicht so verziertes, einfach nur lang und spitz, einfach nur spitz, also ohne irgendwelche sachen drauf, sowas hier in der richtung hab ich, gibts da irgendwas schönes, also ich hab ohne verzierung so ein ding, einfach nur spitz und irgendwie so 1,5 meter lang oder so
oder was ist das, nee, eher 2 meter lang und äh, wenn da einer reinkommt und nix zu suchen hat, gibts in your face, geh so morgens mal auf die arbeit, mags ernst, hast du damit schon, achso, hab ich ja schon mal vor einkaufen gegangen, nee, nee, bin ich nicht, also ich muss eigentlich auch gar nicht einkaufen, weil ich hab eh immer einen halben schrank voller nudel, da isst genug da
ja, also wie sahs jetzt mit corona in hessen aus, ist, ist, ist am start, na gut, dann versorgen wir uns mal mit youtube videos dazu
haha, airflow96, meine baren beweggründe hat ihr das hier baro gestern auf twitter schon rausgekriegt
foxy, twitch prime, 4 monate, huge sub, wenn man sich jetzt noch 20bar verklickt, danke schön, der iq des chats steigt heute echt ins unermessliche, seh ich schon
du hast ein bayonett im schlafzimmer, kann man alles machen, seitdem ich mir so ein multitool auf amazon gekauft habe, so ein ding hier in der richtung, wenn man noch nicht genau weiß was man für werkzeug braucht, ist sowas bestimmt nicht schlecht wenn man sowas dabei hat
also im prinzip ist es so eine art taschenmesser, seitdem ich mir das bestellt hab, so ich glaub das hier, weiß gar nicht genau, nee meins hat ein bisschen größeres messer, ja ich find es jetzt nicht, seitdem empfiehlt mir amazon die ganze zeit irgendwelche waffen und exe und tactical equipment, dabei hab ich überhaupt keine verwendung für, was soll ich mit einer taktischen axt
tactical tomahawk, max wird zum jäger, man weiß ja nie was in nächster zeit so passiert, vielleicht muss ich mit der armbrust in den wald gehen und jagen, ne armbrust hab ich, jetzt hab ich auch das passende multitool, da kann er jetzt in wald stelsen gehen
ne ich hab wirklich nen schrank, weil ich halt nicht gern einkaufen gehe, ich hab nen schrank, da liegen halt aktuell, was sind das so 20 packen nudeln oder so drinnen, die halten ja ewig
die survival ax stimmt, wer weiß jetzt, weiß ja nicht was alle so passieren, ich hab mich ja schon gefragt, ob nicht heute von der arbeit irgendwie ne mail kommt, dass die leuten empfohlen wird, die man soll am montag home office machen, der witz ist ja, normalerweise, ihr wisst ja, normalerweise geh ich montags gar nicht arbeiten
trickshots, klar, also sollte ich mit der armbrust jagen gehen, dann erschieß ich nicht im wald einfach irgendwelche wildschweine oder so zum essen, sondern mach erstmal den 360 swiffer scope davor, nur weil das ding hatte überhaupt keinen scope, was kann man denn dann machen, wenn es keinen scope hat
mail von der uni kam schon, dass keiner kommen soll, oder, da gehts aber ab, in welchem bundesland bist du, einramintgo, was fange man an
ich guck gerade mal, ich hab mein handy nicht hier, sonst würd ich mal gucken, ob irgendwie auf der arbeit einer ne mail geschrieben hat, aber man sieht das, also bei mir in der ecke ist es schon am start, du hast ein level 1 hype train emote erhalten, das scam train war erfolgreich
dudel sind auch easy zuzubereiten, also das einzige, wo ich echt gelitten hab bei mir daheim ist, wenn der strom ausfällt, ich hab keinen generator oder irgendwie, was kosten sowas
keine ahnung, generator, benzin, was kosten sowas, ich hab keine ahnung, der hält aber nicht lange, cute chat ist am start, der kiyokone ist am start, der cute tenmorken, aus interesse mal gucken
achso in düsseldorf, ok, düsseldorf ist ja in der nähe von köln und da ist ja überall auch ganz viel fasching angesagt gewesen, da haben sich die leute wahrscheinlich alle angesteckt
ich find das auch so geil, ne, erst alle großartig fasching feiern und jetzt kommt halt raus, dass die meisten coronafälle halt sich an fasching angesteckt haben, wo ich mir so gedacht hab, hm, da hätte man ja auch gar nicht drauf kommen können, dass auf so einer veranstaltung, wo die leute alle auf einem haufen sitzen, dass man sich da anstecken kann, das ist absolut, das wäre im vorfeld, im vorfeld hätte man sich das nicht denken können
die intellect stream masters spielen jetzt auch ohne publikum, ja ich weiß, das ist auch schon sehr merkwürdig wohl, für die spieler auch
komm, wir fangen mit battlefield an, wir fangen mit ein bisschen battlefield an, so zum einstimmen, ja, hast du blackout gelesen oder gehört, ne, hab ich nicht
ja, so einen major ohne publikum zu gewinnen ist schon kacke, also ein major zu verlieren ist ohne publikum auch kacke, aber gerade wenn man sich, die events sind jetzt, also die majors sind jetzt ja auch nicht jede woche eins, auch wenn cs go so groß wie nie ist
also cs, deswegen ist cs go aktuell auch so mein lieblings e-spot, den ich gucke, du kannst eigentlich jedes wochenende einschalten aus irgendeinem turnier, jetzt zwar, jetzt zwar kein riesen, riesen ding unbedingt, aber du hast, also du hast ja unter der woche schon normale, normale turniere, du hast am wochenende meistens ein bisschen was größeres und ab und zu halt irgendwelche großen sachen, ist kein cs go major mehr, aber trotzdem spielen wahrscheinlich die ganzen leute da, die ganzen großen teams, aber
also das einzige cs go turnier, wo ich offline war, war in köln, in, ist das die lanxess arena oder wie das ding heißt, weiß gar nicht mehr genau was das war, es war in esl 1, esl ich hab doch da ein video zu gemacht
ja esl 1 cologne, genau, das ist das einzige turnier, wo ich mal offline gewesen bin, das war schon nice, das war schon nice und das beste an der ganzen sache war ja, dass wir von asus eingeladen waren, das heißt man konnte auch
entspannt oben sitzen und zugucken, inklusive, inklusive verflegung, das war natürlich huge, huge brain, das war schon ganz angenehm und das war mal cool mitzukriegen, öfters, öfters müsste ich jetzt nicht unbedingt auf irgendwelche offline events, weil so cool das ist immer atmosphäre und alles mitzukriegen, muss ich sagen
entspannender und irgendwie besser zuzugucken ist es daheim vom fernseher oder vom rechner, aber mein atmosphäre ist, da kannst du nicht damit vergleichen, wie wenn du daheim sitzt, aber trotzdem, angenehmer zugucken ist es von daheim
ja gestern war fast ne millionen spieler, ich weiß, ich hab's gestern gesehen hier, steams, stats, csgo, oder vor 2 tagen war das glaube ich schon
guckt euch das mal an, mehr als dota, mehr als pupke, das ist noch nicht so lang, das ist noch nicht so lang, also vor einem jahr sah das noch ein bisschen anders aus, cs hat ziemlich einen aufschwung gehabt wieder
gibt's nicht mal steams stats, was ist denn die seite, steams stats hieß die doch oder, oder bring ich das jetzt durcheinander, oder was steam, steam charts, ach das da, ja genau das meine ich, hieß das nicht früher steam stats
ja die cs, die cs stonks gehen hoch, guckt euch das mal an, innerhalb von einem jahr, die sind wieder, genau vor einem jahr waren die noch ein bisschen weiter unten, aber allgemein muss man halt sagen, ist cs halt hier, ich weiß nicht wo sie die skins und den ganzen shit eingeführt haben, aber ab da ist wahrscheinlich hier so und ab da ist es halt
free to play, ist das jetzt free to play, ja das kann, dann legt das auf jeden fall daran, dass es free to play wurde, aber es ist halt heftig zu sehen auch wie viele leute zugucken, ja
skins waren seit anfang 2014, da passt doch hier ab, hier ist dann, ui, rauf, hier so in dem dreh, hat man irgendwie so ein bisschen den untergang von cs go vorausgesagt und das hat auch ein bisschen das interesse nachgelassen, aber spielerzahlen mäßig war der eindruck halt falsch, hier ging es ein bisschen runter
aber ab da, ich weiß nicht ab wann, free to play, ab wann das free to play geworden ist, ab wann ist das free to play geworden, wisst ihr das, Mitte 2019 irgendwann ne, also wahrscheinlich hier so, wahrscheinlich hier so wo es wieder direkt hochgegangen ist, wahrscheinlich hier, hier war es, hier haben sie bestimmt handschuhe, hier kam bestimmt die handschuhe oder irgendwie sowas, wo die leute ja voll drauf abgehen
irgendwie cosmetics ist so ein ding, ähm, mich wird die faszination von cosmetics in game nie, wenn ich nie so hundertprozentig nachvollziehen könnte, ich mein ich hab in overwatch auch skins gesammelt und in passive exile hab ich mir auch ein paar skins gekauft, aber in passive exile hab ich mir hauptsächlich ein paar skins gekauft, weil die default rüstung und die default charakter und so, die sehen halt richtig scheiße aus
hier der battle royale, das suck, ne, aber zumindest seitdem ist es halt wieder voll abgegangen hier, und jetzt ist es wieder ein bisschen getroppt, warum auch immer
achso, das ist der monat, ja gut, weil der monat hier gewechselt hat, aber ist schon heftig ey, echt hart, wie das, wie cs immer noch abgeht, man darf ja nicht vergessen, dass es ein game ist, was irgendwann so mal als mod, weiß nicht wann die erste version rausgekommen ist
so 99 müsste das sein, ich mein half life 1 ist glaub ich 98 rausgekommen, dann ungefähr ein jahr später, cs 0 irgendwas, das erste cs was ich damals gespielt hab war 0.5.2 glaub ich, und damals, kann ich mir auch dran erinnern, damals waren, ganz am anfang waren die demolition maps gar nicht so beliebt, da haben alle geiselrettung gespielt
und assault war eine der meist gespielten maps, das kann man sich heute überhaupt nicht mehr vorstellen, da konnte man auch, ich war ja der übelste kack noob, und ich hab dann immer damals mit der scout bei assault auf dem dach gekämpft, wo man in den luftschacht, oder wo der luftschacht reingeht und rauskommt, schon die pro strats am start gehabt damals
italy, ja aber italy kam später, italy kam später, militia hat man damals auch viel gespielt, diese komische häuser map, mit dem tunnel, ich glaub ich weiß gar nicht ob es die maps heute überhaupt noch gibt, und es war auch so, ich kann das ja aus erster hand noch berichten, weil ich war ja dabei
als dust 2 rausgekommen ist, und dust 2 ist ja eine der langlebigsten und immer noch gespieltesten maps in dem game überhaupt, und die leute haben übelst dust 2 gehated als das rausgekommen ist, als es neu war, die haben alle gesagt, dust 2 braucht kein mensch, dust 1 beste, und jetzt spielt keiner mehr dust 1
hast du auch früher wolf team gespielt, was war denn wolf team, war das das unreal cs, war wolf team das unreal cs, oder es gab ja auch noch, es gab ja noch so einen cs-ähnlichen mod für unreal tournament, ich weiß aber nicht mehr wie das heißt, das war damals auch relativ beliebt, aber ich hab keine ahnung mehr wie das ding genau hieß, cs hat sich zumindest im endeffekt durchgesetzt, mal eine maske haben wir uns jetzt genauer angeguckt
wolf team ist doch, ich kenne das nicht, ich kann nicht jeden shit im internet kennen
wir sind eigentlich so die overwatch viewer zahlen, seit sie auf youtube umgestiegen sind
50k, das ist aber immer noch ganz ok, also ich werde nicht einen stream auf youtube gucken in der richtung
was ist denn, leptis, its a good thing ovl is moving to youtube, nein, nein das ist total von arsch, für game streams beziehungsweise, ich meine guckt euch einmal diesen hässlichen youtube chat an
lechak1978, 5 monate dankeschön, cute chat geht auch auf youtube nicht, extreme night von 5 monate abonniert, 3 monate in folge dankeschön, ich glaub ich hab nix übersehen
burpel, 5 monate dankeschön, massive IQ chat, jedem sub gehts steil nach oben
schlechter als wolf team, aha ok, ich hab noch nie piz meat geguckt, ich gucke eh wenig let's player, die einzigen let's player die ich gucke war auf youtube mal eine gibt es nicht mehr
und auf twitch gucke ich nur dense gaming, wenn überhaupt
ja, youtube streaming suckt einfach nur
ich weiß nicht, ich weiß nicht wie das gut sein soll, für mich als interessierten zuschauer, der das spiel selbst spielt, also nicht mehr, aber gespielt habe, ich gucke ja auch kaum noch auf abord
aber ich weiß nicht wie es für mich als interessierter spieler, der was lernen will und zugucken will ein gutes ding ist, sich immer mehr an den casual scheiß anzuschleimen
ja, natürlich aus sicht von blizzard mag das alle sinnvoll sein, weil casual gleich money ist halt so und ich mein blizzard zieht man in letzter zeit auch, blizzard gehts immer mehr darum, genauso wie allen anderen auch
was halt früher nicht unbedingt so gewesen ist, nur das zu machen was halt möglichst viel kohle bringt
not having twitch emotes is a temporary problem, nee das ist permanent, die werden auf youtube niemals twitch emotes kriegen
ich halte google nicht für in der lage einen ordentlichen emote chat zu designen, oder generell was da auf youtube läuft, das ist alles so langweilig im vergleich zu twitch, das werden die nicht auf die reihe kriegen
schauen wir das neue rantvideo zu blizzard, was denn, welches denn, auf 40 minuten talkvideo von der gamestar, also ich überlege mir das anzugucken, also wir können uns das nachher angucken
aber nur, wenn es entweder mit moris ist oder mit dimitri, anderen mag ich nicht, moris ist aber da, dann können wir uns das später mal angucken, gamestar, youtube, aber nachher, wenn es 40 minuten geht, das kann ich mir jetzt nicht gleich am anfang geben
das da, das alte blizzard ist erledigt und das musste so kommen, das war klar, ich weiß noch, vor ein paar jahren, als diese activision blizzard geschichte angefangen hat, habe ich damals in einem video gesagt, ok leute
bei blizzard ist jetzt vorbei, da ist activision mit am start, da sitzen jetzt, werden mit der zeit immer mehr leute sitzen, die sich nicht für spiele interessieren, sondern rein für zahlen und bwl studiert haben
und der witz ist ja, damals haben mich die leute teilweise, teilweise nicht alle, meisten wussten, dass ich recht habe, ich wurde übelst angeflamed so nach dem auto max, du hast von börse und bwl und sonst was hast du überhaupt keine ahnung, ist ja auch richtig, habe ich auch nicht
das stimmt überhaupt nicht, die haben mir versucht zu erkennen, die haben nur gemerged, das bedeutet nicht, dass irgendwie jetzt activision bei blizzard was zu sagen hätte und umgedreht, da habe ich mich übelst aufgeregt über das was ich im video gesagt habe, also hier die stonks leute
aber im endeffekt ist es doch klar, vor allem wenn es, das wird nicht von heute auf morgen gehen, man war da zusammen, boah das ist schon 5-6 jahre her, ach das ist schon noch länger her
das ist noch länger her, hier, hier irgendwie in dem dreh, seit wie wenn die weg ist, irgendwie hier so in dem dreh war das, wo ich das video auch gemacht habe, wo ich da drüber ein bisschen ausgelassen habe
und es ist doch klar, dass sowas nicht von heute auf morgen passiert, aber man sieht es immer mehr und jetzt spätestens seitdem metzen weg ist und der alte blizzard chef vor 2 jahren oder so gesagt hat, er macht es jetzt vom acker
da war es für den letzten offensichtlich, dass die schlüsselpositionen immer mehr durch irgendwelche activision bwl leute ersetzt werden, was eigentlich auch logisch ist, weil halt stonks und money
allerdings, entwicklungstechnisch sieht es glaube ich gar nicht mal so schlecht aus, was man sich hätte kaufen müssen, wäre nvidia gewesen, aber nachher ist man immer schlauer, man hätte auch milliarden machen können, wenn man sachen weiß, natürlich ist klar man weiß, nachher ist man immer schlauer
aber nvidia ist dieses jahr echt gut abgegangen, hätte man das mal gewusst, stonks bei nvidia sind hoch, rtx on
so ein alex sagt, ich frage mich ja immer noch, was amazon langfristig mit twitch vor hat, immer mehr sachen einzubauen, was es den leuten einfacher macht, geld auszugeben
das fängt an mit bits, geht weiter mit sub only streams, mit dem subtrain, mit irgendwelchen emote unlocks, man hatte schon gesehen, seit twitch bei amazon ist, hat amazon einiges eingebaut, was halt die sache konsumfreudlicher macht
ich finde das aber nicht schlimm, ich verstehe es eh nicht, es wird von vielen leuten auf twitch rumgehated über twitch, das ist zum teil schon in gewisser weise berechtigt
wenn man zum beispiel sieht, dass community regeln bzw. die tos-geschichte, je nachdem wie bekannt einer ist, dass das nicht unbedingt nachvollziehbar und einheitlich ausgelegt wird
aber auf welcher plattform ist das schon, das macht sich wirklich besser, aber eins muss einem ja klar sein, egal ob jetzt youtube, twitch, mixer oder sonstige dinger, man ist eh auf gedei und verderben dem jeweiligen anbieter ausgeliefert
das ist auf jeder plattform so, also wenn der anbieter jetzt da meinung ist, max wir schließen deinen channel, wir machen deinen profil dicht und wir löschen alle deine posts, ich kann dagegen nichts machen
was soll ich dagegen machen, selbst wenn es einen theoretischen weg gäbe, da jetzt irgendwas zu klagen zu machen, das wird in absehbarer zeit nicht zum erfolg führen, das einzige was hilft ist, und das ist grad der witz dabei, weil das auch nichts offizielles im eigenen sinn ist, das einzige was hilft ist shitstorm
es war vor einem jahr oder so, haben die auf youtube angefangen channels dicht zu machen, die sich mit waffen beschäftigt haben, weil nicht kinderfreundlich und nicht allgemeinfreundlich und in dem zuge haben die auch relativ viele channels geschlossen, die sich, und das könnt ihr jetzt nachgucken, das ist kein witz, die sich mit mittelalterlichen kampfmethoden und waffen beschäftigt haben
das ist wirklich big brain gewesen von youtube, da haben die beispielsweise versucht einen channel dicht zu machen, der hat halt gezeigt, wie man sich eine armbrust baut, mittelalter style, da hat youtube gesagt, oh nee, das geht nicht, weil waffe
und das gab halt einen riesen massive shitstorm, den wahrscheinlich nicht jeder mitgekriegt hat, aber alle die ein bisschen diese channels verfolgen haben, das gab einen riesen shitstorm, und der channel ist wieder da, also lustigerweise das einzige, ja genau, toxics, du kennst das, du kennst das
und das einzige, was hilft, ist lustigerweise das nicht offizielle, ist shitstorm, das ist witzig, bei vielen, bei vielen sachen ist das heute so, es ist, es ist mittlerweile fast egal, ob was rechtmäßig erfolgt, unrechtmäßig erfolgt, irgendwie, ähm, einer, einen betrogen hat, sonst was, das was hilft ist shitstorm
shitstorms führen dazu, dass produkte zurückgerufen werden, shitstorms führen dazu, dass youtube channels, die zugemacht werden, wieder aufgemacht werden, shitstorms führen indirekt dazu, dass irgendwie neu gewählt wird, äh, shitstorms ist das mittel 2020, Dinge durchzusetzen, die man haben will
man muss halt nur gucken, äh, man muss halt nur gucken, dass man verbündete findet, ja, genau, sonic wird umgestylt, weil shitstorms, shitstorms bei unity media, oh die bekommen genau shitstorms, die sind aber, was man auch merkt ist, dass die anbieter mittlerweile ein bisschen feinfühliger geworden sind, was shitstorm anfälligkeit angeht
es ist nicht umsonst so, dass, äh, alle größeren anbieter heute, äh, twitter support, twitter support haben, die sich um, um sachen kümmern und ich, ich vermute einfach mal, ich mein, ich hab immer noch, ich hab irgendwie um die 1, 2500, 20.500 irgendwie follower auf twitter und so fies das klingt, aber ich geh, ich geh wirklich davon aus, dass unity media und telecom und wir auch immer
schneller auf jemand antwortet auf twitter, der 20.000 follower hat, als einer 5 follower hat, einfach weil die, äh, äh, shitstorm aware sind mittlerweile, die haben da keinen bock drauf und sowas kann sich hier auch wie feuer ausbreiten, wenn da einmal mal
shitstorm wird an der richtigen ecke und die passenden leute drauf aufspringen ist vorbei, da ist corona nix dagegen von der verbreitung
das montana pleck macht 70k mit prime, ja gut, warum nicht, das ist einer der größten streamer der welt, wenn der kein geld macht, wer sonst, hab vor 5 tagen eine frage gestellt, einfach keine antwort bekommen von unity media, man müsste das jetzt ja mal testen, wenn ich das quote, ob die dann antworten
das kommt auch noch dazu crash fluffy, wenn du den leuten hilfst, die quasi, sag mal, wenn du leute hilfst, die 150.000 follower haben und der schreibt dann was gutes oder bedankt sich öffentlich oder was auch immer, das ist top, da gehen die stonks nach oben
was ist in dem china ordner, oh das kann ich jetzt nicht zeigen, das kann ich jetzt nicht zeigen und streamen, doch kann ich zeigen, da sind irgendwelche aliexpress links drin, nichts schlimmes, genau, corona geheimtipps
so, wir haben jetzt noch ein video geguckt, wir schauen uns jetzt das battlefield video an
und danach, ich hab gestern auf youtube ein bisschen rum geguckt, was man heute sich anschauen könnte, ich hab nix gefunden außer ein video, und zwar ist das vom wdr, oder vom br, was zum teufel ist der br rundfunk, was ist br, der bayerische rundfunk, nicht der wdr, die guckt schon so ein bisschen, das ist gefährlich
kann ari in 3 monaten ihre eigene app programmieren, das müssen wir uns nachher angucken, das ist voll cringe, das kann ich mir vorstellen, den blizzard talk haben wir schon auf, das gucken wir uns dann noch an, ich kann mir schon vorstellen, wenn ich dieses erste bild sehe, dass das ein wenig cringe sein wird
wir gucken uns jetzt erstmal in ruhe eine runde battlefield montage an, ihr wisst ja das was ich immer sage, der typ sagt immer das gleiche in seinen videos
moment leute, das battlefield 3 jetzt, das fällt einem echt schwer zu unterschreiten, vor allem auf dem pc, wo man keine controller controls sieht und keine auflösung das festmachen kann
deine meinung zum neuen edge, stimmt, da ist er, der neue edge, ich habe den neuen edge noch nicht ausprobiert, außer hier im stream, was ist eigentlich die default suche, ist die default suche bing, ach nee wir haben sie auf duckda go umgestellt die default suche vom edge
oh ich habe ja einen facebook account, Sachen gibts, habe ich ja irgendwann mal gemacht, habe ich seit 5 jahren nichts mehr hochgeladen oder so
facebook in 2020, das letzte 2018 habe ich irgendwie ein video verlinkt von youtube, hat keine sauer interessiert, weil facebook von der zoomer generation eh keiner mehr verwendet, was sind das hier gewesen
das musste ich checken, kann ich mich gar nicht mehr dran erinnern, habt ihr was für dich, i love cookies und noch den g2a raffling drunter alter, könnt ihr euch da noch dran erinnern, daumen revealed
facebook gaming wächst mehr als mixer, das wundert mich nicht, mixer ist ja auch totaler schrott, könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern an die game pass kopiergeschichte von i love cookies
oh man, gibts den eigentlich noch, ich weiß er war vor einem jahr oder so mal hier im stream und wir haben gesagt wir nehmen mal was zusammen auf, aber das hat sich ja irgendwie, oh guck mal der ist tatsächlich noch am start hier ab und zu
wahnsinn, hätte ich gar nicht gedacht, ja, gab doch großes drama damals wegen den fast passen, ja ja riesen drama
streamt da eigentlich noch poker, das war poker dude, battlefield 3 ist blau sieht man immer unten rechts bei der minima, stimmt hast recht, ja klar, so wir gucken jetzt, wir gucken jetzt battlefield top plays an
das ist, das ist wieder so, das ist wieder so ein typischer clip leute, wo ich mir so denke, bestimmt nicht gestellt, ok ne ich glaube das ist wirklich nicht gestellt, ich glaube das ist wirklich nicht gestellt
wobei man weiß es nicht, aber ich glaube nicht das es gestellt war, dachte jetzt der erschießt einen auf dem turm, macht er aber nicht
hello and welcome to your new battlefield top play video, oder irgendwie sowas, er sagt immer das gleiche
hello and welcome to the battlefield top plays, in todays episode we will be taking a look at clips from battlefield 3, jesus, moment haben wir das, haben wir das nicht schon geguckt, haben wir das nicht letzte woche schon geguckt, 23 februar, ne können wir letzte woche nicht geguckt haben, ach ne moment
haben wir das, haben wir das letzte woche nicht schon geguckt, oh lol, warum geht nach unten auch weiter der monat, das ist microsoft kalender logik, also die chance besteht, dass wir das schon geguckt haben
wie viel Uhr hat denn das hochgeladen, sieht man da die Uhrzeit irgendwie bei, wir machen jetzt trick 17, wir gucken jetzt, wir gucken jetzt wann das erste Kommentar war, big brain leute big brain, übrigens wieder ein punkt warum endless scroll kacke ist
Wir gucken jetzt, wann das erste Kommentar war, wir müssen nur 5 Minuten scrollen und dann wissen wir, ob das... ob wir das...
Ah, first, 6 days ago und zwar wann genau...
Mein Gott, YouTube, ist das so schwer, da ne Uhrzeit anzuzeigen?
Ist das so schwer, da ne Uhrzeit anzuzeigen, ja?
Okay, wir gucken einfach mal den Anfang und dann sehen wir ja, ob wir es schon...
Alter! Browser, please!
Jetzt wisst ihr auch, warum YouTube endless scroll hat.
Weil... weil der Browser übelst am verrecken ist, wenn man endless... wenn man so viele Kommentare angezeigt hat.
Ich weiß nicht, was daran schwierig ist, ehrlich gesagt, 5 Seiten Kommentare anzuzeigen, warum das dann so ruckelt.
Weiß es nicht.
WTF? Ist das jetzt nicht euer Ernst?
Ah, reload.
Jetzt geht's wieder.
Was läuft da im Hintergrund für... für... für ne großrechnermäßige JavaScript-Geschichte?
Jesus!
Das haben wir schon gesehen, oder?
Ist vorbei.
Ja.
Wir warten nochmal an den nächsten Clip, aber wie kommt das mit Kampf vor?
Das haben wir schon gesehen.
Top Plays.
Jetzt gucken wir uns ein anderes an.
Battlefield 5, wer braucht Battlefield 5?
Overrated, jebaited, oder?
Luckyest moment Battlefield...
Ok, komm, das sind alle Games drinne.
Ah, nee, das ist Battlefield 5. Battlefield 5 will ich nicht gucken.
Perfect Time, Battlefield 5, Battlefield 5.
Ein Jahr, ne, vor dem Jahr haben wir noch nicht geguckt.
Moment, das ist... ich will was anderes gucken.
Moment, Battlefield Top Plays, Battlefield Top Plays.
Das haben wir glaube ich auch schon geguckt.
Macht das mit der App in drei Monaten, dann kommen wir in Battlefield.
Gucken wir nachher, genau.
Wir suchen jetzt hier erst mal aufs gescheites Raum.
Das haben wir glaube ich noch nicht geguckt.
Das ist so alt, das können wir noch nicht geguckt haben.
Komm, wir gucken uns den Cringe, die Cringe-Reportage vom bayerischen Rundfunk an.
Aber Leute, ich sag euch, das wird wahrscheinlich übelst zum Fremdschämen.
Wenn ich das erste Foto schon sehe, dann weiß ich Bescheid.
Die quietscht wahrscheinlich das ganze Video über rum.
So nach dem Motto, oh wie kompliziert das ist.
Und Null und Technik und äh überhaupt.
Das wird richtig Paynes Champ.
Hab ich... das wird wirklich Paynes...
Hab ich Paynes Champ eigentlich drinne?
Moment, das brauchen wir noch.
Oh, what the fuck?
High IQ!
Das hat genau das Richtige für uns aufgemacht.
High IQ Plays.
Ich weiß nicht, wie ich das...
Wie hab ich das denn geschafft zu öffnen, das Video gerade?
Hat das jemand gesehen, wie ich das Video gerade aufgemacht hab?
Was?
Ctrl T?
Ctrl T macht nen...
Ctrl T macht nen Tab auf.
Und dann?
Ctrl Shift T?
Nee, das hatten wir gar nicht auf, das Video.
Egal, High IQ Plays.
Der Browser Gotthard entschied, das müssen wir uns angucken.
Ich wollte gerade irgendwas gucken im neuen Tab.
Genau, Paynes Champ brauch ich noch.
Paynes Champ.
Genau, den da.
GIF.
Als GIF.
Als GIF brauch ich den.
Äh, nicht als GIF, als Transparent.
Color, Transparent.
Perfekt.
Bisschen klein, aber...
Was ist das?
Haha, ist das dumm.
Okay, Paynes Champ.
Besser kleines Bild als gar nix.
Paynes Champ.
Perfekt.
Das brauchen wir für das Video.
Ich weiß, dass das essentiell sein wird.
Google Bilder Suche nach Twitch Emotes.
Jeder findet's.
Ich hab immer Angst, wenn ich Twitch Emotes suche
und Google Bilder suche kommt, hab ich immer Angst,
dass irgendwie irgendeine Monka-Toss-Geschichte kommt.
Man weiß ja nie so genau, ne?
So.
Gucken wir uns mal an.
Was hat der bayerische Rundfunk uns da...
Was hat der bayerische Rundfunk mit unseren Rundfunkgebühren angestellt?
Das zeig mal her.
Ariane lernt, programmiert.
Leute.
Es tut jetzt schon weh.
Es schmerzt.
...eigene App haben.
Oh Gott, es schmerzt.
Es tut weh.
Es gäb ne Ari-App.
Also das wär schon was Tolles.
Ich weiß, ich bin ein Computer-Legastheniker.
Es nennt...
Hallo.
Das Programmieren ist quasi das Autofahren des 21. Jahrhunderts.
Wat?
Das Programmieren ist das Autofahren des 21. Jahrhunderts?
Ich versuch mir grad nen Reim zu machen auf den Vergleich irgendwie.
Wat?
Egal, egal.
Wir gucken jetzt...
Ich kann das Video nicht ausmachen, Leute.
Wenn ich das Video ausmache, dann kommen wieder alle Feministen und sagen,
Max, du machst das Video nur aus, weil die Hauptrolle von ner Frau gespielt wird.
Das geht nicht.
Chat, wir müssen das Video fertig gucken.
Na klar, muss nicht jeder nen Führerschein machen.
Aber der, den hat, ist klar am Vorteil.
Der Plan ist jetzt...
Ja, gäb es ordentlich öffentliche Verkehrsmittel.
Und dann kann jeder von euch, die auch sein Handy laden.
Dafür geht's am Valentinstag zu meinem ersten Programmierkurs.
Bei Cook&Code kann jeder gegen selbstgekochtes Coden lernen.
Hallo.
Coden.
Leute.
Hört auf, Coden zu sagen.
Das hört sich an wie Kacken.
Der Galomaten-IT.
Hack-Mac-Programmier.
Fan-Club.
Ja.
Geil.
Und mit Rosen.
Oh Mann.
Ich hab der Bachelor für dich da gelassen.
Ich haffe den Bachelor.
Zum Glück nicht der Bachelor, sondern mein Programmiercoach Alexander.
Er will mit seinen Cosen fürs Coden begeistern und bringt mir heute die ersten Basics bei.
Ich habe ein bisschen Angst, aber es wird schon.
Okay, das ist schon mal ein äußerst unrealistischer Kurs.
So viele Mädels, die in diesem Kurs sind, das muss fake sein.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass es in einem Programmierkurs nur Mädels gibt.
Oder aber wahrscheinlich ist es ein Programmierkurs nur für Mädels.
Wahrscheinlich wird es das sein, weil ansonsten ist die Zusammensetzung nicht sonderlich repräsentativ.
Ich bin ja heute hier, um ein schönes JavaScript-Trinkspiel zu programmieren.
JavaScript ist eine Programmiersprache, mit deren Hilfe man Webseiten interaktiv machen kann.
Und jetzt soll ich direkt selbst damit programmieren.
Zumindest haben sie schon mal angefangen, die beste Aussprache den Leuten beizubringen.
Nicht JavaScript, sondern gleiche JavaScript.
Leute, was sagt ihr?
JavaScript oder JavaScript?
Also ich persönlich bin ja für JavaScript.
JavaScript, JavaScript, JavaScript.
Okay, ich würde sagen aktuell so 10% JavaScript, 90% JavaScript.
Ich wechsle immer zwischen beiden.
Das mache ich auch aus Versehen.
Bei SCSI mache ich das immer.
Wenn ich SCSI einzeln habe, dann sage ich meistens SCSI.
Ansonsten sage ich immer trotzdem SCSI, ist das total weh.
Was gibt denn das für ein Doktor?
Gut, so hat jeder mal angefangen.
Aber wenigstens passiert das schon mal auf einem MacBook.
Weil wir wissen ja, dass alle Pros auf MacBooks programmieren.
Und so hat irgendwie jeder mal angefangen.
Also irgendwie abtippen, was in dem Tutorial steht.
Das ist wirklich witzig, weil ich nämlich mir nicht vorstellen kann, dass da jetzt was bei rauskommt.
Da kommt noch wenig, doch, da jetzt schon.
Oh, ein Hallo Welt, huge.
Alex, warum ist denn das eigentlich so, dass das anscheinend nur Frauen machen?
Es gibt verschiedene Theorien, zum Beispiel bei unseren Kinderkursen kommen nur Jungs.
Na ja, also die Jungs haben das in unserem Alter alle schon gelernt.
Ich versuche mich weiter am Trinkspiel. Funktioniert das jetzt?
Haben wir das zu laut?
Nein.
Trink.
Hab ich programmiert.
Tolles Trinkspiel, als Antwort kommt immer Trink.
Das ist natürlich auch eine Möglichkeit.
Okay, wer hätte das gedacht? Also ich vor einer halben Stunde nicht.
Ob das so easy bleibt? Ich meine, ich will ja eine komplette App programmieren.
Hier arbeitet der Alex.
Schauen wir mal, was man so schaffen kann, wenn man als Anfänger drei Monate programmieren darf.
Auch in drei Monaten kann man schon relativ viel machen.
Die hat eine Voraussetzung, die ist gar nicht schlecht mit Programmieren anzufangen.
Die weiß, was sie machen will.
Das sage ich auch immer, wenn Leute hier im Stream fragen, was ist die beste Variante anzufangen, zu programmieren.
Das Beste ist, wenn man von Anfang an irgendwas im Kopf hat, was man machen will.
Weil dann erübrigt sich schon mal die Technologie-Auswahl zum größten Teil.
Ansonsten stehst du vor einem Riesenberg so nach dem Motto, mit was wird das Standbilder?
Ist ein bisschen unglücklich gewählt, aber ich habe einfach Pause gedrückt.
Ansonsten stehst du vor einem Riesenberg und denkst dir Scheiße, mit was fange ich jetzt an?
Aber die hat echt einen Vorteil, die hat schon im Kopf, sie will eine App machen.
Das grenzt vieles aus, was du nicht lernen musst oder was gar nicht in Frage kommt.
Die muss jetzt beispielsweise nicht mit.NET WPF anfangen oder so ein Blödsinn, weil damit machst du keine App.
Also die Voraussetzungen sind gar nicht mal so schlecht.
Hast du dir denn schon Gedanken gemacht?
Ja, bin gespannt, ob das klappt oder nicht.
Meine geniale Idee, eine Spiele-App, in der du dir eine Soap freispielen kannst.
Darauf kann auch nur jemand kommen, der beim Rundfunk arbeitet.
Und eine Kartoffel namens Clemens und natürlich ich.
In der App spielt man Schnick, Schnack, Schnuck. Wer verliert, muss nochmal spielen.
Massive Game, huge.
Wer gewinnen darf sich aussuchen, wie die Soap weitergeht. Und so ungefähr sollen die Videos aussehen.
Aber so doof ist das nicht. So doof ist das nicht. Das ist ziemlich simpel zu machen.
Und die hat jetzt schon zwei Voraussetzungen, die echt nicht verkehrt sind.
Die weiß, dass sie eine App machen will, das heißt, strengt die Technologie ein.
Und sie weiß schon mal, was zu grob in die App rein soll, wo man abschätzen kann, das ist in drei Monaten überhaupt möglich.
Wenn ich jetzt eine total abgedrehte Idee habe, so nach dem Motto, ich will hier irgendwelche Machine Learning,
noch nie dagewesene, superadvance Sachen machen in drei Monaten, aber noch überhaupt keine Ahnung,
dann ist die Chance, dass das in die Hose geht, relativ hoch.
Sie weiß, dass sie eine App machen will. Und sie weiß jetzt im Endeffekt auch, dass es in drei Monaten möglich ist.
Weil die Idee ist nichts Schwieriges in dem Sinn. Das kann man in drei Monaten hinbekommen.
Das ist auch so nach dem Motto, du machst ein Minispiel rein.
Im Prinzip ist es ja nur random zwischen drei Zahlen und dann gucken, was größer ist im Endeffekt.
Also, Schere-Stein-Papier zu programmieren ist jetzt nicht so huge.
Aber für einen Einsteiger ist das gar nicht so einfach, wenn man sich überlegt,
es geht ja nicht darum, dass die irgendwie ihre zehn Zeilen Schere-Stein-Papier programmiert,
sondern die muss ja den ganzen anderen Kram drum herum auch machen.
Und da sind drei Monate, ist realistisch. Und das ist schon mal gut, dass man weiß, dass es überhaupt geht.
Schön, dass ihr da seid. Mein Name ist Oriana Alter und das ist Clemens Kartoffeln.
Vor drei Tagen stand er einfach vor der Tür.
Der Clemens Kartoffel.
Für dein Projekt, HTML, CSS, JavaScript.
Muss das unbedingt im Browser laufen?
Ja gut, ist das Einfachste. Kann ich aber verstehen.
Ist die simpelste Geschichte und lässt sich auch am einfachsten entwickeln.
Und die Frameworks, Angular.
Angular? Okay, Ionic verstehe ich.
Muss man Ionic in Angular programmieren? Nö, oder?
Achso, ich habe mit Ionic noch nichts gemacht.
Ich weiß nur, was es ist.
Ionic ist ein App-Framework für Browser-Anwendungen in App-Store passende Dinger zu verpacken.
Ich glaube, da bin ich mir jetzt nicht ganz sicher, weil ich habe mit Ionic noch nichts gemacht,
mit den passenden Bindings für die jeweilige Plattform drinnen.
Also sprich, du kannst dann die Kamera zugriffen. Es ist so ein bisschen was wie Electron.
Ein bisschen was wie Electron mit zusätzlichem Mobile Framework dabei.
Und du kannst am Ende, glaube ich, eine App-Store Package rausfallen lassen.
Und es hat, soweit ich weiß, hast du auch irgendeinen Designer für GUI.
Ionic ist quasi ein Rapper, du kannst mit Java-Hardware, mit Native-Schnittstellen ansprechen.
Genau, das ist quasi, das ist irgendwie so eine Mischung aus, das kann wohl mehrere Sachen.
Ich habe damit noch nichts gemacht.
Du hast auf der einen Seite wohl irgendwie so ein Mobile Framework-Geschichten drin.
Also sprich, dass du eben auf die Kamera zugreifen kannst, auf GPS zugreifen kannst,
auf irgendwelche Dinger, die deinen Sensoren und Geschiss, was halt eben dein Smartphone hat.
Halt mit JavaScript-Runtime und im Endeffekt ist da wahrscheinlich einfach ein ganz normales V8
und ein bisschen Chrome unten drunter, vermute ich jetzt mal, einfach mal geraten.
Plus wohl noch so ein paar Hilfetools, dass du App-Store Sachen machen kannst.
Und ich glaube, ein GUI-Designer hat das Ding auch.
Ich habe mal bei Simple App-Creator, ich glaube, das könnte das sein.
Und was das Schöne auch daran ist, du kannst halt iOS und Android-Apps damit machen.
Ich habe da mal ein Video zugesehen von, ja, da ist übrigens auch Max,
deswegen kann ich mir den Channel immer gut merken.
Der hat mal so eine Serie gemacht.
Ionic vs. Flutter vs. irgendwelche Native-Script-Gedöns.
Und da hat er ein bisschen was zu Ionic erklärt.
Und das scheint mir wirklich ein guter Mittelweg zu sein zwischen Easy-Einstieg und Funktionen.
Du wirst jetzt nicht die Wahnsinns-Performance für irgendwie ein Game rausholen,
aber die meisten Apps sind halt irgendwie keine 3D-Performance-fressende Dinger.
Wie viele Tabs hast du offentlicht? Viele? 15 oder so?
Angular und Ionic.
Muss man Ionic echt mit Angular programmieren? Ich glaube nicht.
Ah ja, das ist gar nicht so wenig.
Brave Browser ist gut.
Mission Impossible.
Und jetzt starten wir mit HTML.
HTML ist das Skelett einer Website.
Und bringt Inhalte wie z.B. Fotos auf die Seite.
Achtung, es ist keine programmierte Sprache.
Aber super wichtig als Grundgerüst einer Website.
Bist du dir sicher, dass es JPEG ist? Ja.
Speichern.
Und jetzt kommt der große Moment.
Oh mein Gott, es hat geklappt.
Noch ein Bild. Unglaublich, ein Bild.
Damit du das gelernte JavaScript-Wissen nicht wieder vergisst, möchten wir das gerne...
Moment, da war doch gar kein JavaScript dabei.
Ach so, ja, vorher.
Hallo World in JavaScript.
Derholen, und zwar machst das du alleine in der Hausaufgabe.
Hausaufgaben.
Bevor ich mich um die Hausaufgaben kümmere, fange ich lieber mit dem Videodreh für meine selbst ausgedachte Kartoffelsop an.
Herr Kartoffel.
Das ist prinzipiell schon mal keine gute Idee.
Quasi, bevor man irgendwie nicht auch einen halbwegs laufwürdigem Prototyp hat, Content zu erstellen,
für was, wo man überhaupt nicht weiß, ob es funktioniert.
Das ist eigentlich verkehrt rum.
Ihr fragt euch jetzt, warum eine Kartoffel?
Ich sage, warum nicht?
In einer Folge kommen zum Beispiel ein paar befreundete Pommes bei Clemens Kartoffeln vorbei.
Alter.
Guten Morgen.
Programmpunkt für den heutigen Tag ist die erste Hausaufgabe.
Ich soll ein Beispiel programmieren.
Übrigens, erfahrungs-, also rein meine Erfahrung im Bett programmieren funktioniert nicht.
Auf Englisch.
Auf Englisch? Oh Gott.
So.
Moment.
Wartet mal kurz.
Also, der Sprung.
Also der Sprung von JavaScript Hello World.
Zu irgendeinem Space Invaders Klon oder was das da genau ist.
Das erscheint mir jetzt ein bisschen weit.
Oder sie ist wirklich extrem massive big brain.
Ja, oder es ist copy-paste. Ja, das kann natürlich auch sein.
Einfach, einfach copy-paste und dann...
Das könnte natürlich auch sein.
Stand da doch eben, oder? Was denn?
Canvas Basics. Ach hier, das ist die Mozilla Hilfe.
Gut, da steht aber nicht drin, wie man da draußen ein Game macht.
Game Dev Canvas Workshop. Was?
Ist das Alex?
Lesson 1. Ach so was ist das hier.
Ach, das kommt da raus. Ah.
Okay, dann geht das doch.
Ich vermute mal, dass es so ist, man bekommt das hier.
Man bekommt das hier und soll dann verschiedene Aufgaben an diesem Source Code durchführen.
Na dann geht das doch. Dann ist das doch okay.
Kann man auch machen.
Ich soll ein Beispiel programmieren.
Das ist ja alles auf Englisch.
Da muss man sich aber dran gewöhnen, dass der Kram auf Englisch ist.
Ich bin mal gespannt, was Alex sagt. Es könnte auch sein, dass ich einige Aufgaben nicht gemacht habe.
Das fängt ja schon gut an.
So, dann wollen wir doch mal sehen. Du hast gesagt, du hast die Hausaufgabe gemacht.
Ich habe es sogar ein bisschen schneller gemacht, weil ich finde, dass es zu langsam war.
Nicht schlecht.
Leider habe ich den zweiten Teil der Hausaufgabe nicht hingekriegt.
Darin sollte der Ball eigentlich die Farbe wechseln, wenn er gegen die Wand fliegt.
Also da weiter raus.
Das ist genau der Punkt. Das ist eine Übung, die kann ich dir nicht beibringen, außer du machst es selbst.
Das ist ja zu kotzen.
Also dann würde ich sagen.
Warum kann er ihr nicht erklären?
Warum soll das nicht funktionieren? Warum kann er ihr nicht erklären, was sie hätte machen müssen, um das zu machen?
Warum soll das nicht gehen?
Warum soll das nicht funktionieren?
Der kann das nicht, der muss es nicht vorsagen.
Es gibt ja immer noch einen Zwischenweg zwischen gar nichts und ich erkläre dir, ich sage dir, was du hinschreiben musst.
Man kann den Leuten ja einen Hinweis geben.
So nach dem Motto, guck dir mal die Funktion an, die aufgerufen wird, wenn der Ball an die Wand klatscht.
So, und dann kannst du sagen, guck dir mal die Funktion an.
Du kannst ja nochmal eine halbe Stunde Gedanken machen, ob man es nicht an der Stelle machen könnte.
Wie du es an der Stelle machen würdest.
Also es ist ja der Unterschied zwischen Vorsagen, Vorsagen und gar nichts.
Alter 292, das ist euer Rekord.
Ich glaube das höchste bisher war irgendwie 250 Sonntags Massive Zuschauer.
Also nur weil sie Ari in drei Monaten beim Programmieren zusehen wollen.
Huge.
Fangen wir an mit CSS.
Warte, ich muss noch kurz das Ding speichern.
CSS beschreibt das Design einer Website.
Oh, jetzt geht es los.
Damit kann man also derselben Seite unterschiedliche Looks geben.
HTML war ja das.
Gillette.
Yes.
Also ist CSS.
Ich liebe Klamotten.
Genau.
Die Challenge.
Ich soll meine Website mit CSS-Grün programmieren und rosa Kästchen draufbauen.
Boah.
Herzlichen Glückwunsch, du hast es geschafft.
Das ist ja schon fertig.
Fertig?
Ja.
Okay.
Du hast HTML gelernt, du hast CSS gelernt, du hast JavaScript die Grundlagen gelernt.
Ich würde dir empfehlen, die Hausaufgaben wieder von vorne anzufangen.
Gut.
Ja klar.
Die Freizeit war dann nicht mehr so, weil in jeder freien Minute habe ich entweder programmiert.
Die könnte doch einfach.
Ich meine ihr Job ist es, Reportagen für den BR zu drehen.
Da ist das ja wohl in der Zeit drin oder?
Oh Chat.
Chat.
Aufhören.
Ich muss weitermachen.
Clemens Kartoffel gedreht.
Jetzt?
Ja.
Vielleicht habe ich den Bezug zur Realität verloren.
Eine Süßkartoffel hat zum Beispiel in meinem Betten Ingwer geboren.
Kann auch nicht jeder von sich sagen.
Weißt du was ich merkwürdig finde?
Man sieht sie total oft am Notebook setzen, aber man sieht sie so gut wie nie programmieren.
Oder irgendwas machen.
Jetzt kommen Konsequenzen Leute.
Ich war gespannt was da am Ende rauskommt.
Hallo.
Schon wieder.
Ich finde wir konnten auch schon zusammenziehen.
Mittlerweile muss ich sagen, ich habe diesen Mann zu meinem Geburtstag eingeladen, weil
ich so viel Zeit mit ihm verbringe, wir treffen uns mindestens einmal die Woche, ich hacke
irgendwas in die...
Da ist dann der Plan von Alex mit dem reinen Mädelworkshop voll aufgegangen.
Die Tastatur regt mich auf, weil irgendwas wieder nicht geht.
Er rettet mich aus diesem digitalen Meer der Unsicherheiten.
Also der Alex und ich...
Was machen wir heute?
Heute sprechen wir über Angular und über Ionic.
Es wird halt jetzt sehr abstrakt.
Ab jetzt wird das abstrakt?
Es könnte sein, dass du jetzt kurz zur Verzweiflung kommst, aber das wird schon ganz gut werden.
Schon wieder.
Bist du bereit?
Ja.
Angular ist eine Art Baukasten für JavaScript.
Klingt einfach, ist aber wahnsinnig komplex.
Ja, eigentlich ist die Beschreibung...
Ich meine, die trifft es nicht wirklich.
Aber wie willst du das anderweitig erklären?
Wie willst du anderweitig ein Anwendungsframework...
Wie willst du das erklären als Bau...
Ist doch eigentlich ganz okay.
Oh, was haben wir denn hier?
Sie lernen auch noch Timescript nebenbei.
Es wird auch noch Timescript nebenbei gelernt.
Easy.
Was ich mich frage, wer den ganzen Kram eingerichtet hat, weil ehrlicherweise ist das reine Setup
von so einer Entwicklungsenvironment.
Also ich rede jetzt nicht von dem Editor an sich, sondern von den ganzen Tools im Hinterkonto,
dass das funktioniert.
Ein bisschen beschäftigen muss man sich damit auch.
Ach, Angular geht nur noch in Timescript, okay?
Ein bisschen muss man sich damit beschäftigen.
Ich meine, bei Vue hast du Vue CLI zum Generieren, bei Angular...
Ah ja, die Wolle sagt es gerade, Angular CLI gibt es auch was zum Generieren.
Ein bisschen mit beschäftigen, was die all diesen Dinger machen, muss man trotzdem.
Zumindest ist jetzt...
Ich wusste nicht, dass Timescript Pflicht ist bei Angular.
So, jetzt machen wir das Ganze hier auch noch in Timescript, was deutlich angenehmer ist.
Ich habe trotzdem nicht Bache.
So, weiter.
Ich tauche immer tiefer in die Matrix ein, aber wirklich bereit bin ich nicht.
Wenn du das jetzt ausführst, dann wird ein Wunder passieren.
Was wolltest du noch mal in deinem Projekt machen?
Video, shing shang shong, mehrere Optionen, dann wieder Video, shing shang shong und immer so weiter.
Aber die Leute sollen es auf dem Smartphone nutzen?
Am meisten, ja.
Okay, dann kannst du das zum Beispiel mit Ionic machen, das ist dafür sehr gut geeignet.
Ionic ist ein Gerüst, mit dessen Hilfe ich aus meiner Idee tatsächlich eine App bauen kann.
Und das Beste, es macht Spaß.
Oh, das Ding meinte ich hier.
Ich wusste, dass das Ding irgendeinen GUI-Designer hat.
Ah, ist das Ding nochmal Ionic?
Ja.
Das ist schonmal mein bester Freund.
Das ist das GUI.
Die Funktion ist nicht da.
Es läuft gar nichts, Alex.
Oh je.
Gibt es nur noch Paid?
Alex hat bestimmt einen Paid-Zugang zu diesem Ionic-Creator.
Ionic, zum vierten Mal gemacht.
Und es geht nicht.
Ich verstehe es nicht.
In drei Monaten, neben dem Job von Null, eine App programmieren?
Puh.
Dann ratet mal, wohin es wieder geht.
Meine App ist noch nicht fertig, aber Grundkenntnisse im Programmieren.
Check.
Ich habe mit Ionic eine App gebaut.
Jetzt muss man die nur noch hinten rum programmieren.
Nur.
Nur noch.
Ich meine, das ist das Eigentliche.
Jetzt kann ich nur den Oberflächenlook festlegen.
Danach kommt erst die eigentliche Programmierarbeit.
Oh je.
Okay.
Leute.
Ich glaube ihr, das glaube ich ihr, dass ihr die Seite selbst gemacht habt.
Genauso sieht eine Anfängerseite aus.
Hintergrundbild, Standard Schriftart, absolut keinen Kontrast zwischen.
Das glaube ich ihr.
Also.
Bis jetzt kaufe ich ihr das ab.
Und das ist in drei Monaten noch ohne Probleme möglich.
Eigentliche Programmierarbeit für die verschiedenen Funktionen meiner App.
Aber Hauptsache erstmal einen Bootstrap.
Hauptsache erstmal einen Bootstrap-Button.
Das ist wichtig.
Hintergrundtext sieht kacke aus.
Einfach einen Bootstrap-Button.
Programmierarbeit für die verschiedenen Funktionen meiner App.
Mit Abstand das schwerste war dieses formaledeite Spiel.
Ich dachte es ist so einfach.
Der Computer macht zufällig was.
Ich mach was und dann wird geguckt wer hat gewonnen.
So schwer kann es ja nicht sein.
Doch es ist so schwer.
Und die Kartoffel-Video.
Okay.
Ich hoffe wir sehen noch ein bisschen Sourcecode.
Schwer.
Darf man?
Darf man sich APK runterladen?
Und die kompilen?
Obwohl wir müssen das gar nicht die kompilen.
Das ist ja JavaScript.
Darf man sich APKs runterladen und auspacken?
Also on stream?
Ich will mal gucken was da drinnen ist.
Wir laden uns gleich Klemer ins Kartoffel runter.
Gucken wir rein.
Ich weiß aber nicht wie man APKs auspackt.
Weil bisher sieht man nicht viele.
Man sieht eigentlich überhaupt kein JavaScript.
Aber wenn man auf der App läuft und da herauf geht,
könnt ihr euch ja auf der App erspielen.
Das Spiel muss ich aber auch noch fertig programmieren.
Da merkt man irgendwie schon was macht mir mehr Spaß.
Zeigt doch mal was sie so programmieren.
Mich interessiert das echt was da drauf.
Also mich interessiert wirklich was da auf dem Bildschirm ist.
Nicht dass er auf ein Notebook tippt.
Ich will sehen was auf dem Bildschirm ist.
Aber diesmal wird es wahrscheinlich das letzte Mal sein.
Denn heute schließen Alex und ich die App ab und laden sie hoch.
Also es gab Zeiten wo ich nicht mehr rangeglaubt habe.
Ich bin so glücklich. Wahnsinn.
Ich habe jetzt auch diese Videos fertig.
Jetzt haben wir auch die Fotos.
Im Prinzip habe ich alles dabei um das Projekt heute abzuschließen.
Kriegen wir hin?
Wer jetzt sagt die Bilder sehen ja total unproseniell aus.
Ach nee, das sind ja auch nur die Platzhalter.
Und das wird jetzt einfach nur ersetzt.
Dieses Ersetzen kann mir jetzt die ganze Schose wieder vollkommen verhauen.
Hast du eine Sicherung gemacht?
Jetzt wäre der passende Zeitpunkt, dass Alex ihr mal beibringt eine Runde Gitcomit und push.
Wäre jetzt wirklich angebracht.
Was ist wenn ihr den Computer jetzt abbraucht?
Dann müssen wir wieder von vorne einfach.
Also jetzt hast du mal...
Ernsthaft?
Ja.
Oh Gott, erst mal auf Festplatte sichern.
Das fühlt sich so an, als würdest du am offenen Herzen operieren.
Ja.
Ich wusste es.
Jetzt ist das Foto weg.
Foto ist weg. Ari hat sich vertippt.
Was?
Wie läuft man ein Foto, mit dem man sich vertippt?
Vertippt.
Und neuer Versuch.
Ersetzen.
Hacker-Mans am Start.
Und so sieht es dann auf dem Handy aus.
Also jetzt beim Endspurt merkst du, du machst gerade den geilsten Scheiß.
Mache ich jetzt den heißesten Scheiß?
Na gut.
Es gibt bestimmt noch anderen heißen Scheiß, aber es ist schon einer der...
Heißesten Scheißer, die es gibt.
Wobei ich glaube, wenn wir mal davon ausgehen, dass es wirklich legit was wir gezeigt kriegen,
dann kann ich sich wirklich freuen.
Also wenn man echt keinen Plan hat, dann ist das schon nicht übel, sowas hier zu basteln erst mal.
Ich meine, mit allem, was dazugehört.
Wie gesagt, wenn wir davon ausgehen, dass das alles legit ist, was wir gezeigt bekommen haben,
dann würde ich mich an ihrer Stelle jetzt auch freuen, wenn das Ding im App Store landet.
Ich klicke auf Clemens will Muskeln und kriege das Video.
Stimmt, die zeigen mehr oder weniger immer die gleichen Stellen.
Aber wahrscheinlich, ich meine, die App wird jetzt auch nicht allzu lang sein.
Ich meine, ein bisschen HTML und Embedded YouTube Videos mit ein paar Scheiß...
Also das wird nicht so lang sein.
Wahrscheinlich sind das irgendwie 300 Zeilen mit allem zusammen oder so.
Sie benutzen ein iFrame ja wahrscheinlich für YouTube, oder?
Leute, ich habe die Idee.
Wir gucken jetzt mal.
Wir gucken uns jetzt Clemens Kartoffel an.
Ohne App gucken wir uns Clemens Kartoffel an.
Oh fuck.
Moment.
Ich muss mir das mal kurz abschreiben.
Was haben wir denn da?
Oh fuck.
Da muss ich mich...
Wir gucken uns jetzt Clemens Kartoffel an.
Oh Mist.
Ich habe die Slash.
Das habe ich.
Falsche Tastaturlayout.
Mal gucken, ob ich vertippt habe.
Nein.
Wir können uns Clemens Kartoffel ohne die App angucken.
Okay, wir müssen uns Clemens Kartoffel nicht wirklich angucken.
Aber ich wollte nur gucken, ob die Ults auch stimmen, die sie reingesteht zeigen im Video.
Wenn ich da jetzt raufpicke, dann fängt es tatsächlich an.
Aber Clemens, du bist eine Kartoffel.
Da bist du rund genau richtig.
Voll gut.
Siehst du?
Check, check.
Jetzt muss ich meine App nur noch in die Stores kriegen.
Nur wenn ich keinen größeren Fehler gemacht habe, wird sie angenommen.
Heißt also noch mal zittern.
Was würdet ihr eigentlich programmieren, wenn ihr programmieren könntet und eine App
rausschicken dürftet?
Oh Gott, das war es.
Auf Wiedersehen sage ich.
Und ich sage hoffentlich nehmen die das an.
Ich glaube schon.
Also ich bin dir für alles sehr dankbar.
Daumen drücken.
Bis die App draußen ist.
Nein.
Nein, nicht so.
Sondern so.
Okay.
Leute, ihr seht mich wahnsinnig aufgeregt.
Clemens Kartoffel rastet fast aus.
Denn wenn alles gut gegangen ist, müsst ihr jetzt eine kleine Clemens Kartoffel-App
auf diesem Handy machen.
Wow.
Das ist ganz öffentlich.
Das ist jetzt, das ist nicht nur hier, sondern das ist, das kann man jetzt auf der ganzen
Welt.
Oh Gott.
Das laden wir uns an.
Installiert.
Erst mal selbst geliked.
Aber hallo.
Also ich sag mal so, als wir das da reingestellt haben, haben der Alex und ich vielleicht jetzt
kein so richtig gutes breites Bild gehabt.
Und jetzt sieht er ein bisschen dick aus.
Okay.
Schön, dass ihr da seid.
Mein Name ist Ariane Alter und das ist Clemens Kartoffel.
Mega geil.
Wow.
Also Leute, ihr wisst ja gut.
An welche Art von Leuten ist das Gerichte total cringe?
Ja, dann habt ihr recht, dass das total cringe ist.
An die Leute, die gerne Bayerischen Rundfunk gucken.
Was ihr jetzt machen müsst, diese App runterladen.
Wir reden von müssen.
Nicht sollen dürfen wollen.
Nee.
Okay.
Wo ist die App?
App Store?
Play Store?
Verbindung zum iTunes Store wird hergestellt.
Das zeigt das Ding meistens an, wenn die App nicht mal da ist.
Aber Android funktioniert.
Fünf.
Versiv.
Sind das insgesamt Downloads oder Bewertungen?
Vorgasseier.
Das sind 5253 Bewertungen.
Huge.
Hat irgendjemand eine Ahnung, wie ich eine APK runtergeladen kriege vom Play Store, ohne
mich anzumelden?
Gibt es bestimmt irgendwelche fertigen Scripts, für die das machen.
Müssen wir jetzt ausprobieren.
Ich muss mir jetzt den Source Code von Clemens Kartoffel angucken.
Übrigens gibt es ein Update, was meine Heizung anbelangt.
Wow.
Ach nee, nicht Localhost.
Meine Heizung spackt nämlich immer noch rum.
Ihr seht es schon wieder, die Pumpe pumpt nicht.
Morgen kommt der Heizungs-Man.
Heizt alles, Kessel-Temperatur, Status okay, Warm-Wassertemperatur okay, aber die Pumpe
pumpt nicht.
Und ich hab jetzt was Neues.
Muss jetzt mal gucken, ob ich euch das zeigen kann.
Ich muss erstmal die Kameras rumdrehen kurz, dass ich euch das zeigen kann.
Ich hab jetzt nämlich noch was Neues.
Ich hab jetzt sogar im Keller noch eine Kamera installiert, die mir den Druck von der Heizung
anzeigt.
Die Kamera ist ein bisschen nah dran, deswegen ist es unscharf.
Und das Problem ist der Druck, ich glaub die Heizung ist undicht.
Sieht aus wie ein Horrorgame, ist halt schon ein bisschen weiß.
Die Heizung ist undicht, weil, ich hab gestern wieder nachgefüllt, da war das hier, und jetzt
ist es wieder auf 1 runter.
Ich glaub das Ding ist undicht an irgendeiner Stelle.
Ich hab jetzt nämlich innerhalb von 2 Wochen schon, gestern war das dritte Mal, das dritte
Mal, ähm, was mag Defekt, was es mag?
Zumindest ist es zu wenig drauf.
Das ist ziemlich ja Sack.
Das heißt morgen kommt dann der Heizungsman und guckt sich das mal an.
Ausdehnungsgefäß.
Oh, das muss ich mir aufschreiben.
Der war voll überrascht, mein Heizungsmann, als ich ihm erzählt hab, ich werte das ganze
aus und hab da jetzt in den letzten paar Tagen hier ein paar Statistiken drüber.
Und ich weiß, dass, äh, wann der Brenner angeht, dass die Pumpe nicht funktioniert,
was die Kessel, äh, die Kessel Temperatur ist, die Abgas Temperatur.
Und dann hab ich gesagt, wie kriegen Sie das denn raus?
Und ich sag, ja, ich hab mir, ich hab mir so ein Optolink von Wiesmann bestellt, Raspberry
Pi, hab angeschlossen, lese das ganze aus.
Dann hab ich gesagt, was das geht?
Das geht?
Aha!
Da war voll überrascht, äh.
Das heißt, wenn der morgen vorbeikommt, zeig ich ihm das mal.
Ähm, was er auch gemeint hat, ist irgendwie, ja, wie alt ist der?
60 oder so, ähm, was er gemeint hat, ist, ja, er weiß, dass es von Wiesmann sowas gibt,
wo, dass er das dann auch sehen kann, ähm, das Problem ist, dass dieses offizielle Wiesmann
Zeug halt, ähm, äh, übelst viel Geld kostet und nicht so gut ist für ihn, wie das der
Fall, ich hab's gebaut hab.
Ist das Wasser kalt und die Heizkörper beziehungsweise Fußball?
Ja.
Nee, das Wasser ist nicht kalt.
Also, das Wasser aus dem Wasserhahn, wenn ich, wenn ich, ähm, Wasser aufdrehe, das funktioniert.
Aber die Heizung ist kalt.
So, wir laden uns nebenbei jetzt erst mal hier, ähm, Clemens Kartoffel runter.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob's da Monkertoss-Werbung gibt hier drauf.
So, Clemens Kartoffel runtergeladen.
Verkauf ihm deine Lösung.
Das Problem an solchen Lösungen ist, die funktionieren daheim wunderbar.
Die mögen auch zu 99% funktionieren.
Aber wenn man sich jetzt überlegt, man installiert sowas mit einer Verfügbarkeit von 99% und
hat, und hatten nur 100 Kunden, da gehen einem laufend die Kunden auf den Keks, ähm, das,
was kaputt ist.
Also, sind wir bei einem kaputt.
Also da, da, da, für, für ein halbes Gebrauch ist das super, super.
Wenn ich da ab und zu mal gucken muss im Jahr, weil irgendwas nicht geht, ist okay.
Aber wenn das der Fachmann verwendet, ähm, dann ist es zu fehleranfällig, was ich hier
gestrickt hab.
Dann ist die Heizkreis-Umwälzpumpe fest.
Kannst du die anderen Pumpe für warm Wasser auch sehen?
Oh.
Das muss ich nachher mal ausprobieren.
Die Dinger sind halt ein bisschen doof benannt.
Das müsste ich nachher mal gucken, weiß ich.
Das müsste ich mal schauen.
Ich kann alle, ich kann die intern, ich hab, ich kann abfragen, Pumpe 1, Pumpe 2 und Pumpe
intern.
Kann ich alles abfragen, ja.
So, wir, wir entpacken jetzt aber erstmal Kleemanns Kartoffel.
Ähm, hier, wie entpackt man Kleemanns Kartoffel?
Kann man einfach so ein APK?
Easy, einfach so APK entpacken.
Eats AF kann man dazu nur sagen.
Eats AF.
Manchmal, manchmal muss ich wirklich sagen, äh, cringe es bei mir selber, äh.
Wenn ich mich, wenn ich vorm Rechner sitze, ja, und quasi vor mich hinsage Eats AF, Eats
AF und mich freue, dann hab ich echt so meine Zweifel, ob ich echt 35 bin und noch ganz
dicht im Kopf war.
Alter, mein Rechner ruckelt übelst rum.
Was ist hier los?
Mein Vorschau-Rechner ruckelt übelst rum.
But why?
Ah, wegen der Kamera wahrscheinlich.
So, ähm, äh, Moment, wie, wie, wie, ja gut, wenn das ein ZIP ist, kann ich einfach unzip
machen?
Ah, ich, oh nee, jetzt hat er alles noch in Downloads extrahiert.
Igitt.
Äh, äh, ok.
Ich, ich verschiebe das nochmal.
Und ZIP.
So, jetzt aber.
Also, was haben wir denn alles drinne?
Ähm, hohohoho, Bild, nach Bild müssen wir, Bild.
Cordova?
Ich dachte, es ist Ionic oder verwendet Ionic Cordova irgendwie unter der Haube.
Aber vielleicht, ich hab immer da nicht so.
Android Manifest, Clemens Kartoffel, also hier ist anscheinend das Interessante drin.
App.js?
Bild.
Hier, hier müssen wir, hier müssen wir reingucken.
Oder?
Wo, wo, wo ist hier, wo, wo ist hier der Interessante so aus Core drinne?
Hm.
Was machst du eigentlich beruflich?
Ich hab dazu ein Video mal gemacht, wenn dich das interessiert, ausführlich.
Ich hab da mal ein Video zugemacht und zwar noch gar nicht so lange her.
Am 18.
Oktober 2019, da hab ich mich 14 Minuten drüber ausgelassen, was ich auf der Arbeit mach.
Kannste hier von mir auf YouTube angucken, wenn du es genau wissen willst.
Das ist dann relativ ausführlich.
So, wo ist denn jetzt hier das Zeug drin?
Das muss eigentlich unter Bild sein, oder?
Main.js?
Main.css?
Ich würde mal sagen, Index.
Ne, nun müssen wir mal rein.
Assets, oder wo ist der ganze Kram drunter?
Assets.
www.
Ähm.
Index.
Ok, das ist Boilerblade, äh, sonst was gedünns.
Also müssen wir, Bild.
Wahrscheinlich können wir uns das nicht angucken, weil es Minifight ist, oder so.
Ne, ist es nicht.
Import.
Kafka-Page.
The fuck, Alter.
Was ist das?
Das ist doch nicht von Hand gebastelt hier, oder?
Das ist doch automatisch generiert.
Das ist automatisch generiert, das, äh, zusammen, zusammengefügte Source-Zeug.
Das ist, äh, nachschwanger Prototype.
Na gut, den richtigen Source-Code haben wir halt nicht, ne.
Ähm, haben wir da sonst noch irgendwas interessantes drinne?
Main.css.
Bevor, bevor, bevor, Alter.
Ah, das ist, das ist, das ist alles Ionic-generated, also den richtigen Source-Code, den kriegen
wir an der Stelle nicht.
Aber das Index, wo war denn Index hier nochmal?
Irgendwo muss doch, irgendwo muss doch das JavaScript gedünns sein.
Äh, das, das HTML gedünns.
Irgendwo muss das HTML gedünns sein.
Oder ist das HTML gedünns wie bei React im JavaScript drinne?
Hat sie also doch nicht, nö.
Da stand was von 10 Doppelpunkt-Users Alex.
Die haben das da irgendwie zusammen gemacht, das wird schon, das, das würde ich jetzt
mal nicht so überbewerten.
Wir gucken uns grad die App an aus dem Videobeitrag von eben.
Äh, doch, doch, das hat die schon selbst gemacht.
Das, das sieht, das sieht nicht wie was aus bisher, was irgendjemand gemacht hat, das
schon eine Weile macht.
Ich denke, man kann das mit einem Node-Webserver starten.
Ach nee, lass mich das gar nicht ausführen.
Ähm, haben wir hier Manifest.
Okay, nee, nee, nee, also wirklich großartig angucken können wir uns das Ganze nicht.
Das ist halt, äh, Minif, nein nicht Minifight, aber zusammengefügt und ein bisschen transpiled
und so, das, das, das können wir, können wir nicht wirklich viel drin erkennen.
Vielleicht können wir aus den Map-Files ein bisschen was raus.
Oh fuck.
Was, Android-Manifest soll ich mir angucken?
Hier.
Wo ist denn das?
Was ist hier?
Ja, wo ist das?
Meta, hier.
Was da?
Generated by, ja, das ist, das ist, das ist sie.
Du hast es übersehen.
Ach da, da ist es doch, hier.
Android-Manifest.
Woah.
Das soll ein XML sein?
Das sieht mir nicht aus wie ein XML.
Das ist ein Android-XML.
Oh, what?
Dann haben wir da sonst noch schönes drin, ein Bildchen.
Also ich glaube, dass der schon, dass die das selbst gemacht hat.
Das ist jetzt nicht so die HugeBrain App und in drei Monaten kriegt man das hin.
Das würde ich da keinem unterstellen, dass das irgendwie gefakt ist.
Das erscheint mir jetzt irgendwie zumindest halbwegs mit Unterstützung legit.
Wie würdest du das auf der Arbeit bewerten?
Gar nicht, weil das ist, ich sehe ja den, ich sehe ja den ursprünglichen Code, ich sehe
ja das, was Ionic da im Endeffekt als Bild raushaut.
Da erkennt man gar nichts.
Warum sollten die das auch faken?
Ja, da fallen mir ein paar Gründe ein.
Weil ohne die App würde der Beitrag nicht richtig funktionieren.
Aber wie gesagt, ich glaube nicht, dass das gefakt ist.
Das macht, irgendwie passt das zusammen.
So, was schauen wir jetzt als nächstes?
Erstmal die Musik resetten.
Kein Essen oben, fuck.
Was ist denn jetzt oben rechts?
Lockpicking.
Jetzt Blizzard Talk.
Guck mal, was wir noch zur Auswahl haben.
Wir haben irgendwas über den Playstation 4 Emulator.
Wir haben Windows 10 Tipps, die keiner braucht.
Wir haben einen Battlefield 4 Gameplay.
Wir haben einen Single Board Computer mit Grafikkarte.
Irgendwas zu Doom.
Ein Linux Desktop auf WSL.
Die Top Plays, HRQ Plays, das machen wir mal zu.
Das haben wir gerade geguckt.
Der App Store hat es rausgeschmissen.
Ein paar Lockpicks.
Und den Blizzard Talk.
Der PS4 Emulator.
Wir gucken uns die Sachen hier vorher noch an.
Weil die gehen nur eine Viertelstunde.
Weil das Blizzard Talk Video geht halt 40 Minuten an.
Wir gucken uns die zwei Sachen vorher an.
Das geht nur 5 Minuten und 10 Minuten.
Dann gucken wir uns das Blizzard Talk Video an.
Oder seid ihr schon wach?
Laut genug.
PS4 Emulator.
Ich frage mich gerade, ob nichts mit einem PS4 Emulator
prinzipiell einfacher ist als mit einem PS3 Emulator.
Weil ein PS4 ist halt viel, viel näher an einem
stinknormalen Desktop System ran.
Also du musst zumindest schon mal da keine CPU
Architekturen emulieren.
Zwischen PS4 und einem normalen PC.
Weil der PS3 sieht das ganz anders aus.
Also ich würde so aus dem Bauch raus sagen,
PS3 Emulator ist wahrscheinlich sogar schwieriger
als PS4 Emulator.
Wieso benutzt du eigentlich Windows als
Main OS und Linux in der VFM?
Weil es die beste Kombination ist.
Windows unter Linux ist eklig.
Also quasi Windows VFM unter Linux ist nicht so schön
wie eine Linux VFM unter Windows.
Und ich brauche Windows halt für Spiele,
ein bisschen Videokram und das ganze Streaming Zeug.
Also sprich, ich brauche Software und Geräte,
die so unter Linux nicht tun.
Und dementsprechend ist es einfacher.
So, gucken wir weiter.
Bisschen lauter.
Mach ich.
Achso.
Man konnte vorher immer den Controller verwenden.
Das ist natürlich ein bisschen blöd.
Ja, das dachte ich ja.
Ja, das dachte ich.
Zum Glück sind die PS4...
Ach, Moment.
Ich wollte grad sagen, zum Glück sind die PS4 Keys geleakt.
Aber das waren die PS3 Keys.
Warum laufen da keine Spiele?
Wahrscheinlich Verschlüsselung, Gruppierschutz
und generell das Fehlen vieler Funktionen, die Spiele brauchen,
dass sie überhaupt starten.
Eine Kombination daraus.
Achso.
Wisst ihr was ich gerade gedacht hab?
Ich dachte es wäre Nier Automata
bloß mit massive Graphik-Clitches.
Aber nee, das ist ein anderes Game.
Spockelt ein bisschen.
auf einer besseren Leistung.
Ein paar Tage später sahen wir auch
mehrere Verbesserungen, die Audio-Renderung
an den Emulatoren addierten,
nun wieder etwas gebrochenen Audio
in We Are Doomed zu spielen.
Schnell weiter, noch vier Tage
der Entwicklung, und dank der Verbesserungen
wieder zu ihrem Audio-Backend,
haben sie nun Audio korrektiert
in a We Are Doomed on a GPCS4.
Oh, also, in vier Tagen
kann man sich da nicht beschweren, ne?
Da Anthem ist nach einem halben Jahr
immer noch kaputt.
Oder Wolzen, ne?
These guys have been putting in
some killer work lately
and regardless of their...
Werden sich die neuen Konsolen
deiner Meinung nach lohnen,
die Xbox Series X-Vita 12 Teraflops haben?
Ich weiß gar nicht,
was bei denen abgeht,
dass sie da irgendwie groß
mit Teraflops um sich schmeißen,
damit kann der normale Usainics anfangen.
Also, 12 Teraflops,
ich weiß gar nicht, auf was ich das beziehe.
Wahrscheinlich auf die GPU allein,
also ich weiß nicht,
also, das ist ungefähr so schnell
wie eine 1080 Ti, so im Dreh,
was schon ziemlich gut ist im Vergleich
zu dem, was damals rausgekommen ist
von, bei der letzten Generation.
Also, ich denke schon,
dass die neuen Konsolen...
Die PlayStation setzt sich
in Deutschland eh durch.
Deutschland bzw. Europa,
aber Deutschland allgemein
ist halt PlayStation-Land schlechthin.
Spackt das Audio, das liegt an dem Video.
Ich muss mal übrigens gucken,
ob Unity Media heute rumspackt.
Nein, Unity Media funktioniert wunderbar.
Eins?
Inwiefern spackt mein Audio rum?
Hab ich mein Noise Gate
zu empfindlich eingestellt oder wie?
Test, test, test, test, test, test, test, test.
Test, test, test, test, test, test, test.
Also, ich muss leiser
so reden dass es ausschaltet also sprich wenn ich so rede in der lautstärke dann ist
noch alles an erst wenn ich aus ungefähr in der größten ordnung geht es aus
ne also ich glaube nicht dass mein neues gett ausschaltet ehrlich gesagt es muss
irgendwie hier sein dass es ausschalten ich bin da
ich weiß aber in vier tagen den audio zu fixen ist schon mal nicht schlecht
aber so wie es aussieht kann man auf dem ps4 emulator spielen ok also es gibt noch
kein ordentlichen ps4 emulator ich habe mir ein paar zaps vergessen leechak1978 hatte resubbed
extremer hat resubbed burple hatte ich schon hat auch resubbed dankeschön für die ganzen zaps
immerhin zwölf fps mehr sieht das auge eh nicht wie man ja offensichtlich sieht ihr
seht ihr könnt ja alle gar nicht erkennen dass das ruckelt wir kommen uns jetzt noch
den singelbord computer an wtf was ist das
der ist die grafiker der zählt mal so groß wie das ding
irgendwie ist die lautstärke kacke
was kostet so ein ding was latte panda alpha
wtf
warum sollte ich so was kaufen für den preis
was ist da drauf was ist ok ok vielleicht bin ich ein bisschen vielleicht bin ich ein
bisschen so schnell was was ist da an hardware drauf
core m3 das ist irgendein mobile ding
die cpu ist ordentlich ram ist auch ordentlich das ist schon ganz ok von der hardware aber
das ist schon ein ordentlicher preis für den singelbord computer
ich glaube der hauptsächliche der hauptsächliche vorteil davon dürfte halt eben tatsächlich
die größe aber trotzdem also man kann sich über den anwendungszweck streiten aber gucken
wir mal was rauskommt
der nuke ist nicht viel größer ja ich weiß ich habe mir absichtlich keinen nuke gekauft
für die neue kiste hier weil ich erweitere weil ich erweiterung gebraucht habe das ist
halt gut das hat am pc express in nuke hat kein pc express
warte mal warte mal moment
ja was nun läuft es jetzt über usb der strom oder über einen stecker
oder ist es ist oder oder geht beides man kann es darüber betreiben oder darüber betreiben
wenn er sagt usb aber es ist nun aber es ist ein stecker dran
ok ich weiß nicht was ein core m3 ist aber das dürfte wahrscheinlich so die mobile variante
von dem i3 sein lpd ok der ram ist uralt
1866 64 gigabytes of internal storage but you can use an sd card and external hard drive
or an in das ist ganz schön teuer
as for operating system ist ein klein windows 10 linux
das ist halt klein dass das mag der vorteil sein aber ich wüsste nicht wo also ich habe
gerade wirklich legit keinen anwendungszweck dafür
weil meistens ist die leistung gar nicht das was man braucht
sondern halt der formfaktor
deswegen ist ja so ein raspberry pi 0 ich habe mehr zeros im einsatz als normales vorbei
ne stimmt nicht
zumindest ich finde den raspberry pi 0 an sich praktischer als die normalen einfach
weil man den sogar sogar in steckdosen reinkriegt
wie viele piles hast du denn am laufe das war ich glaube drei stück gerade ein am 3d
trocker ein für die access points ein im keller für die halsung
und hier oben ab und zu ein paar dinger zum testen aber so wirklich 24 7 und und und mit
wichtigen funktionen laufen gerade drei stück
was ein bisschen mehr läuft sind sp 2866 und sp 32
so mit so dinge haben wir ja auch schon rum
hantiert wer sich noch dran erinnert das sieht dann immer ein bisschen falsch aus
es sieht immer ein bisschen falsch aus wenn man die netzwerkarte verkehrter
rum auf dem mainboard hat
was für die acpo haben wir nicht in hohen flaschen als
und das alles über usbc nähe nicht über usbc anscheinend ist ja nur die stromversorgung
usbc der rest nicht
von
Die Dinger sind wirklich gut. Davon hab ich auch ein paar.
Hab ich euch ja gezeigt. Sogar hier meine neue...
...Kiste, die ich jetzt... Ich glaube, man sieht was.
Okay, man sieht nicht viel. Man sieht...
Man sieht, wo ich den Kram reingeschmissen habe ins Gehäuse.
Aber man sieht hier auch, das ist auch so eine Pico PSU.
Das ist einfach random ins Gehäuse reingeschmissen, der Kram.
Wie hat der denn ein 16x in 4x bekommen? Einfach aufgeschnitten hinten.
Oder aber es ist offen.
Das müssen wir uns mal angucken. Hat man das hier gesehen?
Ja, guck, der Vierfachslot ist hinten offen.
Kannste einfach reinstecken. Guck dann halt hinten raus.
Das geht. Das ist kein Problem.
Du sagst, du hast Raspberry Pi als Wi-Fi-Point.
Ne, ne, ne. Ich hab den Raspberry Pi als Web-Interface für meine Access Points.
Also mein UniFi-Controller läuft auf dem Raspberry Pi.
Die Kamera-Software läuft auch auf dem Raspberry Pi.
Und ein paar andere kleine Sachen, ein MQTT-Controller läuft auf dem Raspberry Pi.
Ne, aber hauptsächlich ist der für die Access Points.
Ich hab zwei UniFi, ich hab einen AEPro und den neuen AEPro.
Ich finde das immer so geil, wenn ihr das ausbringt.
Molex, SATA.
Das sieht irgendwie ein bisschen falsch aus.
Ich finde es ein bisschen komplex.
Das sieht irgendwie ein bisschen falsch aus, das USB-C da dran.
Aber warum nicht? Ich meine, das ist ja keine Daten drüber.
Das ist ja einfach nur Strom.
Machst du auf deinen Raspberry Pi regelmäßig von Hand Updates?
Regelmäßig, unregelmäßig mache ich da drauf Updates.
Wir haben es verstanden, so komplex ist das Ganze jetzt auch nicht.
Wir haben es verstanden, wie der Kram angeschlossen ist.
Ich bin ein 120 Watt, 12 Volt Power Supply.
Auch wenn ich einen Power Brick benutze, ist das ganze Gerät sehr kompakt.
Ich konnte sogar den ganzen Power Supply auf die GPU zerstören.
Ich habe dann die Wagen aufgeschnitten und denke, dass das ganze Gerät gut aussieht.
Ich denke, das ganze Gerät gut aussieht.
Ich finde, das sieht irgendwie falsch aus.
Das sieht irgendwie falsch aus.
Das sieht aus wie eine riesen Grafikkarte mit einer kleinen Grafikkarte obendrauf.
Oder? Es sieht aus, als steckt eine Grafikkarte auf einer Grafikkarte.
Das scheint nur PC Express.
Ich meine, performancemäßig ist das Ding natürlich
meilenweit besser als jeder Raspberry Pi, als sonst so ziemlich jeder andere
armbasierter Single Board Computer, besser als den Shield TV
oder als sonst was.
Also wer irgendwie so einen High Performance Media Center braucht,
ist das wahrscheinlich gar nicht.
Das ist auch besser als ein Raspberry Pi Cluster.
Also was ist denn das, ein Vierkern?
Ne, zeig mal her.
Oh fuck.
Was? Core? Core? M3?
Was war da drinnen?
Ja, zwar Dual Core ist das trotzdem.
Performancemäßig dürfte das Ding schon ordentlich Power haben im Vergleich zu den Alternativen.
Allerdings ist halt die Frage, inwieweit man das braucht.
So ein Shield TV ist halt eine super Sache.
Oder wenn man es günstiger haben will, so ein Fire TV Stick, wenn man einen Media Center braucht.
Und wenn man halt richtig was spielen will, richtig Power haben will,
dann stellt man sich halt ein kleines Gehäuse hin mit aktueller Desktop Hardware hin.
Also der Anwendungszweck erschließt sich mir noch nicht so hundertpro,
aber es ist cool, dass es geht.
Ja gut, wenn du einen Raspberry Pi Cluster aus 72 Stück hinstellst,
dann hast du wahrscheinlich schon theoretisch schnellere CPU-Leistung,
aber du musst den Kram erstmal sinken.
Okay, jetzt kommt erstmal Cortana und nervt.
Okay, das sind zwei Cores mit Hyper Threading, oder?
Okay, was ist das in M3? 7, Y, 3, 0. 7, Y, 3, 0. M3.
Okay, was ist da drinnen?
2016, okay, schon ein bisschen her.
Lumber of Cores. Ja, Dual Core mit Hyper Threading ist das hier.
Curve Display. Wir haben auf der Arbeit ein Curve Display,
was wirklich verdammt ähnlich zu dem hier aussieht,
bloß dass es ein 21 zu 9 Display ist.
Weil könnte das hier auch sein.
Es ist gewöhnungsbedürftig.
Es ist gewöhnungsbedürftig, aber es fällt einem eigentlich gar nicht mehr auf,
nachdem man eine Weile davor gesessen hat.
Das muss man bei mir auf der Arbeit wirklich lassen.
Die Arbeitsplätze sind echt in Ordnung.
21,9, 21 Zoll, nicht 21 Zoll, 21 zu 9.
Was ist jetzt 32 Zoll? 4K Bildschirm.
Leider nur 60 Hertz.
Ihr wisst, ich hätte gerne lieber mehr, aber das war damals noch nicht drin.
Ein höhenverstellbarer Schreibtisch, ein ordentliches Notebook.
Das ist ganz in Ordnung.
Wir können ruhigen Gewissens in die Stellenbeschreibung schreiben,
moderner Arbeitsplatz, und es ist wirklich ein moderner Arbeitsplatz,
schreiben aber alle rein.
Und letztendlich, die Nvidia GTX 1650.
Ich bin wirklich interessiert, wie das mit PC-Gaming auf 1080p funktioniert.
Das geht. Das dürfte...
880p spielen, damit dürfte kein großes Problem.
Das sollte wunderbar funktionieren.
Kommt halt auf das Game und die Grafik-Settings an, aber prinzipiell ist es kein Problem.
Ja, das funktioniert.
Das wundert mich auch nicht, dass das geht.
Ganz ehrlich, wenn man sich die Specks anguckt,
surprised mich das überhaupt nicht.
Erstens läuft das Spiel prinzipiell gut,
und die Kombi aus einem halbwegs modernen Dual-Core,
ich meine 2016, aber aus einem halbwegs modernen Dual-Core
und einer ganz guten Grafikkarte, kein Wunder, dass das läuft.
Kommt nicht bald das neue Doom?
Oh, Rennspiele.
Residenz-Liter-Rennspiele.
80-90% Last, der ist doch gut.
Dann schafft es wenigstens, war es das Ding.
Die Grafikkarte wird es wahrscheinlich nicht limitieren, eher die CPU.
Vermute ich jetzt einfach mal.
Ist das GTA?
Das geht schon in Ordnung.
Der hat jetzt nicht wirklich ausgepiepst, oder?
Gut, also ganz ehrlich, CS läuft auf dem Taschenrechner mittlerweile.
Massive Headshots.
Leute, habt ihr es gerade gehört?
Man hört den Reload-Sound, aber er reloadet nicht.
Oder ist das gar nicht der Reload-Sound?
Das ist eine Tastatur gewesen.
Doom 1 läuft auf einer Regelung von Erheizung.
Ja, Doom 1 läuft echt auf allem.
Doom 1 läuft auch auf einem Epson-Drucker zum Laufen gebracht.
Jetzt kommen wir gleich danach.
Es gibt keine Plattform mehr, auf der es kein Skyrim gibt.
Dann müssen wir ein paar Mods installieren, dann hat er 5 FPS.
Okay, wir haben es jetzt verstanden, dass das läuft.
Das stimmt, dafür ist es wahrscheinlich ziemlich praktisch.
Nicht unbedingt für den Switch-Emulator, aber für...
Aber Gamecube und Wii-Emulation mit Dolphin ist toll, solange die Spiele mit dem Emulator kompatibel sind.
Dieses System läuft.
Das ist Mario Kart Double Dash bei 1080p.
Also kann man also ein System unter Gamecube machen, außer für PS2.
Wenn man PSP oder Sega Saturn machen möchte, kann man es machen.
Ja, sehr schön.
Für 99 Cent die Woche.
Leute, ist das wirklich so?
99 Cent die Woche, Amazon Prime, was man damit alles machen kann.
Also den Anwendungszweck sehe ich nicht wirklich.
Es ist cool auf jeden Fall, dass das geht und dass das so gut tut.
Aber einen wirklichen Anwendungszweck dafür habe ich nicht.
So Leute, ich habe es doch versprochen, wir gucken auf das GameStar-Video.
Auf geht's.
Aber was haben wir denn hier?
40 Minuten Maurice, der über Blizzard meckert.
Das kann ja nur was taugen.
Die Aufgaben vom BND?
Nee, das haben wir noch nicht ausprobiert.
Oh, ein bisschen leise, hä?
Oh, das Video ist aber übelst leise.
Das Video ist übelst leise.
Ich mache gleich noch einen Ticken lauter.
Aber wir müssen erst mal gucken, wie laut die anderen beiden eingestellt sind.
Jetzt haben sie sich richtig eingestellt.
Okay, jetzt habe ich ihnen überhaupt nicht zugehört.
Und dass sie
das möglichst, möglichst, ähm, beste aus, aus, ja, sagen wir mal, Hardcore-Gaming-Perspektive
abzuliefern, sondern das, was Kohle macht.
Als Nass, na trotzdem, als Nass würde ich auch was anderes verwenden.
Die Stonks sind wichtiger, so sieht's aus.
Spielst du noch Overwatch?
Nee, schon eine ganze Weile nicht mehr.
Hu, äh, ja, hast du dir gleich mal ein Flaggschiff überlegt, um so zu starten?
Ja, natürlich, natürlich.
Also, äh, ich glaub nicht, dass Blizzard die Community nicht mehr versteht, ich glaub
nur, dass Blizzard, äh, mehr als früher einfach, äh, vor allen Dingen durch die
ganze, den Firmenzusammen- Kohle machen.
Ähm, mit Activision Blizzard mehr auf Dinge guckt, die sich irgendwie rechnen und was
man tun muss, um Geld zu verdienen.
So sieht's aus.
Und wie, wie sehr es sich lohnt, in bestimmte Dinge zu investieren, sei es jetzt neue Projekte,
sei es, äh, Innovation oder so.
Schade, du hast einen stabilen Lucio gespielt, das ist schön zu hören.
Aber ich kann mir Overwatch jetzt nicht geben, es tut sich in dem Game einfach zu wenig.
Ja, Status zu halten, ähm, was jetzt die Qualität von den...
Wie man mehr Geld verdient.
Ja, da hat er Recht.
Wenn man das als Produkt sieht, angeht, bin ich nach wie vor der Meinung, dass das ganz,
ganz oben ist bei dem, was man so auf dem Markt sieht, vielleicht sind die einen oder
anderen Releases problematisch, ja, das haben wir jetzt ja neulich erst gesehen, ähm, aber
ich sag mal, das eigentliche Spiel, ja, die Crispiness, wie es immer so schön da genannt
wird und, ähm, das Gameplay...
Blizzard, Blizzard hat halt so ein bisschen die, die, diese magische Aura verloren, was
die Sachen, äh, von Blizzard früher umgeben hat.
Ich glaub, das trifft's eigentlich ganz gut.
Das hatte schon Overwatch nicht mehr richtig, ähm, mein, mein, mein Eindruck bei der ganzen
Sache, das hatte schon Overwatch nicht mehr richtig, aber Overwatch war wenigstens, war
wenigstens was Innovatives an sich, ja, ähm, mach die Maus da weg, nee, geht nicht.
Und so weiter, das, das ist schon immer noch ganz weit oben.
Problem ist halt ein bisschen die Innovation, die, äh, von diesem Konzern eben nicht mehr
so kommt, wie man sich erwünscht hat.
Allerdings, wenn man mal genau hinschaut, äh, kommt auch das Zitat, Innovation is overrated,
ja, auch von Blizzard, weil sie eigentlich relativ wenig Innovation über die ganzen
Jahre gemacht haben.
Blizzard hat schon viel erzählt, die letzten zwanzig Jahre.
Es wurde nur von den besten geklaut, in Anführungszeichen, und das dann einfach refined, bis es wirklich
richtig, richtig super war.
Insofern, ich glaub schon, ähm, dass Blizzard, also, grad der kreative Teil ist, der vieler
oder...
Er guckt so ein bisschen, wie so, ich möchte auch was gefragt werden.
Nachdenken, was denn Spieler wollen, sie haben ja auch ihren eigenen, ihre eigenen zehn
oder zwölf Regeln da, äh, so wie so eine, zehn Gebote, nach denen sie sich da, äh,
wo sie sich auch fügen möchten.
Wie sowas?
Nur, letztendlich ist auch immer die Frage, ist das was, was denn am Ende Geld verdient?
Mhm.
Wobei ich schon das Gefühl hab, dass, also, die Produktqualität ist die eine Sache, aber
in der Kommunikation vor allem, hab ich das Gefühl, dass Blizzard sich schon sehr viele...
Und Blizzard ist halt auch mittlerweile ein relativ großer Laden.
Man darf nicht vergessen, Blizzard hat Hearthstone am Start, Heroes of the Storm, wobei Heroes
of the Storm ist jetzt ein bisschen, ein bisschen zurückgegangen, ähm, Starcraft, WoW, also
die haben sau viel Sachen am Start, ähm, das machst du nicht mehr mit 40 Leuten.
Fehltritte geleistet hat in letzter Zeit, zum Beispiel, dass jetzt Diablo Immortal vielleicht
nicht gut ankommen würde, wenn du seit Jahren nichts anderes zu Diablo...
Die Mobile.
Sie hatten natürlich, fairness halber, nichts anderes anzukündigen, aber, dass sie völlig
überrumpelt waren davon, dass ihre Hardcore-Audience das blöd fand, auf ihre Hausmesse, dass
da nur ein Mobile-Spiel kommt, das finde ich Zeug schon so ein bisschen davon, also, das
war doch, hätte sich jeder denken können, war so mein erster Gedanke, ich saß ja im
Publikum damals, äh, und jetzt genauso auch bei Warcraft 3 Reforged, wie du sagst, da
werden wahrscheinlich rechnerische Gedanken dahinterstehen, dass man sagt, okay, so viel
Aufwand lohnt das nicht, aber das dann irgendwie...
Diablo Immortal.
...konzentriert zu kriegen an die Spieler in einer Form, die den Shitstorm auch nur
annähern.
Ich hab's schon so oft gesagt, wo es um diese Diablo-Geschichte geht, ne, die hätten einfach
nur Diablo 4 teasern müssen, so wie die es mit Elder Scrolls gemacht haben, und die hätten
auch einfach drei Stunden, drei Jäger nichts mal sagen können danach, es ist egal, die
hätten Immortal angekündigt und hätten sie gesagt, übrigens, Diablo 4, bam, und fertig.
...quasi eindämmen kann, und das ist ja in letzter Zeit doch oft mehrfach schon bei Blizzard
gewesen, dass sie in solchen Fällen, vielleicht auch weil Blizzard früher solche Fälle gar
nicht so oft hatte, nicht wissen musste, wie man mit den Spielern spricht, und es gab ja
auch, oder?
Das ist vielleicht der gute Punkt, Blizzard früher war ja sehr, auch sehr strikt in seiner
eigenen Kommunikation, auch sehr zurückhaltend, also in uns alles dauerte immer sehr lange,
bis Dinge gezeigt wurden, zum Beispiel StarCraft 2 damals wurde ja...
Dafür war der Kram, wenn Blizzard irgendwas in der Beta rausgebracht hat, mein Overwatch,
als es in der Beta rausgekommen hat, das war technisch und von dem wie das lief und online-mäßig
besser als viele fertige Spiele, und eins kann man Overwatch wirklich nicht nachsagen, auch
wenn ich nicht mehr spiele und auch wenn man das vom Inhalt her mittlerweile ein bisschen
auf den Keks geht, aber technisch ist Overwatch vor allem was Netzwerk-mäßig angeht, saumäßig
gut, also ich hatte in Overwatch im Vergleich zu allen anderen Multiplayer-Spielen seltenst,
wirklich seltenst das Gefühl, ich hab auf den Sack gekriegt, weil irgendwas nicht richtig
registriert hat oder irgendwas nicht richtig funktioniert hat, klar hat Overwatch die ein
oder anderen Sachen, die auch online, ich mein es ist online, da kann immer mal ein
bisschen was schief gehen, aber Overwatch Netzwerk-technisch ist wirklich gut, da können
sich viele eine Scheibe von abschneiden, das funktioniert einfach erstklassig.
Holy Dich gibt's immer noch, ja mich gibt's schon, mich gibt's schon ganz schön lang,
und auch immer noch, ja, und mich gibt's hoffentlich auch noch eine Weile, man weiß ja nicht, Corona
in Hessen und sowas, aber ich hoffe ich überlebe das noch ein bisschen.
Bis Dinge gezeigt wurden, zum Beispiel StarCraft 2 damals, wurde ja glaube ich, was war das
in Paris oder in Korea, weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, aber es wurde eigentlich gezeigt,
als es schon fast fertig war, also dass man sehr lange und sehr behutsam immer gewesen
ist in den Interviews auf einer BlizzCon, als ich mit den Entwicklern oft gesprochen
habe, war auch immer zu merken, das ist alles super auf Kontrolle ausgelegt, ich hab teilweise
das Gefühl, dass das eben in der heutigen Zeit ihnen schwerer fällt, überhaupt auch
über alle Projekte, die sie nun mal haben.
Naja, also dazu muss ich sagen, Blizzard früher, also ganz früher, wir reden jetzt nicht von
2012 oder so, sondern noch davor, da haben die Entwickler einfach oftmals erzählt, was
sie bewegt hat, was sie wollten, vielleicht kann sich noch einer dran erinnern, wo Jeff
Kaplan, also sprich der Overwatch-Man, der war ja früher bei World of Warcraft dabei,
als der irgendeinen WoW-Raid vorgestellt hat, der hat auf der BlizzCon gestanden und gesagt
öffentlich auf der BlizzCon, das würden die sich heute überhaupt nicht mehr trauen, dass
er schlechte Spieler aus der Gruppe kickt, das hat der wirklich auf der Bühne erzählt
damals, das wäre in der heutigen Zeit undenkbar, die Leute werden heute so ultra getriggert,
würde einer auf der BlizzCon stehen und sagen kickt schlechte Leute aus der Gruppe, das
hat die damals nicht gejuckt und das fand ich auch ehrlich gesagt viel besser.
Ja, auch so eine Sache, früher hatte Blizzard fast immer nur so ein Ding, dann das nächste
Ding, dann das nächste Ding, jetzt haben sie halt viele Titel, die parallel laufen, parallel
betrieben werden müssen.
Das ist auch ein Punkt, ja das stimmt.
Und da geht dann auch ein bisschen eben der Überblick und auch die Kontrolle im Sinne
von, was mache ich, wie kommt das an, wie kommt die Ahnung und so weiter ein bisschen
zu kurz und vielleicht auf den Punkt zu fragen, weil du sagtest versteht Blizzard seine Community
noch, vielleicht für die heutige Runde wird es ja auch ein bisschen das sein, versteht
denn die Community Blizzard?
Oh ja, ich verstehe Blizzard, schon was, warum die manche Sachen machen, das heißt ja nicht,
dass es mir gefallen muss.
In die Richtung, das ist natürlich für den Spieler nicht wirklich wichtig, aber darüber
wollen wir ja ein bisschen reden, was sind denn vielleicht Gründe, egal ob die gut oder
schlecht sind, aber einfach ein bisschen Licht ins Dunkel bringen, wie kommt es denn
dazu, dass diese Dinge vielleicht auch passieren, oder aber auch an manchen Punkten zu sagen,
vielleicht sind sie für uns als Core Fans, die wirklich von Anfang an von irgendwie
vom ersten WarCraft über alles, was danach kam oder sogar von eben den Titeln davor,
der alles immer mitverfolgt haben, vielleicht ist es im Großen und Ganzen weltweit gesehen.
Hat er eine Max Payne?
Ist das eine Max Payne Tasse, nee oder was ist das für eine Tasse?
Max, welcher Max?
Also von mir ist die definitiv nicht.
Hat er da am Start?
Xmas?
Weihnachten?
Vielleicht ja.
Öfter mal mit dem Hintergrund, was ein Dinger macht.
Nicht so relevant, also welchen Impact hat denn jetzt wirklich dieses oder jenes auf
die Sache und genau wie das Zitat geht, aber so nach dem Motto, man sollte nicht hinter
allem, was passiert, immer einen großen Masterplan verstehen, manchmal so.
Ja, da hat er recht, da hat er recht, da hat er recht, ich gehe ganz stark davon aus,
dass vieles weniger durchdacht ist, wie man das teilweise vermutet, manches ist da einfach
auch ein Schnellschuss, so nach dem Motto, oh Gott, die Fans regen sich jetzt auf, Shitstorm,
sich zusammenbrauen, lass mal irgendwas raushauen und das ist schon überlegt, aber wahrscheinlich
nicht so der Wahnsinns-Big-Brain-Plan, wie man oftmals denkt.
Da gebe ich ihm schon, da greife ich zu, was sich auch durch Dummheit erklären lässt.
Und zum Beispiel die Immortal-Geschichte, würde ich sagen, war pure, das war einfach
blöd.
Nicht sich damit richtig mal auseinandersetzen, was es denn jetzt heißt, diesen Shift zu machen,
sondern ich glaube, das war einfach aus, ich will nicht Arroganz nennen oder so, aber aus
einem gewissen Selbstsicherheit und Selbstzuschiedenheit, wie damals eben, und das geht allen großen
so, das hat ein Apple schon hingekriegt, das hat ein Microsoft, ein Xbox One hingekriegt,
das hat einen Playstation, nach ihrem Mega-Erfolg mit der Playstation 2 waren sie halt sehr
cocky bei der Playstation 3.
600, zahlt mal!
So und ich glaube, dass es war bisher auch so ein Thema an manchen Punkten, wissen Sie
vielleicht auch selbst nicht, wer sie noch sind und wie ihre Wahrnehmung da draußen
ist, und deswegen glaube ich, ist dieses Immortal-Ding zumindestens voll darauf zurückzuführen,
hey, ihr nehmt doch eh, wenn wir Diablo raufschreiben, dann liebt ihr uns, dann jubelt ihr, und ich
denke, das ist jetzt auch eher so ein Lernprozess mal ein bisschen wieder.
Ich denke, da hat er Recht.
Ja, das glaube ich auch, dass die sich gedacht haben, so nach dem Motto, ey, alle lechzen
nach einem neuen Diablo, warum soll man ein neues Diablo nicht auf dem Handy machen?
Und die Sache mit, ihr habt hier keine Handys, das hat der ernst gemeint, das war nicht
irgendeine Beschwichtigungssache, das hat er wirklich ernst gemeint.
Da hat sich gedacht, wie kann man sich darüber aufregen, ihr habt doch alle Handys und das
ist doch eigentlich die logischste Sache der Welt, dass man Diablo auf dem Handy spielt.
Oh, okay, alles wird uns nicht verziehen und alles geht einfach auch nicht und wie gesagt,
vielleicht kommen wir da ein bisschen hin so eigentlich, was ist der Grund, warum Blizzard
jetzt so handelt oder eben so agiert, wie sie das einfach tun?
Es gab ja durchaus dann auch ein paar, sag ich mal, ein bisschen handfestere Schlappen
für das Studio, zum Beispiel hat man gemerkt, Heroes of the Storm war offensichtlich ein
Problem, das war nicht der Erfolg, den sie sich erhofft haben, jetzt, es läuft ja immer
noch, aber es ist irgendwie so, man kapiert selber nicht ganz so.
Da haben sie es wieder, da kamen die Stonkstypen von Blizzard wieder an den Start.
Es waren alle guter Dinge, Heroes of the Storm, die letzte Season von ihrer Pro League war
glaube ich ganz gut und es haben sich alle darauf gefreut, vielleicht wird nächstes
Jahr oder es war eigentlich alle sehr zuversichtlich, nächstes Jahr wird noch besser, ich meine,
noch besser bedeutet nicht, wir können auch nur ansatzweise, sie hätten auch nur ansatzweise
mit LoL oder Dota oder CS und irgendwas anderem mithalten können, das nicht, aber halt besser
als das Jahr davor und das ganze Ding wurde eingestellt, so shady irgendwie alles, dass
noch nicht mal die Spieler im Vorfeld geschweigen, die Team-Owner oder irgendwie einer, noch
nicht mal die Mitarbeiter wussten das vorher und da haben sie sich überhaupt nicht mit
Ruhm bekleckert, weil wohl einige News-Redakteure, Journalisten wussten Bescheid über interne
Blizzard-Quellen, halt eben aus dem Stonks-Office-Bereich und nicht aus dem Entwicklerbereich, dass
dieser Move kommt, bevor es die eigenen Mitarbeiter, bevor es die eigenen Teams wussten teilweise,
das war schon ein bisschen fragwürdig.
Semi eingestellt worden, wir haben die E-Sport-Szene eingestampft, sehr überraschend und ich erinnere
mich noch, ich habe kurz davor, war ich auf der BlizzCon, habe mit den Entwicklern von
Hots gesprochen, die mir voll begeistert ihre neue Heldin vorgestellt haben, die zum ersten
Mal eine ist, die nicht aus anderen Blizzard-Spielen kommt und was sie da noch für coole Pläne
haben, das war vollkommen klar, die hatten keine Ahnung, dass das Mutterschiff einen
Monat später sagt, ne, wir sägen die halbe Belegschaft ab, angeblich haben die das irgendwie
am gleichen Tag erfahren.
Das muss nicht jetzt auch wieder handsfest finanziell sein, aber als letzte WoW-Add-On,
die Story, das kam nicht sehr gut an, auch Overwatch 2, sag ich mal, wurde zumindest
gespalten aufgenommen und im weiteren Sinne hat das Studio auch, wie du sagst zwar, sehr
viele laufende Projekte.
Overwatch 2 ist halt so ein Ding, ich halte es immer noch für fake, dass es Overwatch
2, also ne, ne, fake ist falsche Wort, ich halte das immer noch für kein wirkliches
Overwatch 2 im eigentlichen Sinne, sondern eigentlich eher sowas, was Apex und Fortnite
und sowas jetzt auch schon machen, so eher Season 2, also quasi, man nimmt Overwatch
1 und erweitert das halt noch ein bisschen und macht das halt wieder interessanter für
die Leute, die schon mal gespielt haben, aber es ist, kann man nicht vorstellen, dass
es wirklich dem gerecht wird, was sich Leute unter einem Overwatch 2 versprechen.
Projekte, aber dann doch jetzt ne Weile lang gar nichts mehr Groß, wirklich Neues raus
gemacht, das letzte wirklich neue Spiel war ja Overwatch 2016, seitdem sind schon Dinge
passiert, hauptsächlich im WoW Sektor, WoW Classic war ja auch ein großer Erfolg, Battle
for Atheros so Mittel.
Wenn ich mal kurz unterbringen darf, muss er sich glaube ich schon auch mal als Spieler
dann dazu herablassen, mal eine Frage zu stellen, warum werden bestimmte Projekte von dem Spielehersteller
gemacht und warum wird er so mit den Dingen entschieden?
Weil Stonks, so klar.
Blizzard hat kein Overwatch gemacht, weil die klagen, hm cool, lassen wir einen Shooter
oder so und genauso haben sie keinen Hots gemacht, um einfach, ja finden wir irgendwie
cool, wollen wir auch noch machen, vielleicht im Kern im kreativen Team schon, vielleicht
kam da die Impulse her, aber bei Hots war natürlich die Idee, hey MOBA, großer Markt,
League of Legends, Dota, guck mal was da bewegt wird, guck mal welche Summen da laufen und
sie haben halt ihren Weg versucht da drin zu finden, haben auch da wieder ein sehr,
sehr gutes Produkt abgeliefert, ob das jetzt dem einen oder anderen gefällt, dem anderen
oder dem anderen, ob es in die MOBA Szene gepasst hat, obviously not, aber es ist immer
noch ein, also als Spiel vom Gameplay und von allem wie es läuft ein gutes Spiel und
dann ist auch irgendwann mal klar, wenn man sieht, ok wir können damit nicht das bewegen
was wir wollten, wird es halt eben nicht eingestellt, aber wird es halt eben nicht mehr so verfolgt,
Overwatch ist ja ein Gegenbeispiel, wenn du mal so willst, wenn du mal guckst, ich habe
jetzt dazu keine Zahlen, dafür gibt es ja vielleicht ein Dich, ein bisschen, aber wenn
man sieht, was Blizzard mit Overwatch geschafft hat, ist ja unfassbar, wenn man es jetzt mal
so will, also sie haben ein so gutes Spiel abgeliefert, was in der Multiplayer-Shooter-Community
jetzt auch so einen Status hat, gespielt wird.
Es ist tatsächlich ziemlich auf dem absteigenden Ast, mich würden die Spielerzahlen von Overwatch
echt mal interessieren, da veröffentlicht Blizzard ja nichts, aber wenn man sich so
die Aktivität anguckt, also in diesem, wie heißt das, Competitive Overwatch Reddit und
wenn man sich mal die Wartezeiten der Queues anguckt und Streaming-Zahlen und Content, der
erstellt wird, das ist schon, das hat schon seine beste Zeit hinter sich.
Gepflegt wird die ganze Geschichte mit den, mit der Liga, es kommt ja auch nichts, guckt
euch doch mal an, was Fortnite für einen Content, bzw. für einen Change-Feuerwerk
abfackelt, seit sie so groß sind.
Overwatch hat ein paar Helden, paar Maps, meiner Meinung nach grundlegend, aber nichts
am Spiel geändert, zumal 2CP immer noch der größte Bullshit-Modus aller Zeiten ist.
Was ich von Anfang an in Overwatch nicht verstanden habe, das muss ich jetzt noch mal kurz loswerden,
das ist ein Spiel, was sich dadurch auszeichnet, dass es verschiedene Helden gibt, mit Persönlichkeit
dahinter.
Ich hab's von Anfang an in Overwatch nicht kapiert, warum es überhaupt möglich war,
pro Team die gleichen Helden mehrfach zu picken und ich hab von Anfang an nicht verstanden,
warum es überhaupt möglich ist, in einem Game den gleichen Helden mehrfach zu spielen.
Ja, ich weiß, ich kenne die Beweggründe dahinter, warum sie das gemacht haben, sie haben sich
auf, dass das Ganze dynamischer wird, balancet wird, mehr balancet wird und Overwatch war
ja ursprünglich darauf angelegt, als Spiel, wo man permanent Helden switcht, das hat sich
so halt nicht bewährt, aber gerade in einem Spiel, ich finde, das passt so von der Identität
her irgendwie schon nicht so richtig zusammen, man hat ein Spiel, wo man die Persönlichkeit
und die Unterschiede der Helden besonders in Vordergrund stellt und dann erlaubst du nicht
nur den gleichen Helden in beiden Teams zu spielen, sondern auch noch von Anfang an
den gleichen Helden mehrfach zu picken.
Das passt irgendwie nicht zusammen und ich, Overwatch, der Hero Pool, was ist denn das?
Irgendwie 10 Helden von, was haben die mittlerweile, 35 und ich weiß gar nicht, wie viele es mittlerweile
sind, die gespielt werden, das ist ein bisschen wie in LoL, ja, in LoL werden glaube ich
auch nur 10 Helden oder so gespielt.
Und gerade bei einem Spiel, wo es eben die Persönlichkeit und die Einzigartigkeit von
den Helden ausmacht, verstehe ich nicht, warum man das nicht versucht hat, darauf auszulegen,
dass es eben ein Held pro Spiel nur einmal gibt.
LoL ist der Champions Pool echt riesig, ich habe letztens irgendwas gelesen, dass im Pro-LoL-Meter
irgendwie 10 Helden gespielt werden.
Über 80% der Champs wurde bei Nebels gepickt, okay.
Oh ja, ist ja gut, aber man darf nicht vergessen, LoL hat halt auch massig Helden zur Auswahl.
Es ist übrigens auch eine Sache, die Overwatch gut tun würde.
Bullshit, es werden viele gespielt, Alter, ich habe gesagt, dass ich das gelesen habe,
nicht, dass es ja die ultimative Wahrheit ist.
Jetzt war gleich der LoL-Fan wieder übelst getriggert hier.
Spiele oder so in der Sportsbar geguckt haben jetzt ein paar Overwatch gucken, wenn man
sieht, was da für Summen fließen, dann ist es halt schon beachtlich und am Ende darf
man nicht vergessen, nur ein Satz zu dieser Diablo-Immortal-Geschichte, vielleicht ist
halt auch so ein Team, was in so einer kreativen Bubble ist und einfach sagt, naja, jeder guckt
doch die ganze Zeit auf sein Handy, jeder spielt doch die ganze Zeit auf seinem iPad,
gibt genug Vorbilder, PUBG Mobile, Fortnite Mobile, Clash Royale und so weiter und so
fort, hat man gar nicht darüber nachgedacht, dass das jetzt als negativ empfunden werden
kann so ein Spiel.
Genau, da hat er voll und ganz recht, das ist das, was ich vorhin meinte, der hat das
wirklich ernst gemeint, als der auf der Bühne gesagt hat, habt ihr keine Handys, habt ihr
keine Smartphones, das hat er nicht gesagt um die Leute zu beschwichtigen oder auch
zu beschwichtigen, aber da war der wirklich von überzeugt, so nach dem Motto, wie ist
es doch das Normalste von der Welt, dass man jetzt alle auf dem Handy spielen, den Diablo
auf dem Handy rausbringt, das hat er nicht gemeint, doch gesagt, um die Leute zu gibaten,
das meint er wirklich ernst.
Spiel zu machen und ich würde jetzt auch ehrlich mal bezweifeln, wie sehr es ihnen
in ein, zwei Jahren geschadet haben wird, dass sie dieses Misannouncement gemacht haben,
weil ich lehne mich jetzt mal aus dem Fenster, wenn es da ist, jeder wird es erstmal spielen,
zumindest mal runterladen, ob es dann weiter gespielt wird, weiß ich nicht, aber...
Werdet ihr spielen?
Was meint ihr Leute?
Würdet ihr Immortal spielen, also wenn ich die Auswahl hätte zwischen Diablo Immortal
und Path of Exile Mobile, dann würde ich eindeutig Path of Exile Mobile vorziehen, allerdings
würde ich es wahrscheinlich gar nicht spielen, weil die Zeit wo ich mobile Spiele spielen
würde, wären wahrscheinlich zum größten Teil eh nur im Zug und das ist am Tag nicht
so lang und vielleicht mal wenn ich irgendwo warten muss, aber das kommt so selten vor,
das lohnt sich eigentlich gar nicht so richtig.
Die Steuerung, ja das ist das größte Problem, weil ich finde die Steuerung von den meisten
Mobile Games ist crap.
Ausprobieren, ich würde es wahrscheinlich mal installieren, ja.
Ja, dann kommen wir doch mal, übrigens Leute, wenn das Video fertig ist, oder während ich,
ich habe übelst Hunger, ich, ich, entweder gucken wir noch ein Essenvideo danach oder
ich esse jetzt hier einfach, während wir GameStar Video gucken.
Schon häufiger harte Zahlen angesprochen, kommen wir doch zu denen mal, wir haben hier
zum Beispiel eine Einnahmen Kurve von Blizzard seit Ende 2016, wo man dann doch sieht, es
geht ein bisschen nach unten, es sieht jetzt für den Lion, sage ich mal, auch nicht nach
einer kompletten Katastrophe aus, nur mehrere hundert Millionen, die jedes Quartal umgesetzt
werden, aber es geht dann doch nach unten und die Gerüchte zumindest sind ja von Jason
Shrier von Kotaku, der in der Regel ja keinen Unsinn verzapft und gut vernetzt ist von Insidern,
dass es bei Blizzard selbst einen zunehmenden Einfluss von Activision gibt, das auch den
Begriff ausübt, Kosten zu sparen und wieder mehr Sachen zu releasen.
Vielleicht das ist gerade genau der Punkt, weil das ist ja ein bisschen so das, was dahinter
passiert, um da ein bisschen reinzukommen, wie du schon sagst, die haben jetzt gerade
erst ja jetzt vor kurzem ihr viertes Quartal abgeschlossen und halt ihre Jahresberichte
vorgelegt und so und tatsächlich, ich glaube, ist das das erste Mysterium, mit dem man mal
brechen muss, auch wenn es hart ist, Blizzard ist nicht das, wie ihr Image nach außen
mal suggeriert.
Ja, stell zur Pause mal, da hatte er auch recht, aber das ist bei den meisten so, die
meisten stellen sich nach außen hin immer so als wir lieben die Community und wir machen
alles für unsere Spieler und bla bla bla, es ist halt alles Bullshit, ich weiß das aus
erster Hand, also was heißt, es ist nicht alles Bullshit, es ist da teilweise schon
ein bisschen was wahres dran, aber bei weitem nicht so, wie man sich nach außen hin präsentiert,
ich arbeite bei einer Bank, so und eines der wichtigsten Dinger, die es bei mir auf
der Arbeit gibt, ist nach außen hin gut dastehen, scheiß egal, was wirklich ist, nach außen
hin gut dastehen, ist das wichtigste ever und das ist bei Spieleherstellern auch das
gleiche.
Also Blizzard ist A, seit 1991, ich hab nochmal nachgeguckt, glaube ich durch fünf Hände
gegangen, also es war eben Teil von eher das kleineren Unternehmen, war ja selbst, hieß
es ja auch anders, dann wurde es umbenannt, dann wurde es nachher, ich hab's mal aufgeschrieben,
eine lange Kette von Silicon & Synapse war es, der ursprünglich noch so, genau, dann gab's
nochmal Zwischennamen, glaube ich Chaos Studios, das hatte dann aber rechtliche Probleme, dann
ist es Blizzard Entertainment, 94 geworden, wie gesagt 91 gegründet, dann Blizzard Entertainment
seit 94, dann wurde es aber von Davidson & Association aufgenommen, die wiederum wurden von CUC International
aufgekauft, die wiederum wurden zwei Jahre später von Havas aufgekauft, die wiederum
mit Vivendi zusammengegangen sind und dann die Vivendi Game Group, wo auch Sierra und
so drin war, gegründet worden, 2008 dann nachher, 2007 angekündigt, 2008, wo hat dann
Vivendi Activision gekauft, dann 2013 hat sich Activision selbst aus Vivendi rausgekauft
und so weiter, dann kamen noch Kinder dazu und das ist glaube ich das große Ding, was
auch dahinter steht, am Ende gibt es kein Blizzard, es ist eine Marke, es ist eine Sparte,
es ist ein Teil einer sehr großen Unternehmung, ich weiß nicht genau jetzt nach Markkapitalisierung
glaube ich, ist Activision Blizzard so an die 40 Milliarden oder 44 Milliarden US-Dollar
wert, also es ist keine kleine Klitsche mehr, sondern und es besteht und das ist halt ganz
spannend, wir können es dann auch mal größer ziehen, ich hab's hier dann auch drin, weil
da sind sie relativ transparent und wenn man jetzt mal sieht…
Das bedeutet Schlonks, das bedeutet… alter übel, verschluckt so, also Anspiel auf Stocks,
also Aktienkram.
Wie gesagt, dieses Großunternehmen besteht aus Activision, das hat jetzt im Q4 1,4 Milliarden
gemacht, dann Blizzard, knapp 600 Millionen und King sind Candy Crush und Co. sind 500
Millionen, das bedeutet…
Das haben wir uns ja auch schon mal im Stream angeguckt in den Activision Blizzard Financial
Report und was das Tolle war, da zu sehen ist, dass Overwatch kaum Kohle gemacht hat.
Blizzard ist so groß oder so wichtig ungefähr wie weiß ich ein King.
Wie die Candy Crush Macher, das ist schon eine harte Anzeige.
Machen vom Ergebnis ein bisschen mehr und machen halt aber deutlich weniger als Activision,
was hauptsächlich heutzutage nur noch Call of Duty ist und da kommen jetzt die ganzen
Schwierigkeiten halt rein, die natürlich auch wieder den normalen Spielern mal so gar
nicht interessieren und das verstehe ich auch, aber der Hintergrund ist schlicht und ergreifend,
es ist ein Unternehmen, die versuchen durch kreative Produkte viele Leute zu erreichen
und ich weiß nicht, ob das auch der Jason Schweier war oder ob das woanders mal gut analysiert
wurde, Blizzard hat drei Phasen durchlebt, die sie maßgeblich verändert haben.
Die erste Sache war der Mega-Erfolg von WoW, der diese Firma krass intern verändert.
Das hat einfach monatlich Geld gegeben.
WoW hat einfach und das ist das wovon jede Firma bzw.
also jeder Spielhersteller auf jeden Fall, aber jede Firma träumt, dass du jeden Monat
mehr oder weniger sicher mit einem gewissen festen Betrag rechnen kannst.
Es kündigen nicht einfach mal von heute auf morgen irgendwie alle WoW Leute ihr Abo.
Das war Wahnsinn und WoW, überlegt euch mal, die hatten teilweise bis zu 10 Millionen
Abos, das Abo kostet irgendwie 12 Euro, die haben massiv, massiv Kohle gekriegt im Monat
auf einen Schlager.
WoW 2 erst mal lange Zeit zugrunde gegangen, nämlich das ganze ursprüngliche Starcraft
Team musste mithelfen, dass WoW gelaunched werden kann 2004, deswegen dauerte es so lange,
bis dann das wieder aufgenommen wurde und nachgefahren wurde, dem ist auch Diablo 3
die ganzen Iterationen zum Opfer gefallen.
Sprich WoW war so über erfolgreich, dass es intern so viel verändert hat, sowohl was
Ressourcenausrichtung angeht, als aber auch Denkweisen, ist immer so, wenn man, man stellt
sich vor, man gewinnt im Lotto und das verändert sein Leben.
Man kauft sich vielleicht ein Haus, ein Boot, was auch immer, irgendwie auf einmal sind
andere Dinge und es kommen auch andere Probleme.
Und all deine alten Freunde sind plötzlich auch ganz anders da, hey, was doch jetzt geht.
Und das ist halt natürlich so eine Sache, die halt vielleicht auch Personen ändern,
interne Sachen.
So, der zweite größere Wechsel, was ich mal eben gehört habe, war Hearthstone, weil
was war das Besondere an Hearthstone?
Es war ein Miniprojekt von einem winzig Team, ich glaube am anderen.
Übrigens, das erfolgreichste, ich hab keine Zahlen zu, aber ich dachte das erfolgreichste
Unity Spiel überhaupt.
Überrascht immer wieder Leute, dass das Hearthstone in Unity ist, weil Unity ja immer so gerne
geflamed wird.
Am Anfang wirklich so eine Handvoll, dann waren es nachher 10, 20 maximal.
Das war doch einstellig ursprünglich wirklich das Team, also winzig, ja.
Und es wurde zu einem und ist bis heute noch zu einer so tragenden Umsatzsäule, also was
an Geld immer reinkommt für Blizzard, dass es ebenfalls wieder Denkmuster, wie gehe ich
an Spiele ran, muss ich dann immer das Großprojekt quasi, was acht Jahre in Entwicklung ist,
mit 100 Designern und so weiter und so fort haben, oder ich weiß nicht, bei WoW waren
nachher, weiß ich nicht, 300, 500 Leute nachher, um das Ding auf die Straße zu kriegen.
Am Anfang war das Wort eben gar nicht so riesig.
Das hat auch viel geändert, Hearthstone, klein, richtig getroffen und dann, das war nämlich
auch glaube ich die Idee an Heroes of the Storm, ich habe das ja auch von Anfang an
noch bevor, wie hieß es, Blizzard Allstars, glaube ich hieß es am Anfang, habe auch Preview
damals geschrieben und war auch so, endlich gibt es halt die echten Blizzard-Helden in
einem Dota-Style und so weiter, weil da kam das ja mal alles her, aber da glaube ich hatten
sie nämlich auch die Idee, ach wir nehmen ein kleines Team, wir gehen jetzt in diese
Nische, wir sind Blizzard, bam, knallt, ausgesorgt.
Das war das nächste und Overwatch, was du gerade sagtest, war das nächste, das war ihre
erste neue IP seit ganz langer Zeit, hatten wir auch einen Talk hier gemacht, so was wird
denn jetzt, was ist das Projekt Titan, wie geht es weiter, da wussten wir noch nicht,
wie dieses Overwatch wird und Overwatch war auch wieder zu erfolgreich, es waren Milliarden
Umsatz glaube ich in dem Jahr, also in den ersten 12 Monaten und dann kam jetzt die
Sache.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was die aktuellen Overwatch-Verkaufszahlen sind, aber irgendwie 16 Millionen oder irgendwas,
es ist, es ist irgendwie, Overwatch hat übertrieben krass verkauft da, äh nicht overworld, Overwatch,
ok, 16 Millionen, vergiss was ich gesagt habe Leute, 50 Millionen, Overwatch hat sich echt
übertrieben krass verkauft.
Die dahinter liegen, die Firma wird, ist intern unglaublich erfolgreich gewesen, dann wird
sie verkauft oder mitverkauft, geht in eine andere Fusion mit rein und dann hat das Ding
einen Wert, Blizzard ist jetzt, weiß nicht, 5 Milliarden Wert, 8 Milliarden Wert oder sonst
irgendwas und dieser Wert kommt aus diesem, was die Spiele gerade einspülen und das führte
dazu, dass sie natürlich große Erwartungshaltung bei ihren Neueigentümern haben, plus natürlich
die Leute von Blizzard, die da jetzt übergegangen sind, die machen das auch natürlich aus Leidenschaft,
das habe ich denen immer abgenommen, das waren keine Business-Leute, sondern Chris Metzen,
Mike Mohan und so, das waren Überzeugungstäter.
Nur mit dem Unterschied, dass die jetzt halt weg sind.
Blizzard gilt ja auch als eine der Spiele-Schmieden, die am meisten wirklich Spieler in sich drin
hat, ähnlich wie Valve, wo Leute wirklich die ganze Zeit zocken, zocken, zocken und
gucken, was man irgendwie machen kann, das ist nicht selbstverständlich bei großen Dev-Teams,
aber dann kommt wieder eben dieser finanzielle Aspekt, sie kriegen Ziele, wenn du verkauft
wirst und daran Anteile hast, dann kriegst du einfach, wenn du 20% mehr schaffst, dann
kriegst du, weiß ich, 50 Millionen, ich kenne die genau nicht, ist nicht offengelegt, aber
eben du wirst an dem Erfolg gemessen und kriegst dafür deine Ausschüttung, weil auch der
Ausstieg von Mike Mohan und von anderen, das war sicherlich geplant, weil wenn du deine
Firma nach und nach halt in eine andere Firma integrierst, planst du immer mit dem Ausstieg.
Das kann mal anders laufen, dass du sagst, ach, ist ja doch ganz cool, ich bleib, aber
ich bin ganz sicher, das war den Leuten selbstbewusst.
Ich bleib jetzt hier noch drei Jahre unter Activision oder auch vier, fünf, was auch
immer, aber eigentlich, ich bin auf dem Weg nach draußen.
So, um das mal kurz zusammenzufassen, was jetzt jetzt passiert, nochmal, wie gesagt,
Blizzard, das ist eins, darunter ist ein Blizzard Entertainment integriert worden, wie du ja auch
vor einem Vorgespräch gesagt hast, es gibt noch einen President, es gibt keinen CEO,
also kein Einzelschef von Blizzard, also kein Vorstandsvorsitzender, wie man es im Deutsch
nennen würde.
Genau, das war der Mike Mohan und jetzt ist, und der hat ja diesen Titel, der den jetzt
eben vorher erzählt, aber eigentlich gibt es nur noch einen CEO von Activision Blizzard
und das ist Bobby Kotick.
Jay Allen Brack hat jetzt den, wenn ich den keinen sehe, weniger mächtigen Titel in amerikanischer
Palance President, dieser einen Abteilung von Activision Blizzard, der dürfte uns ja
alle bestens bekannt sein.
Das heißt aber jetzt auch, die Gesamtstrategie des Unternehmens, und das kann eben jeder
auch nachlesen, weil es ja börsennotiert ist, müssen wir das offenlegen, was machen
sie, warum machen sie das, was erwarten sie davon, da sind die oft sehr transparent,
auch da wieder, ist für die meisten Spieler völlig irrelevant, man will ja nur einfach
die guten Spieler haben.
Was war so schlimm an dem?
An dem ist nichts schlimmer als an allen anderen Ober-Stonks-Mans, den haben wir aber schon,
wenn es ums Call of Duty-Thema geht, hatten wir den schon öfters mal am Start.
Zum Beispiel und auch drin, was sind ihre Kernmarken, auf die sie sich konzentrieren?
Das sagt leider aber auch, sie haben wenig bis gar kein Interesse neue Marken aufzubauen.
Es gab mal eine Diskussion, 2009, 2008, da hatte sich der Bobby Kotick mal ein bisschen
verplappert, wo er nämlich gesagt hat, er hält gar nichts davon, eigentlich dieses
und das, da noch was, da noch was, am liebsten würde er alles, was jährlich nur geht, alles,
was nur große IPs sind, die wiederholbar sind, die tief sind, das hat er gar nicht
gemacht.
Das ist ja auch logisch, aus dem seiner Sicht, das ist ja auch keiner, das ist ja kein kreativer
Mensch, das ist ein Stonks-Mensch, deswegen, für den ist es ganz klar, du machst das,
was etabliert ist, wenn du jetzt einen Diablo 4 machst, okay, gehen wir mal zurück, wenn
du jetzt einen Diablo 3 machst, du weißt, der Scheiß wird sich verkaufen, die Leute
lächeln nach einem neuen Diablo 3, das war dem Typ auch klar, das ist halt kein kreativer
Mann, das ist ein Stonks-Mann, die denken halt in andere Richtungen.
Aus Geld, Geld, Geld gesagt, sondern weil er selbst gemerkt hat, viele Top-Entwickler
gehen nur zu Teams, die nachweislich fortlaufende Erfolge erzielen, die viele Mitarbeiter von
den Studios offensichtlich nicht so richtig Lust haben, nämlich drei Jahre sich, Entschuldigung,
tot zu arbeiten und danach rausgeschmissen zu werden, sie erwarten von einem großen
Studio, wo sie dann hingehen auch langfristige Erfolge.
Da gibt es ja schon dann einen direkten Konflikt von dem, weil das ist ja auch wie Activision
arbeitet, schon seit langem mit Call of Duty, wie du vor allem gesagt hast, das genaue
Gegenteil von dem, wie Blizzard immer gearbeitet hat und ja eigentlich auch bis heute noch,
abgesehen von WoW, wo sie jährliche Add-ons rausbringen, ist ja...
Hast du uns auch sowas jetzt geworden?
Stimmt, hast du uns auch sowas?
Overwatch soll sowas, das meine ich, aber das ist genau die Brücke jetzt.
Sie haben King, was durch Kendi-Quatsch immer noch Unsummen einnimmt, sie haben überall
gelernt, neue IPs, schwierig, riskant, unsicher.
Aber auch bei Overwatch manchmal vielleicht...
Auch mal, ja, genau, das aber erhöht dann sogar den...
Das ist halt generell das Problem, was wir aktuell haben, nicht nur in der Spielewelt,
auch wenn man sich irgendwelche Filme, Geschichten anguckt, also...
Es gibt halt, wenn man sich die Releases anguckt, das sind 71% oder wenn nicht noch mehr, 80%
Neuauflagen.
Entweder komplette Reboots oder halt meistens Fortsetzungen.
Und ich finde das so langweilig einfach nur.
Im Druck, dass das nächste IP-Ding halt, das IP sagen wir immer, ne, also eine neue Serie,
eine neue Marke, die geschaffen wird, also Intellectual Poverty, aber es erhöht auch
den Erwartungsdruck, das wiederzumachen.
Und jetzt kommt die nächste große Problematik rein, mobile.
Activision, jetzt auch in den letzten Calls und auch in internen Diskussionen, sie sehen,
wie entscheidend mobile auf einer weltweiten Ebene ist.
Was war jetzt der letzte Wert, den sie letzte Woche veröffentlicht haben?
Ja, guckt euch Call of Duty Mobile an, wie das eingeschlagen ist.
So ein Crap.
Wir haben, ich glaube, 150 Millionen installierte Call of Duty Mobile.
War klar, dass das jetzt kommt.
Damit hatten sie ja einen Riesenerfolg und in dem Fall sind ja die beiden Studios sogar
auf Linie, weil, wie du ja sagtest, Blizzard das auch schon vor einer Weile erkannt hat,
der hier ist ja sehr Half-Stone-süchtig zum Beispiel.
Nicht zu sehr, wie du denkst.
Aber das ist halt, weißt du, du hast zwei Arme, die zeigen mobile, mobile, mobile und
dann ist Blizzard da, ja eigentlich würden wir ja am liebsten PC, ein bisschen Konsole
ist noch okay, weißt du, also das auch wieder beeinflusst, ich will nur, dass die größte
...
Klar, Phoenix.
Mobile gibt's.
War vor Modern Warfare das Release und das ist wahrscheinlich sogar deutlich erfolgreicher
als Modern Warfare.
Wir zeigen nämlich, am Ende ist es eben eine große Unternehmung und die jetzt nach und
nach alles bestimmt, deswegen, wie gesagt, nochmal Blizzard konnte früher auch ein bisschen
allein gelassen werden, gerade unter Vivendi, weil zum Beispiel Vivendi auch Riesenprobleme
mit Sierra hatte.
Sierra war so lange ein Problemkind, wurde ja dann auch abgewickelt und aufgelöst und
so weiter und so fort.
Das ist fast immer so, auch bei uns intern, wenn man ehrlich ist, man kümmert sich immer
vor allem erst um die Sorgenkinder, nicht unbedingt um die Sachen, die von alleine laufen.
Jetzt ist es aber so, auch was du schon sagtest, die Kurve von Blizzard selbst ist jetzt nicht
so super, während halt Call of Duty gerade wieder neue Rekorde aufstellt, also Modern
Warfare.
Die haben halt ein absolut geniales Marketing Team bei Call of Duty, also die kriegen das
jedes Jahr wieder hin.
Man muss sagen, dass Call of Duty besser ist als Call of Duty.
Ich hab's nicht gespielt, aber ich hab das bei vielen Leuten auf YouTube gehört, nachdem
auch die Ubisoft Flames sind, aber es ist wie jedes Jahr.
Es kommt eine Call of Duty raus, am Anfang sagen die Leute, ist ja nicht schlecht und
danach kommt immer, immer die gleiche Reaktion, immer dieser gleiche Reflex, oh das aktuelle
Call of Duty ist scheiße, wir spielen jetzt das von letztem Jahr.
Das ist immer, immer und man hält einfach nur eine gewisse Anzahl ein Call of Duty am
Stück aus.
Wenn man Call of Duty zwei Monate gespielt hat, dann ist vorbei.
Das Game, da ragest du mehr rum, schneller rum, als in OV-Ranked.
In OV-Ranked ragest du länger, aber schneller zum Ragen bringt dich Modern Warfare oder
Call of Duty.
Das kannst du nicht länger als zwei Monate am Stück spielen.
Man muss irgendwie dem auch ein bisschen unterordnen und einfügen und deswegen meine ich ja, das
muss man nicht mögen, aber das ist einfach der Grund, warum das ist, wenn ich eben mit
diese und jenen Werten mal irgendwie gekauft wurde, ist auch die Erwartung, dass ich das
wiederhole.
Also dass ich jedes Jahr im Idealfall meinen Milliardenseller habe und nicht nur alle fünf
Jahre mal.
Und das ist glaube ich der Kampf, der jetzt in dieser Unternehmung, was man auch mitkriegt,
irgendwie dort eben einfach vorherrscht.
Genau, das ist ja auch was eben Jason schreier macht.
Was meinst du eigentlich zu Need for Ninja mit dem It's Just a Game, kenn ich nicht.
Das ist übrigens eine coole Idee mit dem neuen Spielmodus in Overwatch.
So einen Spielmodus fände ich cool und ganz ehrlich, können die nicht einfach 2CP umbauen,
die 2CP Maps umbauen in einem ordentlichen Spielmodus.
2CP ist wirklich so, der komplette Hass für Overwatch entlädt sich bei mir, wenn ich
an 2CP denke.
Und es ist gar nicht nur der Modus, der Modus in Kombination mit den Maps und vor allem
mit den Spawnplatzierungen, das ist für mich so der pure Overwatch Rage, den ich da bekomme,
wenn ich da dran denke.
Was ist an 2CP so schlimm?
Zum Beispiel, dass die Defender meistens, zumindest was den letzten Punkt angeht oder
je nach Map, 2 Meter vom Punkt wegspawnen, dass du in 2CP teilweise dafür bestraft wirst,
aggressiv zu spielen, dass du in 2CP teilweise dafür bestraft wirst, Punkte einzunehmen
im falschen Timing.
2CP hat so viele komische Dinge einfach nur, das Ding müsste nochmal ordentlich überarbeitet
werden.
Das ist für mich so der komplette Overwatch Rage in einem Spielmodus zusammengefasst.
Außerdem sind, finde ich, die mit Abstand schlechtesten Maps in 2CP, die 2CP Maps,
das ist so ein Ding, was Leute, die angefangen haben Level zu designen, als erstes basteln
irgendwie so, wir bauen einfach Ding mit einem Chokepoint, einem Eingang, vielleicht einer
Flankhute und sagen, geile Map.
Frustration gibt, dass sie das Gefühl haben, Entscheidungen werden mehr und mehr von Leuten
getroffen, die auch, wie du sagst, Blizzard ist ein Gamer-Entwickler sozusagen, wird
aber weniger von Gamern getroffen, weil Activision irgendwelche McKinsey-Berater oder so was
reinholt und die in Finanzmeetings setzt, die dann Entscheidungen treffen, was ja nachvollziehbar
ist irgendwo, aber was dann gleichermaßen auch vielleicht für, sag ich mal, Reibereien
sorgen kann.
Man hat ja durchaus gesehen, dass auch in letzter Zeit wieder einige Blizzard-Gesichter auch
gegangen sind.
Wir können uns den Tweet von Ninja danach kurz angucken.
Von einer Weile ist ja schon mal der Ben Brode gegangen, der Hearthstone Game Director
war.
Der Ding ist hier.
Metzen ist weg.
Moin ist weg.
Das Browder ist jetzt weg.
Und in letzter Zeit sind auch noch mehr.
Ist ähnlich wie bei DICE.
Bei DICE rennen die Leute auch reihenweise weg.
Das Storm Game Director, davor war das StarCraft II Lead Designer, da wird auch ein bisschen
gemerkt, gerade der Dustin Blowder, vielleicht so die Spiele, die ich gerne mache, die ich
cool finde über Blizzard, sind jetzt offenbar nicht mehr die Dinge, die hier so entstehen.
Was ein bisschen bitter ist, weil der war ja vorher der C&C Lead Designer mal und C&C
wissen wir auch, hat es auch nicht über die Jahre geschafft und ist dann ja zu StarCraft
gegangen.
Ich fühle sehr mit diesem Mann.
Er tut gute Dinge.
Ich habe mal mit ihm eine Stunde lang mit ihm geredet.
Danach war er im Heroes of Storm und es war ganz spannend, dass halt mal, wie ist das
denn für jemanden, der auch mit Strategie, wir beide sind ja große Strategiefans, aufgewachsen
ist und das eigentlich so mit der Muttermilch aufgesaugt hat und dann ist es halt tatsächlich
so ein bisschen...
Milch ist Gift, Leute.
Denkt dran.
Weil am Ende ist es...
Ohne hat uns das erklärt.
... noch mal weltweites Unternehmen guckt, wo sind Spieler und die Spieler sagen bitte
Action, also Shooter, Call of Duty, Overwatch oder bitte Mobile oder bitte mit langer, langer
Bindung.
Ja, mehr Service.
Ich finde es eher ein Liebhaber-Themen, fallen schnell runter, warum gibt es kein StarCraft,
warum gibt es keine, auch warum wurde Warcraft 3 Reforged ausgelagert, ist ja nicht mal mehr
intern richtig.
Wobei ich tatsächlich da noch mal geguckt habe, Blizzard, also das ist ja auch eine Sache,
die sie häufiger zu machen haben, weil du sagst, sie haben jetzt inzwischen einfach
ein bisschen zu viel auf der Platte.
Diablo Immortal wird ja auch mit NetEase, einem chinesischen Entwickler, zusammen gemacht.
Chinesisch.
Tatsächlich, das klingt erst mal so, sie haben es ja nach Malaysia ausgelagert, das Warcraft
von Warcraft 3.
Das klingt wirklich so nach irgendwie in so eine Klitsche so, aber das ist tatsächlich
immer noch ein sehr hochwertiges Studio, LemonSky heißen die, die haben unter anderem auch schon
an Uncharted mitgewirkt.
Ich finde das gar nicht negativ.
Also viele Studios.
Ich meine, ich glaube, also ich habe es erst mal, als ich es gehört habe, wurde nach Malaysia
ausgesucht, das war ja okay, möglichst billig irgendwie, nee gar nicht, da ist tatsächlich
anscheinend ein sehr talentiertes Team, aber trotzdem macht Blizzard ein bisschen weniger
selbst.
Genau.
Du fokussierst das ja auch so, eine Wahrheit, also ich weiß nicht, wie es bei Blizzard
aussieht, aber du siehst, du hast ja auch erzählt, Top-Talents sind teilweise gegangen,
die Branche ist hart umkämpft um richtige Super-Designer, gibt es nicht viele, also
von allen, von den Ubisoft Studios hören wir das, von Microsoft Game Studios, von Bethesda
und so, überall gibt es Mangel an echten Super-Kreativen, also die wirklich visionär,
die wirklich Gameplay verstehen.
Ich glaube auch, also ich glaube, da kommen auch wenige nach, weil ich stelle mir das
einfach nur vor, dass es in der aktuellen Lage, wie es jetzt gerade ist, wo quasi Stonks
vor Kreativität gehen, schwierig ist, neue Leute quasi zu erschaffen, die so denken,
wo soll das herkommen?
Das fängt ja nicht von jetzt auf gleich einfach mal an, das braucht alles ein bisschen Erfahrung,
Talent ist das eine, Übung, Erfahrung, sonst was und wenn es das Umfeld nicht mehr hergibt,
wenn quasi so das Durchschnittsmotto ist Stonks vor Kreativität, wo willst du neue Super-Kreative-Designer-Leute
hinkriegen, herkriegen?
Mechanics und so weiter und so fort, es ist immer noch, auch 2020, eher die Ausnahme,
ein super erfolgreiches Spiel zu machen als die Regel, also es ist weiterhin superschwer,
alles richtig gut hinzukriegen und so weiter und das eben, ja und das führt aber dazu,
dass so viele Retortendinger zusammengefuddelt werden, sowas wie Anthem zum Beispiel, Anthem
ist so ein typisches BWL Stonks-Game, so nach dem Motto, wir brauchen das, wir brauchen
Loot, wir brauchen Service-Game, wir brauchen hier und die und die Elemente und hier und
hier Kreativteam macht man ein Game draus, dann gucken die sich das an, denken die, what
the fuck, was soll man daraus für ein Game machen, nach Übrigens in drei Monaten ist
die E3-Demo, what, so ungefähr muss Anthem entstanden sein und was da rausgekommen ist,
sieht man ja und da kommen bestimmt keine super kreativen Leute und wenn da einer wirklich
kreativ ist und was Gutes draus machen will, hat er keinen Bock mehr, verpisst sich.
Unser Top-Leute müssen jetzt irgendwie am nächsten Overwatch arbeiten oder die müssen
jetzt an Diablo 4 arbeiten.
Deswegen ist ja einer ihrer verbliebenen Top-Leute ist noch Jeff Kaplan, der damit kein
Problem hat, aber selbst der, der hat neulich öffentlich gesagt, er hätte die Blitz-Chang-Sache
nicht gemacht, er hätte den nicht bestrafen.
Der ist auch pissed, das hab ich auch letztens auf Reddit noch mal gesehen ey und der ist
ja schon ewig dabei, man darf nicht vergessen, der hat angefangen als Blizzard WoW entwickelt
hat, das war eine übelst krasse Everquest 2 Suchter, Jeff Kaplan, da gibt's sogar noch
die Flame-Posts von ihm, legendär mittlerweile, die Flame-Posts, wo er sich über Everquest
Mechanics und Everquest, wo er den Hersteller aufgeregt hat, wie scheiße alles ist und so,
hat er übelst rumgeflamet und den haben die bei Blizzard damals geholt, weil halt MMOs
waren ja noch in der Entstehung, gab ja noch kein so das MMO schlechthin, das ist dann
World of Warcraft geworden, aber als WoW quasi in der Entwicklung war, gab's das noch nicht
und dann haben die erfolgreiche Spieler aus damals etablierten MMOs geholt, um quasi
Infos zu bekommen aus erster Hand und die mitarbeiten zu lassen daran, was eben ein
gutes MMO ausmacht, da kommt er ja her, er war mal einer der größten Everquest 2 Flamer
quasi und der ist ganz schön lang bei Blizzard schon dabei und wie gesagt, es gibt noch diesen
Blizzcon-Auftritt von ihm früher, wo er auf der Bühne gestanden hat und gemeint hat,
er kickt schlechte Leute aus der Party, das könntest du heute eben im Leben nicht mehr
sagen auf der Bühne, ey.
Das fand ich auch ein interessantes Zeichen, dass der das so klar sagt.
Weißt du, also ich finde, also man muss noch einmal aufpassen, weil du gerade gesagt hast,
Leute gehen auch von Blizzard weg und so, was den Leuten oftmals von der Community in den
Mund gelegt wird oder was man halt so schnell mal in irgendeinem Chatroom oder in einem
Forum schreibt, ist halt auch nicht immer die Wahrheit, ja, also, oh ja, der Ben Brode
ist jetzt gegangen, weil er damit unzufrieden war, naja, Ben Brode ist halt einfach deswegen
gegangen, weil er gesagt hat, ich habe jetzt dieses Hearthstone-Team geführt und ich will
nicht mehr führen, ich will wieder selber programmieren, deswegen hat er jetzt seine
Kinder gegründet und macht da sein Marble-Kartenspiel, weil er halt einer von denen ist, der wieder
selber hier programmieren will, ja, bestimmt gehen auch Leute, weil sie sagen, ich komme
nicht mehr mit der Firmenstruktur, ich komme da nicht mehr klar und ich will das nicht
mehr, aber ich finde, vergleich es mal mit Fußball, ja.
Ungern, Clegg.
Na ja, ehrlich gesagt, da liegt mir auch nichts ferner, aber es ist ein bisschen ähnlich,
das Herz der Fans ist immer beim Verein und ja, und die stehen dafür und meine ganze
Kindheit und die haben schon damals und so, ja, natürlich und das ist auch das, was viel
Geld in die Kassen spielt, ja, klar, Marketing und so weiter kommt noch dazu und Merchandise,
aber am Ende ist halt der FC Bayern nicht nur elf Leute oder mit denen, die auf der Bank
sind, ein Verein, die halt Fußball spielen, sondern da gehört halt noch ein ganz großer
anderer Apparat dazu, der auch funktionieren muss und es ist halt auch sehr wichtig, dass
das, was da auf dem Platz passiert, dann immer zu einem bestimmten Ergebnis führt und für
die einen, für das eine Firmenkonstrukt reicht halt, ok, erste Liga irgendwo, fürs andere
reicht halt nur Meister und Champions League und hier und da und so sind diese Dinge halt
aufgebaut, was aber nicht im Umkehrschluss, das wollte ich eigentlich sagen, heißt, dass
diese Leute, jetzt bei Blizzard zum Beispiel, die dann wirklich die Spiele machen, nicht
immer noch die kreativen sind, nicht immer noch die, die in ihren, sag ich mal, ich glaube,
bei keinem Entwicklerstudio sitzen zum größten Teil Leute, die kein gutes Game abliefern
wollen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass irgendwo absichtlich Scheiße gemacht wird.
Mal Kinderzimmern mit Postern, mit Actionfiguren, wirklich denen diese Surroundings gegeben
werden, dass sie da so kreativ wie möglich sein können, das bestmögliche Produkt abliefern
können.
Warum ist es denn so?
Ja, aber Mobile Games, Mobile Games zähle ich da schon gar nicht mehr dabei.
Weil ARPGs angeguckt, wegen halt wieder Hype für Diablo 4 und so.
Es tut mir sehr leid, Wolcen, Last Epoch, Grim Dawn, wie sie alle heißen, ich hab alle
ausprobiert, es kommt vom Gameplay her nichts an Diablo 3 ran, steinigt mich, ihr wisst
wie geil ich bin, ihr könnt mich befeuern, von den Hintergrundsystemen her vielleicht
schon, aber vom purem Action-Gameplay ist es immer noch ungeschlagen.
Aber das ist ein schönes Beispiel.
Passive Exile ist das Beste, was es gibt.
Die Leute wollen immer, mach doch was mit Diablo.
Ja, natürlich, wenn du dir irgendwelche Asset-Flips auf Steam anguckst, schon, aber ich meine,
das bei den großen Entwicklerstudios, bei den großen, da sitzt auch keiner da und sagt
so nach dem Motto, ne, wir bauen das jetzt besonders scheiße, das hat meistens äußere
Umstände.
Die meisten wollen ein ordentliches Spiel abliefern, da bin ich mir sicher.
Asset-Flips, ich meine Asset-Flips, nicht Asset, Asset-Flips hören sich ja irgendwie
an nach irgendwelchen chemischen Substanzen, ja.
Gibt uns doch hier, gibt uns doch da, man muss sagen, Leute, ihr habt einmal für dieses
Spiel bezahlt und das war vor wann, acht Jahren oder sieben Jahren, irgendwie so und
es gibt keinerlei Dinge, die ihr in dieses Spiel bezahlen könnt, also keine Cosmetics,
es gibt nichts, es gibt keine In-Game-Transactions, die ihr alle so sehr hasst auch.
Mehr Add-ons, ich zahl doch für Add-ons.
Tatsächlich für Diablo nicht.
Doch es gab noch eine Klasse, konnte man nachkaufen.
Aber das würde ich jetzt wirklich als Add-on sehen, ja, aber du hast jetzt nicht wie Bay
Clash Royale oder so.
Die Leute wollten mehr Add-ons, für die sie durchaus auch zahlen wollten.
So, das heißt, da ist es hier ganz klar, wir machen das einmal und dann muss das beim
Verkauf oder vielleicht...
Okay, okay, na, da muss ich sagen, das ist nicht reiner Fanservice, wobei Fanservice
ja bei unseren Freunden aus dem Animeland ein bisschen was anderes bedeutet, also das
ist nicht reiner, rein um die Fans glücklich zu machen, dass die Diablo 3 supporten.
Wenn die Diablo 3 nicht weiter supportet hätten, das Ding wäre einfach gestorben.
Komplett.
Also das ist schon eigenes Interesse dran, dass die Diablo 3 supportet haben, man darf
ja auch nicht vergessen, Diablo hat auch eine gewisse Konkurrenz, ja, und die haben bestimmt
keinen Bock, dass die Leute bis zur Diablo 4 Release allesamt in Path of Exile oder sonst
wo drin stecken und sich denken, was, Diablo 4 kommt raus, ist mir scheißegal.
Der Hype wird eh nach Diablo 3 am Anfang jetzt ein bisschen verhaltener sein, wobei, weiß
man nie so genau, marketingtechnisch ist Activision hat es ja da voll drauf, wahrscheinlich wird
es trotzdem wieder erfolgreich sein, ich meine, Diablo ist ein großes Ding, aber das ist
nicht nur um die Fans zu erfreuen, das ist genauso wie Rainbow Six nicht weiter betrieben
wurde, gut, da gibt es jetzt vieles zum Kaufen und diesen Passage und so, einfach nur um
die Fans zu erfreuen, da ist schon ganz viel Eigeninteresse dran und die bauen Anthem jetzt
auch nicht weiter um, nur um die Leute zu erfreuen und das wird man in Anthem auch sehen, je
nachdem was für ein Modell die wählen, wenn das nämlich ein Modell ist, wo nicht weiter
irgendwie Kohle reinkommt oder irgendwie was vom Vorteil für sie passiert, dann wird auch
Anthem 2.0 nichts großartiges neues bringen oder nichts, was das Game großartig ändert,
weil für die grundsätzlichen Sachen müsstest du da schon ordentlich Entwicklungszeiten
und Geld natürlich reinstecken und ob man das bereit ist zu tun, außer zu versprechen
man macht das, ob man das wirklich macht, hängt ganz davon ab, wie sehr die noch sehen,
dass man da mit Geld machen kann bzw. zumindest wie sehr sie hoffen, dass sie das ganze irgendwie
noch stärken oder vielleicht, wenn es nur mindestens so ist, dass die Leute wenigstens
Anthem spielen und nicht Destiny, da haben sie auch schon was gewonnen. Also ganz so nach
dem Motto, nur um die Fans zu erfreuen, ist das mit Sicherheit nicht.
Das ist beim Verkauf vom nächsten DLC so knallend, dass über Jahre hinweg, wenn wir euch die
Seasons und alles geben wollen, die Finanzierung dafür halt klar ist. Und ich finde schon,
das kann man dem Spieler, also gerade wenn die ein bisschen jetzt erwachsener sind, schon
mal abverlangen sich auch darüber Gedanken zu machen. Wer würde denn das World of Warcraft
3 oder das Titan, was auch immer es war, falls es es überhaupt jemals gegeben hat, wer hätte
es denn gekauft, wer würde es denn spielen? Und eine Community, jeder der Leute, die jetzt
die meckern, haben ein Smartphone. Und ich sage jetzt einfach mal, auch jeder hat irgendwie
ein Tablet.
Da darf der andere auch noch mal was sagen heute.
Jeder benutzt es Tag für Tag für seine Netflix-Serien, für seine E-Mails, für alles. Und es muss
auch klar sein, dass dieser Markt auch irgendwie von den Unternehmen erschlossen werden muss
oder es wird sterben. Das Blizzard, das man sich so anguckt, mit dem Morhain und allem,
wie sie da am Boden saßen und Magic gespielt haben, dein Lieblingskarten-Spiel.
Gute Leute.
Natürlich ist das ihre Legacy und die Origin, da kommen sie her. Aber sie wären vielleicht
auch noch da. Und jetzt nicht da, hätte es kein World of Warcraft und so gegeben, wenn
sie da geblieben wären und nicht irgendwie in den...
Ich glaube letztendlich, das ist allen klar. Es ist relativ klar, warum Blizzard die Sachen
so macht, wie sie es machen. Der eigentliche Punkt ist doch viel eher, dass es den Leuten
nicht gefällt.
Dass sie sich eben mit Blizzard spielen und dem, was Blizzard macht, was anderes verbinden
als das, was aktuell gerade läuft.
Ich meine, es ist ein Unterschied dazu, ob ich mir erklären kann, warum jemand was macht
oder ob ich gut finde, was jemand macht. Und ich kann mir das durchaus erklären, warum
das bei Blizzard so läuft. Das ist ja auch das, was sie alles erzählt haben. Das hat
schon Hand und Fuß. Ich kann mir auch erklären, warum das so ist. Ob mir das jetzt gefällt,
das ist ja wieder ganz anderes.
...zu einem Konzern geworden wären, ja.
Dann kommen wir mal zum Schlusswort tatsächlich, weil ich merke, wir reden schon sehr lange,
glaube ich.
Ich wollte nur ganz kurz da ergänzen. Das ist tatsächlich eben das. Wie gesagt, auch
das bei uns, eine GameStar ist jetzt auch 22 Jahre alt und so. Das ist halt, wenn Dinge
lange laufen, Dinge verändern sich auch durch die Personen, die dann da sind. Neue kommen
dazu, haben andere Schwerpunkte. Und deswegen meine ich, dass man hier ein bisschen deutlicher
gesagt hat, dass Blizzard eben, was es heute gibt, ist nicht das, was viele im Kopf haben.
Und viele sollten halt dann eher mal wieder gucken, wo können sie denn andere, sozusagen
wo können sie ihr neues Blizzard finden.
Ja, da hat er voll und ganz recht. Da hat er voll und ganz recht. Es hat wenig Sinn,
wenn quasi hier die Stonks-Typen das sagen haben bei Blizzard, permanent drauf rumzuhacken
so nach dem Motto, oh Blizzard macht nicht mehr das, was ich will. Macht nicht das,
was ich will. Das wird Blizzard auch nicht mehr tun. Was aber nicht heißt, dass es nicht
doch die ein oder anderen Games gibt, die einem quasi das Gefühl wiedergeben. Da sitzt
ja jemand dahinter, der wirklich, wo Herzblut in dem Game steckt. Das gibt's. Das einzige
Problem, was ich dabei sehe, ist, es ist unglaublich schwierig, gute Sachen zu finden. Also wenn
man sich mal durch Steam durchguckt, Steam ist so voll. Steam ist so voll von Bullshit.
Egal in welchem Sektor. Im Triple-A Sektor natürlich, da kommt viel Bullshit raus. Aber
gerade im Indie, Alter, Steam ist so ein Drecksloch, was Spiele angeht. Ich glaube, es ist nicht
übertrieben, wenn ich sage, auf Steam sind 95% Schrott. Und die restlichen 5% von denen
sind 90% auch nicht der Wahnsinn, aber die letzten 10%, die muss man halt finden. Und
95% ist eh untertrieben, ja wahrscheinlich. Genau, du musst das gut im Scheißhaufen finden,
so sieht's aus. Und woran man finde ich, das muss ich mal sagen, woran man finde ich immer
noch ganz gut sieht, wie die Leute ticken ist. Also gerade bei größeren Sachen. Wieso
die Konferenzen und Sachen abgehalten werden. Manche Sachen sind so cringe-mäßig, wo du
richtig merkst, okay, da haben sich jetzt ein Marketing-Mensch und ein BWL-Mensch zusammengesetzt
und haben da sich überlegt, was wir irgendwie in der Show zeigen können oder so. Deswegen
sind die ganzen Konferenzen und Ankündigungen heute auch so wenig Gameplay und so wenig Inhalt,
sondern so viel Bullshit drumherum. Da muss ich einfach angucken, wer da sagen hat. Ich
meine, wenn die ein neues Need for Speed ankündigen, ich meine, die Marke kannst du dir eh mittlerweile
vergessen, da ist erstmal 10 Minuten Show mit irgendeinem prominenten, keine Ahnung,
Basketball-Spieler, nee, Moment, wir sind ja bei EA, mit irgendeinem prominenten Formel-1-Fahrer,
der kommt dann mit einem super expensive Auto aus dem LKW gefahren, es qualt ein bisschen
rum, fährt ein bisschen im Kreis, dann kommt irgendwie so ein möchtigeren Influencer-Mensch,
der das Ganze moderiert, irgendwelche schlechte Witze darüber macht. In 30% der Präsentation,
ich hab jetzt einfach mal Need for Speed genannt, weil ich hab die letzten Need for Speed-Sachen
gar nicht mehr geguckt, geschweige denn gespielt, aber das ist bei vielen AAA-Sachen so. Die
machen 30, 30, guckt euch, die Battlefield-1-Präsentation war auch so ein Ding, die machen
30% Show und am Ende bist du fast genauso wenig schlau wie vorher. Cyberpunk und Keanu-Hilfe
war geil, ja das stimmt, aber dem hast du, der Sache hast du auch angemerkt, das ist
halt kein komplett gescriptetes Cringe-Ding gewesen ist, sondern der hat wahrscheinlich
echt Bock auf das Game, damit zu machen. Natürlich kriegt er Kohle für, aber das wäre
bescheuert, umsonst würde er das nicht machen. Angeblich soll es ja sogar so gewesen sein,
dass er gesagt hat, ihm gefällt das, er will eine größere Rolle haben und irgendwie kaufe
ich ihm das sogar ab. Snoop Dogg Battlefield 1 gespielt hat, das fand ich sogar cool.
Wo Snoop Dogg Battlefield 1 gespielt hat, das war geil, der ist einfach nur im, der hat
einfach, das war geil, der ist einfach nur im Kreis gelaufen die ganze Zeit in irgendeinem
Kram und hat irgendwie einen Joint geraut, Snoop Dogg Battlefield 1, das war geil, alter.
Hier, das ist es, der läuft die ganze Zeit hier geradeaus hin und zurück in diesem Kram,
alter. So geil, alter. Der ist die ganze Zeit hier hin und her gelaufen.
Sieht man das Scoreboard von ihm? Sieht man das Scoreboard von ihm irgendwo?
Wo ist er denn? Ist er da selbst? 2 zu 4. Big Brain, alter. Massive.
Wie schwer tun sich denn die Kleinen, die Neuen auf dem Markt, wie schwer ist es dort
durchzuhalten, sichtbar zu bleiben, irgendwie eine Community aufzubauen und deswegen würde
ich halt immer sagen, ja Blizzard wird dann noch weitergehen und die machen halt dann
eher Sachen wieder für den Großmarkt und müssen für irgendwie eben eher an die 100
Millionen Spieler denken, aber es gibt da draußen andere, so eben wie ein CD Projekt
eben auch aufgekommen ist, als aus einer Nische, wo andere das eher ein bisschen ignoriert
hatten und dann konnten sie mit wieder hoch wachsen, dann kann man sie lieben und vergöttern,
aber ganz sicher werden sie auch in 20 Jahren wahrscheinlich auch wieder nicht mehr das
sein, was wir heute sind und dann werden andere wieder sagen, ja, aber früher und das ist
eben auch natürlicher. Als ihr noch diese tollen DLCs für Witcher 3 gemacht habt, 10
Euro für 30 Stunden oder so, was macht ihr heute? Eine Unternehmung ist ein Stück weit
natürlich auch ein Lebendesobjekt und so weiter und da haben wir jetzt gar nicht drüber
gesprochen. Ja, aber das muss mir als derjenige, der die Spiele gut fand, die sie gemacht
haben, die Entwicklung muss mir ja nicht gefallen, dass er das, was ich die ganze Zeit sagen will.
Es ist eine Sache, ob man das nachvollziehen kann, warum was so ist oder ob man es gut
findet. Am Ende ist es ein Aktien- oder ein börsennotiertes Unternehmen. Es ist, also
für Blizzard und CD Projekt ist es vollkommen unerheblich, ob ich das gut finde oder ob
die Leute das gut finden. Wenn die Kohle machen wollen, machen sie Kohle, das juckt
dir nicht, aber ich persönlich muss es ja nicht gut finden, auch wenn ich weiß, warum
sie es machen. Dort auch Bobby Kotick werden halt leider, würde ich jetzt mal so sagen,
aber eben sehr nur über eben auch diese Performance an der Börse gelohnt. Also ich hab mal nachgeguckt,
er hat irgendwie so 30 Millionen Dollar-Compensation am letzten Jahr erhalten oder stehen die mit
zu und ich glaube, wenn ich es richtig zusammen gerechnet hab, sind davon über 80% gekoppelt
an den Unternehmenswert oder an den Aktienkurs. Das heißt, er wiederum... Wie, wenn er das
nicht erfüllt hätte, dann hätte er nur 5 Millionen gekriegt. Da kannst du ja fast nichts
mehr leisten.
Nur wo Kunden sind, wo Märkte sind und dann schiebt er die Unternehmung dahin und wenn
dann man sagt, okay, ich muss eine Million Diablo-Fans zurücklassen, weil ich schiel
ja auf die 100 Millionen Mobile-Fans, dann tut er das.
Bitte jetzt keine Kommentare zu, ich würde auch mit 20% von 30 Millionen Dollar klarkommen.
Es geht gar nicht darum, dass der rumheult, der heult ja nicht rum, ich will nur die...
Der ist knallhart.
Und auch da wieder ist es so, es ist Big Business und das ist das Image so, wir sind
doch von euch, von Spielern...
Das machen sie alle.
...ist manchmal einfach auch eben nur genau das ist ein Image.
Das ist...
Das ist auch schon Teil der Marketinggeschichte.
Geschwätze.
Das muss allen klar sein, dass die ihre Spieler weder lieben noch wirklich das ernst meinen,
wenn sie erzählen nach dem Motto, wir haben die besten und dedikatesten und sonst was,
das ist alles Berechnung.
Das muss allen klar sein.
Ja, der Lion King, alles schön, kuschelig, nett oder frozen, das sind knallharte Milliarden
Unternehmen und wer dahinter guckt, sieht das halt auch.
Und da muss man sich dann halt eher insgesamt fragen, aber wie gesagt, das würde ich nicht
Blizzard per se oder Activision immer vorhalten, oh ihr wollt Geld verdienen, ihr seid gierig
und so.
So in dieser Welt haben wir uns ein bisschen entschieden halt auch zu leben, Kapitalismus,
Marktwirtschaft etc.
Und so weiter und so fort.
Aber was ich scheiße finden kann ist, ich kann es ihnen nicht wirklich übel nehmen,
ich kann es ihnen nicht wirklich wollen, aber was ich halt scheiße finden kann ist, dass
da nicht mehr die Spiele rauskommen, die mir Spaß machen, das ist ja das, woraus letztendlich
für mich als Spieler ankommt.
Dann will, wie gesagt, dann lieber Sachen unterstützen, die es anders machen, was Neues
probieren, die sich wieder hochkämpfen wollen, aber vielleicht nicht dann immer hoffen,
dass der Megakonzern dann immer noch der totale Fan-Versteher ist und auf jeden Einzelnen
guckt.
Da kannst du eh nicht mehr drauf hoffen.
Ob sich Sachen wie Diablo Immortal und so damals auf den Aktienkurs ausgewirkt haben,
ich meine schon, dass das Kurs nach unten ging, aber das hat nie langfristig…
Ich glaube nicht viel.
Das ist auch so eine totale Mähre.
Schon, gell?
Ist nix, ist nix.
Ich habe nur zum Hintergrund, warum ich darüber rede, ich habe dreieinhalb Jahre mal als Wirtschaftsredakteur
gearbeitet bei der dpa und es gibt so viel auch wieder Halbwissen, Unwissen über Verhalten
von Aktienmärkten und ich sehe ganz oft YouTube-Videos, Blizzard-Shares, Crash-After, Announcment.
Entschuldigung, das ist nicht immer ganz so, weil der Gesamtmarkt beeinflusst das viel
stärker und zum Beispiel Blizzard hatte seinen Höchststand, ich habe nochmal nachgeguckt
jetzt was die Aktienkurve angeht, ich glaube Sommer 2018, sie haben danach massiv verloren,
haben zuletzt wieder ein bisschen gewonnen, sprich der Gesamtmarkt und damit meine ich
gar nicht jetzt nur die Börse an sich, sondern auch der Gesamtgaming-Markt kann mehr entscheidend
sein als sowas wie ein verpatztes Announcment, auch jetzt mit Warcraft hatte ich auch ein
Video gesehen, irgendwie Shares fell 5% nach Reforged-Desaster und so, das stimmt nicht,
der gesamte Markt hatte in dem Tag massig verloren und am nächsten Tag ging es wieder
hoch.
War ganz davon abgesehen, als würde das jemand, der wirklich daran auch interessiert ist an
sich, ob der großartige Jucken, das Reforged in die Hose gegangen ist, ich glaube die würde
das viel eher jucken, wenn Blizzard noch, es ist immer rein Stonks und Geldsicht, die
würde das wahrscheinlich viel eher jucken, wenn Blizzard noch 3 Jahre an Reforged rumgebastelt
hätte und massig Geld verschlungen hätte für ein Produkt, was sich eventuell gar nicht
so gut verkauft und das ist denen wahrscheinlich lieber, es kommt jetzt raus, hat ein bisschen
Kohle gekostet und verkauft sich wahrscheinlich auch nicht so wahnsinnig gut, weiß ich nicht,
wie da die Zeilen sind, das ist denen mit Sicherheit lieber.
Sehr komplex, das heißt nicht, dass nicht irgendwie langfristige Entscheidungen negativ
sind, aber auch da wieder, das Gesamtunternehmen, hier man sieht es auch, ist auf einem sehr
guten Weg gewesen, sie haben jetzt, deswegen auch die Cuts, hatten wir jetzt gerade drüber
gesprochen, sie haben letztes Jahr, glaube ich, angekündigt, 800 Leute zu entlassen.
Also Activision Blizzard insgesamt.
Activision Blizzard als Gesamtes.
Das waren vor allem Support-Mitarbeiter und so und das war auch teilweise zum Beispiel
weil sie Destiny nicht mehr hatten, also der Destiny-Support wurde gekartet und so.
Ja und sie wussten schon, sie kommen in einen Bereich, wo sie jetzt erstmal Umsatzschwäche
haben und das ist dann auch wieder ganz normal, auch da wieder muss man nicht gut finden,
aber so ist es halt, gerade in den USA, man holt schnell Leute rein, wenn man sie braucht,
wenn man schnell wächst und man folgt sie auch, wenn man sagt, ok, jetzt sieht es nicht
so doll aus, aber wie gesagt, im Gesamtspektrum, sonst wäre auch Bobby Kotik nicht so lange
dabei, führt Activision sehr erfolgreich, das muss man leider auch mal festhalten und
das ist nämlich dann auch noch der entscheidende Punkt von Blizzard, ist nicht, wie ihr Umsatz
gerade ist.
Sie haben ein Problem mit ihren Active-Usern, weil das ist die Haupteinheit, also viele Unternehmen,
also gerade auch Spieleunternehmen müssen jetzt offenlegen, wie viel Monthly, also MAU
heißt das, Monthly Active Users haben sie.
Ok, dann ist das das, was ich vorhin versucht habe zu umschreiben, ich wusste nicht, wie
man das genau nennt, mit, dass sie das nicht reinmachen, Diablo 3 am Leben halten für
die Fans.
Einzige Teil innerhalb der Gesamt-Corporation, die verloren haben, nämlich von 35 Millionen
Active User 2018, jetzt in einem neuen Report, jetzt von letzter Woche sind es noch 32, während
alle anderen beiden Sparten, hier King auf 150 Millionen Active User und Activision selbst
mit Call of Duty, ich habe nicht mehr den genauen Wert, das war auch deutlich gestiegen,
durch den Erfolg von Call of Duty ist wieder hoch und das ist nämlich der Signal, wenn
du da siehst, ok, du verlierst irgendwie deine Active User, dann wird die Unternehmung anfangen
und wahrscheinlich wird sie aber nicht anfangen im Spielersinne, nämlich ok, dann geben wir
dem ganzen noch 3 Jahre mehr und dann machen wir noch mehr, sondern sie werden vermutlich
eher weiter anfangen zu fokussieren und zu restrukturieren, also sozusagen Overwatch,
alle Kraft darauf und das eher weg, das eher weg, also auch dort, das würde mich nicht
wundern, wenn wir in 3 Jahren hier sitzen und dann gibt es vielleicht nur noch 2 Blizzard
IPs oder maximal 3, das wäre zum Beispiel jetzt so meine Prognose in die Zukunft, in
diesem Firmenkonstrukt, in diesem Firmenkonstrukt glaube ich, wird der Weg in Richtung Mobile
gehen, in Richtung weniger IPs, in Richtung volle Monetarisierung von, wie du schon sagtest,
von Spielen, die lange laufen, die dauerhaft Geld einbringen müssen.
Sehr schlimm hier, in 3 Jahren mag ich Blizzard nicht mehr, in 20 Jahren mag ich CD Projekt
nicht mehr, geh weg René, das ist genug, das fand ich auch tatsächlich ein schönes
Schlusswort von dir wiederum, dass man dann als Spieler ja durchaus angehalten ist, mal
zu gucken, was könnte denn das neue Blizzard sein.
Steam ist voll, Game Pass ist voll, PSD-Signal ist voll, mit so vielen tollen, also nicht
nur Indies, es gibt schon gute Sachen, aber es ist halt, es ist wirklich schwierig was
zu finden.
Es gibt so viel, also wir leben in einer Zeit von so viel Auswahl von so vielen guten Spielen
und vielleicht müssen wir halt mal wieder ein bisschen aus unserer Komfortzone raus,
ein bisschen wieder neugierig sein und da einfach auch mal anderen Sachen wieder eine Chance
geben.
Das finde ich gut, wir werden jetzt damit, bevor du wieder irgendwas böses, düsteres
sagst, nein, geh weg, dann danke ich euch beiden für eure Einschätzung und gebt das
mal noch an die Zuschauer weiter, habt ihr denn Tipps, was das nächste Blizzard sein
könnte für Leute, die jetzt deprimiert sind wegen...
Wenn ich das hätte, würde ich mir Stonks kaufen.
Das einzige worauf ich mich im Gaming Sektor wirklich in naher Zukunft freue, also so innerhalb
von 10 Tagen, ist die neue Path of Exile League, da werde ich wieder mit den Hintern
und Wunden grinden.
Wie gesagt, ich habe jetzt ja die erste League wieder gespielt seit 5 Jahren, wo ich das
Game nicht angefasst habe, das hat ultra Bock gemacht.
Ich setze jetzt auf, am Ende der League, ich meine die League ist vorbei, ich glaube in
3 Tagen oder so, oder so, wann ist das, zehnte in der Woche, in der Woche ist die aktuelle
Path of Exile League vorbei, also viel werde ich da jetzt auch nicht mehr machen.
Ich habe ziemlich viel in-game Währung noch über, ich habe gerade glaube ich jetzt 12
exalted Orbs über und wassig Chaos Orbs, also ich könnte meinen zweiten Charakter
locker noch magieren für die letzten 10 Tage, aber es macht halt übelst Bock, macht halt
übelst Bock.
Und ich habe noch lange nicht alles soweit gecheckt, dass ich gut klarkommen würde in
dem Game.
League grind, also es kann durchaus sein, dass wir einen Path of Exile Stream machen,
wenn die League startet, muss mal gucken, an welchem Tag startet die noch mal, guck mal
mal.
Ach fuck, wie hieß das neue, PoE, D, Delirium, wann kommt das raus, wann startet, dreizehnten,
am dreizehnten, der dreizehnte ist ein Freitag, oh das ist wunderbar, Freitag, da machen wir
wahrscheinlich wirklich mal einen 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10 Stunden PoE grindstream.
Welche Seite ist eigentlich gut um im PoE einzusteigen, guck dir ein paar Tutorials
auf YouTube an.
So, ok, und jetzt, was soll ich mir noch den Tweet von Ninja soll ich mir noch angucken,
ein sehr kontroverser Tweet hat jemand geschrieben, mal gucken wie kontrovers dieser Tweet wirklich
ist von Ninja.
Was hat er geschrieben, ähm, die Aussage, es ist nur ein Spiel, ist, oh fuck, wie soll
ich das jetzt übersetzen, ist, ist, ist, schlechte, ist eine schwache, eine schwache Einstellung,
könnte man das so übersetzen, schwache Einstellung, ähm, wenn man zufrieden ist mit dem was passiert,
äh, wenn man zufrieden ist damit zu verlieren, wenn man mit, äh, irgendwie nicht perfekt
im Spielen, ähm, zufrieden ist, äh, wenn man aufhört, äh, sauer zu werden nachdem
man verloren hat, hat man doppelt verloren, ähm, es gibt immer Sachen zu lernen und es
ist immer, äh, Raum sich zu verbessern, äh, man soll niemals Ruhe geben, ok, äh, warum
ist das jetzt so, so kontrovers, warum ist das jetzt so kontrovers dieser Tweet, er hat
doch prinzipiell, also wenn man das mal auf, auf, auf Spielen beziehungsweise auf sich
verbessern, sich verbessern bezieht hat er doch recht, man muss sich einfach überlegen,
äh, wie ernst man was nimmt, wie ernst man, wenn man was rein aus casual, rein aus just
for fun macht, ähm, und keine Ambitionen hat, da irgendwie besser drin zu werden, irgendwie
im Rank zu steigen oder sonst was, hey, dann ist das vollkommen zu, ok zu sagen, oh fuck,
nehmen wir auf auf watch, ja, wenn man da wirklich keine Ambitionen hat, irgendwie einen besseren
Rank zu kriegen oder CS oder LOL oder irgendwas, ja, und, ähm, man spielt einfach nur mal
ab und zu vielleicht mit ein paar Freunden, die man L kennt, irgendwie ein paar Runde,
vielleicht sogar irgendwelche Bot-Matches oder so, äh, es gibt ja gerade, gerade solche
hyper casual Leute haben ja Probleme mit PvP-Spielen, die spielen am liebsten gegen Bots oder sonst
was, ähm, oder auch, dann ist es doch vollkommen ok zu sagen, es ist nur ein Spiel, aber ihm
geht es ja nicht darum, sondern ihm geht es um Leute, die sich verbessern wollen in dem
Spiel, eindeutig, und, ähm, wenn man dort quasi bei jedem Mal, wo man verliert, sagt,
ach nee, ist ja nicht so schlimm, äh, ist ja nur ein Spiel, dann, äh, wird man auch
nicht das Interesse haben, die Maßnahmen zu ergreifen, die notwendig sind, dass man
besser wird, was nicht bedeutet, ähm, was nicht bedeutet, dass man, äh, seine, schreibt
er irgendwie seine Tastatur einschlagen soll, sondern unter anderem, mal angenommen, ich
spiel jetzt, ähm, ich spiel jetzt irgendwie, ich spiel Overwatch, ich spiel, ich spiel
Ana als Support, so, ähm, und ich hab ne Runde verloren, es ist einfach zu sagen, ähm,
ah, das ist, das ist nur ein Spiel, ich lock jetzt aus, sonst was, ok, aber wenn man Ambitionen
hat, sich zu verbessern, wäre es ziemlich bescheuert zu sagen, so nach dem Motto, ach,
da kann ich eh nix dran machen, es war entweder das Team, oder es war das Spiel, nee, eine
der Sachen, die man dann machen kann, ist, natürlich isst man stinkig, und am besten
isst man erstmal sauer, natürlich unter anderem auf sein Team, das ist, geht in Team Games
immer ein bisschen Hand in Hand, aber man isst auch, und das merkt ihr, das habt ihr
wahrscheinlich schon öfters auch gemerkt, wenn ich manchmal Sachen spiele, wo ich mal
ganz gut drin gewesen bin, und jetzt mittlerweile sacke, ne, also Spiele, wo ich dann lange
nicht gespielt hab, wo wir beispielsweise ein bisschen mit dem Eaxe vor einer Weile
wieder Overwatch Rank gespielt haben, war ich übelst stinkig, allerdings auf mich selber,
ähm, und, ähm, auch wo wir mal wieder angefangen haben, hier ein bisschen, ein bisschen Battlefield
zu spielen, und so, da bin ich übelst sauer, aber gar nicht so sehr auf das Game, sondern
weil ich weiß, dass ich es gerade voll verkacke, und wenn man, wenn man das sich nicht ein,
da hat er vollkommen recht, wenn man das sich nicht eingestehen kann, ähm, dann hast du,
hast du gelitten, ja, und was man machen kann, ist ja nicht, dass man sich dann selbst irgendwie,
äh, du musst ja nicht selbst irgendwie eine klatschen und sagen, Max Spiel besser, das
hilft nix, ähm, du musst dann Sachen, du musst dann Maßnahmen ergreifen, die, die
helfen besser zu werden, gibt's ja verschiedenste Dinger, du kannst dir Replays angucken und
analysieren, was du verkehrt gemacht hast, du kannst mit deinen Teammates, wenn du ein
festes Team hast, drüber sprechen, ok, was für ne Taktik wollen wir machen, wie, wie,
wie wollen wir das in Zukunft, wie wollen wir das in Zukunft spielen, ähm, vielleicht
haben auch deine Teammates Hinweise, was man machen könnte, es kommt halt immer drauf an,
ob man gescheite Teammates hat oder nicht, welche die nur flamen können, oder welche
die auch ordentlich was sagen können, ähm, man kann gucken, ok, was ist denn das, was
ich, was es mir mechanik-mäßig fehlt, fehlt's mir daran, dass ich die Maps nicht kenne,
fehlt's mir daran, dass ich nicht aimen kann, ist meine Hardware kacke für das jeweilige
Game, was auch immer, das wichtigste ist, man muss analysieren, woran das liegt, warum
man verkackt hat, und wenn man die Aussage trifft, es ist nur ein Spiel, nicht weiter
schlimm, und man hat die Ambition, in dem Spiel besser zu werden, dann verträgt sich
das nicht, weil wenn man einfach nur sagt, es ist nur ein Spiel, und juckt mich nicht,
dann wird man das nicht analysieren, und dementsprechend auch nicht besser werden, und aus dem Gesichtspunkt
hat er doch vollkommen recht, über was regen sich die Leute denn jetzt da drin auf?
Der hat doch vollkommen recht, wenn's um Competitive Games geht, ok, also was antworten die Leute
dann drauf?
This is disappointing, this is a disappointing stance, ah ja, but why?
Guck mal, die Antwort ist vollkommen an dem vorbei, was er geschrieben hat, die Antwort
ist voll an dem vorbei, was er geschrieben hat, also wie ich das interpretiere, hab ich
ja grad erzählt, in den letzten 10 Minuten irgendwie, aber die Antwort ist doch vollkommen
an dem vorbei, was er geschrieben hat, und vor allem, es ist doch vollkommen egal, auch
bei dieser Aussage, wer er jetzt persönlich ist, das ist ein Ding, das könnte man für
alle Competitive Sachen so umschreiben, aber ok, sie ist enttäuscht, dass er so eine Einstellung
hat, vor allem von jemandem, der quasi so eine Zuschauergemeinschaft hat, und die würde
das ja angeblich, die Zuschauer würden das ja angeblich so auffassen wie, es ist in
Ordnung, wenn ich mein Keyboard kaputt schlage und screamed at my loved ones, alter was ein
bescheuertes Reininterpretieren, das was er da gepostet hat, sowas beknacktes, also das
könnte mich echt aufregen, sowas, das hat er nie gesagt, nicht mal, das kann man, wenn
man ehrlich ist, kann man das da noch nicht mal reininterpretieren, das kann man, also
man muss schon wirklich, man muss schon, das tut, das ist wirklich Pains Jam, das tut weh,
da muss man schon wirklich sehr, sehr, sehr weit ausholen, dass man auf die Idee kommt,
das da rein zu interpretieren, was er geschrieben hat, also, oh Gott, punch a hole in the wall
just because I lost the game, auf der anderen Seite, gehen wir mal den Extremfall aus, angenommen,
das um jetzt mal zu zeigen, dass ein Loch in die Wand schlagen ist ein bisschen übertrieben,
aber sag mal, den Controller gegen die Wand pfeffern, dass das nicht, dass das eigentlich
was menschliches ist, weil, überlegt euch mal, jemand möchte wirklich besser werden
in dem Game, wirklich besser werden in irgendwas und hat auch wirklich viel geübt, ja, mal
angenommen, jemand hat viel, jemand hat viel, viel, viel gelernt für sonst was und im entscheidenden
Moment verkackt das, dann ist er halt übelst enttäuscht und sauer auf sich selbst und
dann kann auch mal ein Controller an die Wand fliegen, so what, ja, ich glaube die Leute
interpretieren das angry ein bisschen zu, es geht einfach eher darum, dass man auf sich
selbst sauer ist, dass man ein bisschen böse auf sich selbst ist, weil man es verkackt
hat, wenn man das nicht hat, hat man auch kaum eine Motivation zu sagen, ich will das
besser machen, du musst dir erstmal denken, scheiße, da hab ichs verkackt, du musst erstmal
diese Einsicht, diese Einsicht haben, so nach dem Motto, scheiße, ich habs verkackt und
allein schon mit dieser Aussage merkst du ja, oh fuck, ich habs verkackt, weil wenn du
das nicht merkst, dann kommst du ja auch gar nicht auf die Idee, aha, da muss ich was
machen, it's just a dream, das ist eigentlich eine gute copypasta, oder, this place is just
a game, da könnte man eine gute copypasta draus machen, alter, was, das ist die Antwort
hier, wer ist das überhaupt, bomb, wer ist geekbomb, was ist geekbomb, keine Ahnung,
was das ist, oh god, oh, das ist so, das schmerzt ja, das tut ja weh, oh god, alter, was ist
mit den Leuten los, muss man echt allem irgendwie so seinen Stempel aufdrücken, es geht ihm
offensichtlich um Leute, die sich in einer gewissen Disziplin verbessern wollen, es ist
doch vollkommen egal, ob das jetzt CS ist, Fortnite oder, keine Ahnung, 100 Meter schwimmen
oder so, es ist doch vollkommen egal, jemand, der für sich sagt, er möchte besser werden,
der von sich selbst, der an sich selbst den Anspruch hat, in einer Disziplin besser zu
werden, da gehts ihm doch drum, da gehts ihm doch drum, und da sagt doch auch nicht einer
so nach dem Motto, ah ja gut, ich hab jetzt zwar 3 Monate, 3 Monate hier, hab ich das
zwar trainiert, dass ich das hinkriege, aber ja, es hat leider jetzt nicht funktioniert,
nein, die Leute sind stinkig, wenn es nicht funktioniert hat, und die sind meistens stinkig
auf sich selber, nee, falsches E-Mode, da platzt der Mensch den Kopf, wenn man das liest,
es ist immer Raum für Verbesserung, gewinnen heißt nicht zwangsläufig, ich bin erster Platz,
aber natürlich ist es das Ziel von jemandem, der sich in irgendwas verbessern will, dass
er damit auch gewinnt, gegenüber anderen, wo er besser ist, immer wenn du besser bist
und was besser ausfühlst, hast du gewonnen in dem Sinn, ich kann jetzt nicht verstehen,
warum die da so, meiner Meinung nach gut, wenn du 5,5 Millionen Follower hast, da bleibt
das nicht aus, ja Matt, genau, das ist ja genau das, und überhaupt nichts, wo man wahnsinnig
drüber empören muss, aber eins zeigt uns das wieder, dass wenn sowas schon kontrovers
ist, wenn sowas schon als kontrovers gilt, dann hilft nichts mehr, dann ist es vorbei,
the fuck, ich hab echt keine Ahnung, was mit den Leuten los ist, wir sind dort kaum
dazu geguckt, fast 3 Stunden 40 on, schau mal auf die deutschen Twitter Trends, soll ich
das wirklich machen, oder wollt ihr noch mal meine Atemschutzmaske sehen, ok, Twitter
Trends Deutschland, was sind die Twitter Trends, Doppelpass, Mario Basler, Fußball, Fußball,
schönen Sonntag, Eiswein, Flüchtlinge, Toleranz, ja, Fußball halt, wir sind in Deutschland,
Fußball halt, und mal wieder eines der Lieblingsempörungsthemen auf Twitter schlechthin, Grenze, Erpressung,
Verstärkung, Drake, was macht der denn, FC Bayern, gut, Fußballtechnisch muss es ja
gestern wohl wirklich abgegangen sein, das hab sogar ich mitgekriegt, ihr wisst, ich
interessiere mich null für Fußball, dass sie entweder ein Fußballspiel fast abgesagt
hätten, oder abgesagt haben, irgendwas in der Richtung, aber mehr hab ich davon auch
nicht mitgekriegt, was macht eigentlich Corona so auf Twitter gerade, mal kurz gucken, Corona,
Virus.de, was gibt es da gerade Neues, gestern beim Einkaufen haben sich 2 Typen fast eingeschlagen
wegen einem Pack Wasser, da bin ich ja richtig froh, dass ich so ein Wassersprudler daheim
hab, und im Zweifelsfall einen ganzen Fischteich mit Wasser, das ich abkochen kann, Fußballtolleranz
und Flüchtlinge, Deutschland in der Nutshell, zumindest in den Twitter Trends, ok, was
gibt es denn hier, Corona, aktuell sind keine weiteren Verdachtsfälle gemeldet, gut es
ist Sonntag, da werden die Leute weniger krank, ok, nicht wirklich irgendwas spannendes Neues,
langweilig, Leute wir gucken uns jetzt noch ne Runde Battlefield an, brauchen wir ein
bisschen was zum Ausruhen, warum, was für Schwermetall, du meinst, weil es da reingeht,
weil es da reingeregnet hat, oder wie, Genossen bleibt standhaft, ja manche Leute, weiss
ich gerade, was mit denen los ist, außerdem wenn es hart auf hart kommt, ich hab noch die
Heizung im Keller, die hat einen 100, 130 Liter Tank, was, wo wir gerade beim Thema
Heizung sind, was macht eigentlich meine Heizung gerade, die Pumpe geht wieder nicht, die Pumpe
geht nicht, was macht der Druck im Keller, Moment Leute, ich muss mal gucken, was der
Druck im Keller macht, der ist ja fast unter 1 jetzt, ok, dann kein Wunder, dass die Pumpe
nicht pumpt, die kann wahrscheinlich nicht pumpen, weil der Druck zu gering ist, alter
der Heizungsband muss echt morgen kommen, das ist voll für ein Arsch, zum Glück hab
ich meine Klimaanlage, die auch heizen kann, nein, nein, nein, leider geht den Druck, der
Druck automatisch auslesen geht nicht, weil der Druck ist sehr analog, die Anzeige ist
analog und keiner der Sensoren von der Heizung bietet mir die Möglichkeit den Druck abzufragen,
ich hab hier sonst alles drin, was die Heizung ausliest, aber den Druck, der geht bloß per
Kamera, was das für eine Kamera ist, ganz so eine hier, das ist eine ChinaCam unter der
Haube, unter der Haube ist das eine ChinaCam, die übrigens viel günstiger ist, als man
das hier gerade sieht, der einzige Grund warum ich mir die Kamera gekauft habe, ist weil ich
die einmal im 10er Park bestellt hab, also die hier und die hier, und weil es dafür
eine Custom Firmware gibt, das ist die Custom Firmware die ich da drauf hab, ne, die Arbeit
da jetzt OpenCV drüber zu machen und Druck, ne, ne, ne, da hab ich kein Bock drauf, Bild
aus, ne, ne, man kann es auch übertreiben, man kann es auch übertreiben, zumal was hab
ich davon, ich hab nen Bild, ich hab nen Bild mit nem, wie nennt man dieses Ding, Manometer
drauf, ja, oder aber ich hätt nen Bild in meinem Kafana mit nem Manometer drauf, was
das analoge Manometer anzeigt, das macht keinen großen Unterschied, außerdem hoffe ich
ja, dass ich das bald nicht brauche, weil der Heizungsmann das repariert hat, man kann
es auch übertreiben, ihr wisst, ich sag so lang man kann es übertreiben bis ich es dann
übertreibe, wobei ich die Idee mit OpenCV echt gut finde, könnt man vielleicht mal
ausprobieren, so das ist die, das ist die Custom Firmware für die Kamera, das ganz
normale China Cam, musst du dich in deinem Haus eigentlich noch bewegen, ja, ja, ja,
leider, leider muss ich mich noch bewegen, ok, Battlefield, ah yes, excellent, bam, in
den Kopf, jetzt schreckt, Alter, Alter, wie sie da rum, wieder, wieder rumluben, kacke,
ist das hier ein React Stream, das hier ist ein BigBrain Stream, wenn du auch ein BigBrain
haben willst, kostet dich das einfach nur einen Prime Staffel, ich muss meine, ich
weiß Leute, ich muss meine Sellout Übergänge noch ein bisschen üben, aber Übung macht
den Meister, aber du darfst auch so da bleiben, Linus TechTapStore ist der beste, ist die
Überleitung Sellout der beste, ja, dass unser Hirnwirt wirklich steigt ins Unermessliche
langsam, Dankeschön für den Sub, Pure Savage 3, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön, es wird immer,
es wird immer, das Hirn, also der Chat heute ist wirklich schon, der Chat ist eigentlich
um ehrlich zu sein, ist der Chat, ist der Chat schon so, ja, also nachdem, der Hype Train
ist am Start, Leute, abonniert Stufe 1, sieben Monate, Chuck96, huge, Leute, der Hype Train
läuft, das ist gar maß, denn, Official Mathos, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön, Stufe 1 ist erreicht,
das ist, mich hat auch vorhin einer gefragt, so, was hat Amazon noch mit Twitch vor, diese
Sache, die sie jetzt eingeführt haben, mit dem Hype Train, genau solche Sachen werden
wir in Zukunft öfters auf Twitch sehen, in allen möglichen Varianten und Variationen,
einfach, weil das dazu führt, dass die Leute Geld auf Twitch ausgeben, der Scam Train,
und vielleicht schaffe ich es auch irgendwann mal in nächster Zeit, von den 20 oder 24
Emote Slots, mal ein paar neue auf Fiverr zu bestellen, anstatt die vier Emotes, die
wir schon irgendwie seit einem Jahr drinne haben, bis einer wenige so geblieben sind,
wie er ist, ja, nur ich mach zwar keinen Call of Duty mehr, aber ich habe halt den Vorteil
gehabt, an der näher Stelle muss ich auch mal sagen, auf YouTube, ich war halt schon
20 plus, als ich mit YouTube angefangen habe, und ich war quasi fertig, im Gegensatz zu
den anderen, die dann mit 14 angefangen haben, und quasi mit ihrem eigenen YouTube-Erfolg
aufgewachsen sind.
Wo ist eigentlich mal ein T-Shirt vom T-Shirt-Giveaway, im Zug, keine Ahnung, ich will nicht ausschließen,
dass ich nicht mal wirklich ein T-Shirt-Giveaway gemacht habe, aber ich habe eigentlich alles
immer verschickt bei einem Giveaway.
Kommen wir weiter bei der Show, nein da wäre ich nicht draufgekommen, da wäre ich nicht
draufgekommen, ich hätte gedacht, das ist hier, Hardware an der Heizung, Raspberry Pi
oder so, jetzt habe ich den Shot nicht gesehen, Aufwach-Stream-Kaffee-Tasse, oh, das ist eine
gute Idee.
Okay, das war nicht predicted, das kann mir keiner erzählen, dass das predicted war.
TROPSZZ sagt, ich warte immer noch auf meine 1000€ plus Xbox 360, ah yes, und ich warte
auf deinen Twitch Prime-Sub.
Ja, der Kommentator sagt echt immer das gleiche, jedes Mal, oh, der war cool, der war cool.
Ich meine, das ist halt übeles Glück, dass der sich auch nicht bewegt hat, aber das war
schon gut.
Warte, ein Zellot kurz, kann ich nicht überstehen, Blyeks, Blyekspress, oh warte, das steht
wahrscheinlich hinten und vorne, ich habe Dankeschön für den Sub, huge brain, also
Yuki, vielleicht, wenn du 25 plus bist, und da können wir mal probieren, weiblich 25 plus
und vielleicht auch irgendwo aus der Nähe von Frankfurt, da können wir mal probieren,
ob das theoretisch möglich wäre.
Muss aber kochen können, nee nee, nein, nein, Michael, jetzt hier, wenn das jetzt wieder
die falschen Leute lesen, Michael, im Chat, dann ist gleich die Abmahnung raus, ja, natürlich
müssen Frauen nicht kochen können.
Ich weiß nicht, wenn das jetzt schon der Flirt für dich war, aber der Michael ist eh zu
sehr mit seinem, was hat er letztens erzählt im Chat, dem, warte mal, wie war das, Michael,
ich kriege das nicht mal zusammen, was hast du letztens erzählt, der Virgin Simulator
oder irgendwas, ich weiß nicht, Virgin Law, du bist ja schon beschäftigt genug.
Das war die Geschichte, wo ich gesagt habe, du darfst dir einen Emote aussuchen und ich
bis heute keinen Emote, keinen Emote gepasst habe dafür.
Ach so, Version Manager war das, Version Manager, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja,
guckt ihr Moji an, wie er weiber auf Twitch, wer ist Moji, weiß nicht mal, wer Moji ist,
eh, er ist nur ein
I will gar nicht nachgucken, ehrlich gesagt.
Was hältst du eigentlich vom Modern Mellow von der Warfighter, ne, Warfighter, nix, da
kommen die Gegner aus dem Boden gefahren, wer sich noch dran erinnert.
Ich wollte das mit dem Friseur spielen, aber da ist es nie dazu gekommen.
Der Friseur spielt ja aktuell lieber Mobile Games, genau, das so sieht es aus.
Es stimmt überhaupt nicht, dass Shadowplay very buggy on PC ist. Shadowplay funktioniert wunderbar.
Oder Hintergrundchat, Leute, hört ihr das? Wir kommen halt am Start.
Ist Leggy das neue Blackscreen von damals, wenn der Aimbot zu hohen Foff hat?
Habe ich mir noch nie Gedanken drüber gemacht. Man könnte das allerdings sicherlich gut verstecken.
Ich dachte mir, oh Leute, es ruckelt gerade, es ruckelt gerade. Oh, jetzt soll ich mal den Aimbot ausschalten.
X-21, gibt es den Kram überhaupt noch? Warum ist denn das so laut?
Ja, gibt es mit Diamond Plus User.
Die Gegner sind immer wieder absolut auf Massive Brain ausgerichtet.
Das haben wir schon gesehen. Den Clip kennen wir schon, Leute. Das haben wir schon gesehen.
Oder? Den Clip kennen wir schon, aber die anderen Clips kann ich noch nicht.
Hat er die Clips etwa mehrfach verwendet?
Wir haben doch ein Video gemacht. Genau in dieser Konstellation haben wir mal ein Video aufgenommen.
Das ist schon ewig her.
Das war auch garantiert gestellt. Entweder stand er den ganzen Tag da und hat immer in die gleiche Richtung auf der gleichen Maps morse gespammt oder das war gestellt.
Ich tendiere zugestellt.
Ja, da haben wir danach, Michael, außer darüber zu sprechen, haben wir nichts mal gemacht in der Zeit.
Aber dazu müsste ich erstmal eh Videos machen auf YouTube.
Was? Hat er gerade gesagt, er ist nicht mehr drin?
Huge, huge snipe.
Wie kommt denn der mit? Wo gibt es denn auf locker überhaupt einen Quad?
Ach, das ist Conquest. Okay, gibt es auf Conquest Quads?
Drop. Ah, yes, excellent chat. Der Chat weiß Bescheid.
Das ist geil.
Also entweder war das gestellt, glaube ich in dem Fall nicht, oder die Gegner sind einfach komplett beschränkt.
Oder, aber sie wollten eben den Clip nicht versauen.
Gerade, gerade wo er hier gegen die Wand fährt, gerade wo er hier gegen die Wand fährt, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt fährt er hier gegen die Wand.
Der Typ ist down. Guck mal, der kann rückwärts fahren, der kann rückwärts fahren.
Da schießt nicht einer auf ihn, da schießt nicht einer auf ihn.
Was ist mit den Gegnern los? Komplett los, die Gegner.
Oh, cool.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob wir das nicht schon mal gesehen haben.
Ich muss nämlich sagen, das von den Rohren das runtergeschossene kam mir voll bekannt vor.
Der Quad, der Quad Kill kam mir nicht bekannt vor.
Und den Quad Kill, also mit dem Quad, also nicht der Quad, Quad, also ihr wisst was ich meine.
Den hätte ich mir gemerkt.
Ja gut, es ist Metro und Battlefield 4, da spielt kaum einer.
Oh, da werden sie weggesprayt.
Da werden sie weggesprayt.
Ich sehe überhaupt keinen Gegner. Ich habe überhaupt nicht erkannt.
Ja gut, Spotting FTW.
Doch, ich enjoye das richtig in Battlefield 4.
Da muss man einfach nur richtig stehen und dann werden die Gegner weggebashed.
Also das Spotten, kann sich noch einer daran erinnern, wie das Spotten in Bad Company 1 war.
Das war ja leider eine Console-only-Release.
Das Spotten in Bad Company 1 war nahezu komplett useless.
Du musstest den Gegner irgendwie 10 Sekunden oder so durchs Scope angucken.
Wo es ganz praktisch war mit dem Fernklaas.
Wenn die nämlich einfach eine Granate reinwerfen.
Welche Bewegungsmelder gab es auch noch?
Die Waffe sieht man sehr gut.
Heute sind viele Lockerclips dabei.
Ganz ehrlich, in dieser Situation muss ich überhaupt nicht lange überlegen, was ich mache.
Ich spraye einfach so lange in die Gegner rein, bis die gecheckt haben, wo ich bin und mich schon prefire, oder dann gehe ich weg.
Aber die Gegner haben keinen Bock, ihn zu prefiren.
Oder zumindest in die Richtung zu gucken, wo er gleich herkommt.
Das ist zu advanced für das Gegner.
Das war so ein nice Game.
Persönlich ist mir Bad Company 2 und Battlefield 3 immer noch ein Ticken lieber, aber Battlefield 4 ist mittlerweile echt da ganz gut oben mit dabei.
Leider gab es danach kein Battlefield mehr für mich, was mir gefallen hat.
Das ist die Pick-up-Sniper, oder?
Ich habe es gerade nicht erkannt.
Das ist die, die man aufsammeln muss.
Michael, das ist eine richtig gute Idee.
Das hatten wir schon vor ein paar Streams, aber dazu müsste ich halt erstmal Videos machen.
Das stimmt, das stimmt nicht.
Du hast vollkommen recht, dass die Videos nicht großer Aufwand wären.
Aber ich kriege es ja auch schon jetzt gerade nicht in Videos zu machen, die auch nicht großer Aufwand wären.
Ohne Leute, kriegen wir jetzt mal Frage an den Chat.
Ich weiß nicht, wie viele Leute von euch noch Battlefield 4 spielen.
Würden wir es schaffen, aus dem Chat eine Battlefield-Top-Place-Montage zu machen, die, sagen wir mal, so 6-7 Minuten geht?
Battlefield 3? Also alles bis Battlefield 1.
Okay, Leute, wir machen das.
Ich überlege gerade, wie wir das am besten machen.
Ich bräuchte irgendeinen Google Docs, wo man den Kram...
Es muss ja auch keiner sich installieren und spielen.
Wir machen das ja vielleicht noch öfter aus, wenn das jetzt gut funktioniert.
Lasst ruhig erstmal die Leute einschicken, die schon fertige Clips haben.
Wir machen das jetzt.
Also ich lege jetzt mal einen Google Docs an.
Oh fuck, ich muss mir das mal einloggen.
Und dann uns... oh nee, uns onstream schneiden kann ich ja onstream nicht.
Vielleicht, okay, Google Docs.
Yep, login.
Next.
Looks remind me later.
So, ich lege jetzt mal ein Google Docs Dokument an, wo man den Kram eintragen kann.
In der Zwischenzeit lasse ich mal kurz das hier weiterlaufen, dass ich was zu gucken habe.
Ja, los.
Forms.
Okay, okay.
Also wir machen das so, Leute. Ich lege jetzt eine Google Forms an.
Und das einzige, was man eintragen muss, ist quasi Autor, Spieler bzw. Link zum YouTube-Channel oder so, was ich verlinken soll.
Und den Link zum Download.
Das reicht ja im Endeffekt auch.
Ich muss jetzt mal kurz gucken, wie ich das mache.
Question?
Der Eichler hostet mich jetzt. Gibt's nicht auch noch? Der Eichler. Lange nicht gesehen.
Link gehört auf Twitter.
Äh, nicht Twitter. Dings hier. Twitch. Der Eichler ist am Start.
Natürlich, Michael. Selbstverständlich.
Ich muss gerade noch mal kurz... Okay, wir nennen die Form BF Top Plays.
Vax FPS BF Top Plays. Gameplay einschicken.
Darma.
Short Answer.
Verlinkung.
Und Options.
Options. Link zum Gameplay.
Okay. Probieren wir mal aus, ob das funktioniert.
Ich weiß, dass da... Ich fand's so cool, weil ich gerade gesehen hab, dass du mich gehostet hast.
Okay. Ähm, ich speicher die Form mal.
Wie, wir speichern wir hier safe? Nee.
Ich bin zu dumm, Google Forms zu bedienen, Leute. Das ist, das ist unglaublich.
Share Link.
Copy.
Okay, mal gucken. Mal k... Leute, mal gucken, ob die Form funktioniert.
Massive.
Okay, Shorten... Shorten-Uhrl ist besser.
Okay.
Testen wir mal, ob das funktioniert.
Name, Max, Verlinkung.
Link zum Gameplay.
Submit.
Okay, your response has been recorded.
Wo sehe ich denn jetzt, wer darauf geantwortet hat?
Also Leute, es hat keinen Sinn, da jetzt was drauf zu machen, wenn man...
Ah, responses. Ich hab's. Easy.
Na super. Nice.
Moment, das funktioniert nicht. Das ist kaputt.
Ich glaube, oh, oh, ich glaube, ich hab's falsch gemacht.
Wenn ich jetzt nämlich hier Max 2 eingebe, Verlinkung, äh, keine Ahnung, Google.de, dann sehe ich nicht, wer von was erstellt hat.
Oh fuck.
Oh nee, das ist kaputt, das geht nicht.
Ich kann damit nichts anfangen.
Shit.
Alter, es gibt sich... Ich bin zu dumm für Google Forms, Alter.
Oh man.
Wobei doch, natürlich bringt mir die Antwort was.
Doch klar, funktioniert. Alles gut, funktioniert Leute.
Eats. Ja, Link.
Okay, also Leute, wenn ihr Clips habt, könnt ihr einschicken. Ich schick euch nochmal in den Chat den Link, Shared Link.
Also wer Clips hat, haut rein. Wie viele Clips? Ihr dürft so viele Clips senden.
Also nee, nee, nee, das mach ich nicht. Chat, ich weiß es.
Maximal erst mal 5 Clips pro Person, weil ich will da ein bisschen Variation drinne haben und sonst wird's zu viel.
Maximal erst mal 5 Clips. Was ihr machen könnt, ist, wenn ihr mehrere Clips habt, mal angenommen, ihr habt irgendwie richtig geile 30 Sekunden Clips oder sowas.
Dann könnt ihr die zusammen machen. Keine Ahnung, so 2-3 Minuten Clip und den als einzelnen Clip hochladen.
Haben wir einen Mod am Start? Ah, Serious Maxis, da könntest du ein Bot-Command erzeugen, wenn du weißt, wie das funktioniert, zu dem Form.
Maximale Länge pro Clip, naja, nachdem es kurze Clips, also Top Plays sind, sollte das mit maximal so 2 Minuten gehen.
Also halt einen zusammenhängenden Clip, wo gebashed wird. Eine komplette Runde muss man da nicht schicken.
Und es sollte schon so geschnitten sein, dass ich da nicht erst noch eine halbe Stunde an jedem Clip rumeditieren muss.
Also das sollte ungefähr dort anfangen, wo das gute Play kommt und da ungefähr aufhören, wo das gute Play zu Ende ist.
Ein bisschen kürzen kann ich's immer noch. Oh, das wird geil, da hab ich echt Bock drauf jetzt.
Äh, wie soll der heißen? Äh, nennen wir's... Chat, gute Idee. Nennen wir's... Place, Battlefield, äh... BF Place?
Ja, BF, Battlefield, ein gutes kurzes Command. Battle Plays, oh Battle Plays ist cool. Battle Plays, Komfix kennt sich aus, äh.
Mach Ausrufezeichen Battle Plays, das find ich gut. Das ist huge.
Ok, soll ich mal funktionieren? Soll ich mal gucken, ob da Leute... Ja, es haben schon Leute was eingeschickt hier.
Responses. Von Foxdutzen. Link zum Gameplay.
Ok, schauen wir mal, ob die ganzen Sachen funktionieren. Wahrscheinlich hat er jetzt einen Rickroll eingeschickt.
Und Leute, seht davon ab, ich weiß, sobald man das sagt, machen's die Leute, seht davon ab, Blödsinn einzuschicken.
Wenn das nämlich zu viele Leute machen, wird das mit dem Video nix. Und außerdem...
Derjenige, der Fakes einschickt, über den bin ich zumindest nicht erfreut.
Wenn er mir da noch weiter im Chat auf den Sack geht, batte ich jeder. Weil da hab ich keinen Bock drauf, quasi mir die einzelnen guten Sachen rauszusuchen zu müssen zwischen Bullshit.
Ähm, das muss nicht sein. Muss man einen Google Account dafür haben? Nee, brauchst du nicht.
So, das hat grad hier mal eingeschickt. Gucken wir uns das mal an.
Pup. Oh, oh, mit, mit, mit Slow-Mo, mit Slow-Mo.
Ok, also, dann machen wir das. Das ist eine coole Idee, da hab ich echt Bock drauf.
Man muss, man muss aber dazu sagen, der ist gleich mal Disclaimer. Gleich, gleich, gleich mal ein Disclaimer.
Ähm, ich behalte mir vor, nicht alle Clips zu verwenden, die eingeschickt werden.
Also, es kann durchaus sein, dass wenn manche Clips nicht reinpassen, ich die nicht nehme, aber ich versuche alles so weit zu verarbeiten, wie es, wie es kommt.
Sind Fail-Clips auch erlaubt? Kommt auf den Clip an, kann ich jetzt, kann ich jetzt schwer sagen.
Aber, ähm, vielleicht soll als ein oder andere, der ein oder andere Gag zwischendurch...
Ist das glaube ich schon ganz nice.
So, hier haben wir einen Link, sehr gut.
Huge.
Heißt das wirklich immer noch Untitled Form?
Nee, Max FPS BF Top Plays.
Pok.
Nice, nice, da hab ich Bock drauf. Guck mal, ob dabei was rumkommt.
Ähm, und dann, dann setz ich mich dran und mach... Ich glaube, da freuen sich die Leute auf YouTube auch drüber.
Wenn es einfach mal wieder nice Battlefield, Battlefield Gameplays gibt.
Also das ist, das ist eine coole Sache, das machen wir.
Und, ähm, wenn das dann, wenn das gut...
Wenn das, wenn das gut funktionieren sollte, dann krieg ich bestimmt auch über YouTube ein paar weitere Clips, ja.
Äh, achso, äh, welche Spiele?
Also prinzipiell würde ich sagen, ähm, erst mal alles bis Battlefield 1.
Allerdings, ich würde die Ausnahme machen, weil ich mein, es ist immerhin Battlefield.
Ich hätte auch keinen Schmerzen damit, äh, ab und zu einen Battlefield 1 oder einen Battlefield 5 Clip rein zu machen.
Aber ich würde gerne mal, so die ersten 1, 2 Folgen, oder zumindest die erste Folge, erst mal, ähm, erst mal gucken, wie es ankommt.
Also, ähm, wenn ihr richtig geile, also sowas hier in der Richtung, wie wir uns hier angeguckt haben, ähm, in Battlefield 1 und 5 habt, oder Hardline, oder was auch immer, könnt ihr die auch erst mal posten.
Ich persönlich hab mehr Bezug zu Battlefield 3, 4 und Bad Company.
Aber wenn ihr richtig, richtig krasse Battlefield 1, äh, oder Battlefield 5, oder Hardline, oder sonst was Clips habt, könnt ihr die auch posten.
Und dann muss ich mal gucken, was wir, was wir da draus machen.
Poggers.
Schauen wir mal.
So.
Also, mit Ausrufezeichen, ähm, was war es, Battle Plays, kriegt ihr den Link zum Formular.
Ähm, wenn ich mit dem Stream fertig bin, schreibe ich noch, schreibe ich vielleicht noch irgendwie was drunter.
Ähm, was, kann man da irgendwie noch ne, ah hier, Battlefield.
Okay, ich schreibe, ich schreibe noch mal oben drüber, ähm, was man, äh, was, was man da für Game Plays, also, Game Plays sollten von, sagen wir so, 30 Sekunden bis, äh, 2 Minuten pro Clip.
Äh, also pro Clip, 30 Sekunden bis 2 Minuten, äh, alle Battlefield Games erlaubt.
Bevor, ne, bevorzum, aber gar nicht, hör mal, alle Battlefield Games erlaubt.
Ihr wisst, dass ich persönlich halt mehr Bezug habe zu den älteren Teilen.
Ähm, aber, und ich kann halt auch vor allem ältere Teilen etwas besser kommentieren, weil ich halt das Game kenne.
Ähm, bevorzugt die älteren vor BF1.
Hallo, ich kann nicht mal richtig tippen.
Die älteren vor Battlefield 1.
Okay.
Gut.
Fehlt noch ne, ne Spalte, naja, du kannst, du kannst dein Name eintragen, die Verlinkung.
Äh, ach so, bei Verlinkung, das soll ich vielleicht aktualisieren. Mit Verlinkung ist gemeint, den Channel, also was ich von euch verlinken soll.
Äh, das aktualisieren wir nochmal schnell.
Spielername.
Ähm, Spieler-Channel oder...
Spieler-Channel oder...
Link.
Oder, oder, äh... äh...
Ne, nicht Profil, wie nenne ich das denn? Spieler-Channel oder...
Link.
Oder, oder, äh...
Ne, nicht Profil, wie nenne ich das denn? Spieler... äh...
Link, Link für Credits, ha? Credits, sowas oder was man.
Für die Credits.
Ja.
Link zum Gameplay, okay, sehr gut.
Okay, sollte, sollte es eigentlich funktionieren.
Äh, hat sich der...
Hat sich der Link jetzt geändert, dadurch, dass ich die Form geändert hab?
Ne, ist immer noch...
Ist das, ist der Link jetzt anders als vorher?
Oh Gott, ich und Google Docs, äh...
Ich und Google Docs. Na klar ist der Link anders, ich seh das doch sofort, äh.
Der Link ist nicht der gleiche.
Ich hab gerade den neuen Link gepostet. Okay, perfekt. Okay, hat's funktioniert.
Okay, dann ist es egal, dann, dann lass, dann lass es so, dann lass so.
Okay, mal gucken.
Okay, mal gucken. Tatsächlich, okay, dann ist es egal, wunderbar.
Was ist mit sieben Kills in zehn Sekunden? Na klar, hau rein, hau rein.
Hau rein.
Im Zweifelsfall spiel ich den Clip einfach doppelt ab.
Oder du machst noch ein bisschen was da vorne. Schickt einfach mal ein.
Erstmal nicht so sehr, also nicht so 100%ig das, was ich reingeschrieben hab.
Wenn es ein bisschen plus, minus, paar Sekunden, ist es auch nicht so wild.
Hauptsache, dass wir ein bisschen Gameplay zusammen kriegen.
Und dann schau ich mal, was man draus machen kann.
Mal gucken wir uns den Rest hier vor noch an.
Ach ja, übrigens, Plattform ist mir auch egal.
Boah, äh gut, also, das war nice.
Boah.
Ja, vielleicht ist ja auch außer Wasser nichts, nicht vieles.
50 Minuten, 90 Killstreak.
Ähm, ja, das ist zu lang. Dann musst du, dann schneit, dann schneit doch einfach das Beste raus.
Ja, du kannst auch ohne Probleme da eine 2 Minuten Montage draus, also eine Montage in Form von halt, dass du 2 Minuten lang die besten Clips da rausschneidest.
Das ist auch okay.
Aber ich will halt nicht aus 50, weil da komm ich, da komm ich, wäre ich ja nie fertig mit dem Video.
Ich will nicht aus 50 Minuten mir das selbst raussuchen müssen.
Ach ja, stimmt, das muss ich noch reinposten.
Keine Musik.
Wenn da, wenn da Copyright-Musik im Hintergrund ist, kann ich nicht verwenden.
Oder, oder ohne Sounds, aber ohne Sounds ist doof.
Ähm, das muss ich noch unbedingt reinschreiben.
Summary, Summary.
Keine Copyright, nee überhaupt keine, keine Musik im Hintergrund.
Sonst YouTube-Strike von KS-Strike.
Okay, ich hab noch mal eingetragen.
Sind ohne Sounds okay?
Es ist zwar nicht schön, aber wenn's ein geiler, richtig nicer Clip ist, geht's auch ohne Sound.
Jetzt sagt er nix mehr oder was, weil er gemeint hat eben, äh, Clip ohne Commentary.
Der kann auch so ein Standard, sein Standardgezeug hier wieder ablassen.
Kiyokonas war mir klar.
Aber auch bitte kein Hentai im Hintergrund.
Einfach nicht, was Copyright Probleme macht im Hintergrund.
Was ist denn ein gutes Schnittprogramm, wo ich nicht zahlen muss wegen Ausprobieren und so?
Keine Ahnung.
Da Vinci Resolve ist das nicht übertrieben kompliziert?
Du kannst einfach mit FFmpeg was wegschneiden vorher, musst du nicht mal re-encoden.
Okay, dann kommen wir den Weg nicht mehr.
Äh, das ist ja langweilig.
Also blöd.
So, ich seh schon die ersten Einsendungen sind am Start hier.
Die ersten Einsendungen sind am Start.
Tribolon, genau solche Clips mein ich.
Genau sowas, einfach ne Minute lang, wo die Gegner gebashed werden.
Huge.
Zeig mal den Clip, äh, den Clip gibt's dann im Video.
Da können wir uns sehen, wenn wir uns jetzt die Clips alle im Video hier im Stream angucken, ist ja auch doof.
Aber Michael, ich muss sagen, das war ne gute Idee.
Vielleicht komm ich so dazu, mal wieder ne Runde YouTube-Videos zu machen.
Je nachdem, wie viele Clips heute noch kommen, ähm, vielleicht auch, vielleicht heute noch.
Also zumindest das Video aufnehmen, aber ich glaube dafür haben wir nicht genug.
Kann man bisschen, bisschen, äh, zu wenig Leute, die noch Battlefield spielen auf, ähm.
Bekommst du 3k Q-Chat-Punkte? Würde ich dir geben, aber man kann leider keine Punkte giften.
Ah, letztes Video ist ja schon wieder ewig her.
Vier Monate, Alter, vier Monate.
Ähm, bevor ich aufgehe, Leute, ich bin jetzt ja schon eine ganze Weile am Start, bevor ich aufgehe.
Wollen wir das erst mal, wollen wir das erst mal Twitch Only lassen?
Oder soll ich's auf Twitter posten? Das Formular. Was meint ihr?
Wollen wir erst mal gucken, ob, ob wir mit Twitch, Twitch und, und, ähm, Battlefield-Spielern hier auf Twitch die erste Folge voll kriegen?
Ich würde sagen, wir gucken erst mal, was zusammenkommt hier über, über Twitch.
Oder was meint ihr? Chat.
Warum geht der Link nicht mehr? Äh.
Was?
Der Link geht nicht mehr?
Doch.
Der Link geht noch.
Guck hier. Der Link geht.
Quatsch mit so, so poste mal, also.
Leute, könnt ihr mal probieren, ob der Link bei euch geht? Also bei mir ist kein, kein Problem. Funktioniert.
Geht bei mir.
Du lebst ja noch, ja.
Das ist der Link, in den du da im Linux einrichtest.
Ja gut, ey. Keine Ahnung, warum der nicht mehr geht. Wahrscheinlich ist das Video zu alt.
Check. W.
Geht, geht, geht. Okay, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Was bringen die Q-Chat-Punkte? Du kannst mit den Q-Chat-Punkten zum Beispiel deine Nachricht hervorheben lassen hier.
So zum Beispiel.
Das ist eigentlich ein ganz cooles Twitch-Feature.
50.000 Q-Chat-Punkte. Ai, ai, ai. Dafür könnt ihr ja fast schon mal eine Maske hier bestellen.
Ne, leider kriegt man von Q-Chat-Punkten, leider gibt es keine Möglichkeit, Q-Chat-Punkte in, ähm, echte, in Cent umzurechnen.
Dann hätte ich bei, ich glaube bei Dance-Gaming habe ich auch schon irgendwie 60k oder irgendwie 50k oder irgendwie massig, ja.
Aber ich finde das ist eine echt gute, gute Idee mit dem, mit dem Battlefield, ähm.
Wer kam eben noch mal auf die Idee Battle-Plays zu machen?
Irgendwas mit C glaube ich am Anfang.
Wer kam da eben noch mal auf die Idee?
Comfix? War das Comfix? Ah hier, Comfix 21, genau.
Wie bist du auf Ideen gekommen? Einfach spontan oder, oder gibt es das schon? Battle-Plays.
Ok, nicht wirklich, oder? Nichts großartiges Bekanntes.
Ne, anscheinend nicht. Aber es ist eine gute Idee gewesen.
TF.
Ok, ähm, Leute, es war schön, dass so viele dabei waren heute. Ähm, gucken wir mal, ob das mit den Clips, ob da was zusammenkommt.
Wenn nicht werde ich im nächsten Stream noch mal ein bisschen, ein bisschen das ganze rumpasten und ein bisschen erwähnen.
Denkt dran, Ausrufezeichen Battle-Plays gibt's den Link zum Formular.
Ich komm die Top-Plays gut an, da kannst du ja auch auf YouTube nach Clips fragen. Jaja, ich mach das dann auf jeden Fall auf YouTube in die, ähm, in das Kommentar von dem Video.
Aber wir müssen erstmal initial, guck mal, oben rechts, oben rechts, äh, oben rechts, essen, immer oben rechts essen.
Das ist doch, das ist doch schön, Michael. Auch wenn es wahrscheinlich Debated ist.
Aber es ist schön, wenn es dir gefällt. Ähm, und, äh, mir gefällt's auch. Wenn da mal gucken, was da rauskommt am Ende.
Soll ich's mal im Discord pausen? Kannst du machen? Kannst du, ist eine gute Idee. Kannst du machen. Ähm, kann man im Discord irgendwas pinnen?
Mega-Quest. Der Name kommt mir noch bekannt vor. Gibt's den noch?
Der kommt mir bekannt vor. Der Name. Jo Leute.
Okay, gibt's den halt nicht mehr.
Musst du oder sie warum machen? Was pinnen? Okay, das probier jetzt mal aus im Discord, ob man das pinnen kann. Gucken, wie man Sachen im Discord pinnt. Hab ich noch nie gemacht.
Ich muss erst mal alle Updates installieren. Leute, ich muss euch mal ausblenden. Wer weiß in welchem Fenster ich im Discord gerade rauskomme.
Oh, oh.
Okay, passt. Man weiß ja nie.
Okay, allgemein.
Ach so.
Hat eine nach, das ging doch, oder?
Und wo sieht man das jetzt angepinnt?
Ach hier.
Okay, nice, nice, sehr schön.
Sehr nice. Ja, mal gucken, was so alles zusammenkommt. Schauen wir mal. Haben wir schon einige Leute geschrieben, die sind noch aktiv hier am Battlefield spielen.
Jetzt haben wir schon sechs Einsendungen, aber davon sind zwei Stück oder drei Stück von mir zum Testen.
Ich habe insgesamt sechs Anfragen, aber drei Stück sind von mir vom Testen.
Gucken wir mal, wir haben ein bisschen Zeit. Ist ja nicht, ist ja nicht so, dass das irgendwie jetzt übers Knie gebrochen werden muss.
Meins rennt gerade. Ja, wie gesagt, Leute, wenn wir da genug zusammenkriegen, nehme ich vielleicht heute Mittag schon auf.
Aber ich denke mal, wir werden ein bisschen länger Zeit brauchen, bis da genug zusammen sind. Ich lasse mich mal überraschen.
Aber ich habe da auf jeden Fall jetzt gerade spontan echt Bock, das zu machen.
Wer das mit den Gameplays hinhaut.
Peilst du dann so zehn Minuten an? Ich würde in dem Dreh, ich würde mal sagen so fünf bis zehn Minuten. Also wenn ich über fünf Minuten habe, würde ich aufnehmen.
Du willst doch nur easy Views. Wer will das nicht?
Hast du echt nur vor Battlefield zu machen? Bevor ich mir über weitere Sachen Gedanken mache, mache ich jetzt erst mal ein Battlefield Top Play Video.
Vielleicht mache ich dann auch mal ein paar andere, aber ich habe von dir schon fünf Minuten.
Da muss ich gucken, dass noch ein paar andere Leute eingestreut kriege, weil nur von einem Spieler. Die Hexe hat bestimmt auch noch ein paar Sachen.
Das kommt sowieso in die Trends, ich weiß ja nicht.
Was mache ich denn für einen Sound in den Hintergrund? Einfach Battlefield Soundtrack am besten.
Einfach Battlefield Soundtrack im Hintergrund. Ein bisschen Soundtrack im Hintergrund ist der Sound von den Clips klar, aber ein bisschen im Hintergrund finde ich schon nicht verkehrt.
Oder ich weiß, was ich im Hintergrund mache. Nein, das mache ich nicht wirklich im Hintergrund, aber das wäre doch mal was.
Beste Battlefield Hintergrund Musik überhaupt.
Ich werde schon was ordentliches finden. Ich werde schon was ordentliches finden.
Da brauche ich Clips, dass das funktioniert.
Exzellent.
Okay Leute, also schon mal danke für alle, die was einschicken. Wenn ihr das Formular sucht, Ausrufezeichen, Battle Plays, dann zeigt euch der Link zum Formular.
Heute noch jemand Rain, das ist glaube ich keiner on, den ich kenne. Und der Viewer brauchen würde.
Haben wir da irgendjemand on?
Das war eskalierend.